HEARING AS A JOINT HEARING WITH
THE SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE. WE
WILL TAKE ROUGHLY TWO HOURS TO
DISCUSS THE STATE'S RECENT
INVESTMENTS IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS TO GET
AN UPDATE ON THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THAT FUNDING AND TO LEARN
ABOUT THE LOCAL EXPERIENCE WITH
THESE INVESTMENTS. AFTER THAT WE
WILL ADJOURN AND TAKE A ROUGHLY
FIVE MINUTE RECESS BEFORE WE
RECONVENE AND BEGIN OUR STANDARD
BUDGET HEARING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE. IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVE IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY
SENATOR WIENER WILL BE JOINING
US REMOTELY THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE IS JOINING US IN
PERSON. THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE ALSO PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY SO FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZE THAT YOU USE THE RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM
AND EACH TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
TO SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ON MUTE PLEASE SELECT ON
MUTE. BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING.
OUR IT PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON YOU WHEN YOU ARE DONE.
ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME. AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING
ROOM. TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT WHICH WILL OCCUR AT BOTH
THE END OF THE JOINT HEARING AND
AT THE END OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARING THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. 844-291-4185 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. NINE FOUR ONE SEVEN
FIVE ONE SO WRITE THAT DOWN. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES THEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DAN DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. BUT I KNOW
YOU CAN DO IT ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR MIND NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT
IN THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR
TO CALLYOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT
TIME YOU WILL BE A MUTED AND YOU
ARE NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY. AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU NEED TO MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU.
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HERE. AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTE.
LASTLY BUT PHYSICALLY HERE TODAY
PLEASE KEEP YOUR MASKS ON
COVERING YOUR NOSE AND YOUR
MOUTH. AT ALL HI. BEFORE WE
BEGIN WITH OUR JOINT HEARING I'D
LIKE TO SAY A FEW WORDS IT IS NO
SECRET. AT THE STATE IS FACING A
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGE
TO PUT IT MILDLY. WE ARE ONE OF
THE MOST EXPENSIVE HOUSING
MARKETS IN THE COUNTRY AND IT'S
ONE OF THE MOST CITED CONCERNS
AMONG OUR CONSTITUENTS FROM THE
TIPPY TOP OF THE STATE TO THE TO
BE TO BE BOTTOM. CLOSELY RELATED
TO A HOUSING AFFORDABILITY WE
ARE DEALING WITH A HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS WITH HOMELESS POPULATIONS
SEEMING TO GROW YEAR AFTER YEAR
ALONG WITH ALL OF OUR
FRUSTRATIONS. IN RESPONSE THE
STATE HAS INVESTED SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES AND MY DISTRICT WE'D
SAY BUKU DOLLARS IN ADDRESSING
BOTH OF THESE ISSUES OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS INCLUDING
NEARLY FIVE BILLION WITH A B.
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING LAST
YEAR. AND TWELVE BILLION WITH A
B. FOR A VARIETY OF SOLUTIONS TO
HOMELESSNESS OVER TWO YEARS AS
PART OF THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET. THIS HEARING IS
GOING TO GIVE US A CHANCE TO
REVIEW THOSE INVESTMENTS. I E.
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OTHERS GOING
BACK TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO SEE
WHAT WE HAVE ACCOMPLISHED WITH
THAT FUNDING AND WHAT LESSONS WE
HAVE LEARNED THAT WE CAN APPLY
TO THIS YEAR'S ONGOING BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS SO THIS IS ABOUT
THE PAST AND THE PRESENT TO
INFORM US ABOUT THE FUTURE. I
THANK THE SENATE HOUSING
COMMITTEE AND THEY'RE CHAIR
SENATOR WIENER FOR JOINING US
TODAY TO DISCUSS THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND NOW I WOULD LIKE TO
OFFER MY CO CHAIR. SENATOR
WIENER PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
THE CHANCE TO SAY A FEW WORDS
SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND- THANK YOU
FOR THOSE ARE REMARKS AND IT'S A
PLEASURE AS ALWAYS SO TO WORK
WITH WITH YOU- SO. THIS IS A
VERY POOR HEARING- AND I'M
REALLY GLAD THAT WE ARE JOINING
FORCES. TO CONDUCT THIS
OVERSIGHT TODAY. STUDENTS FROM
WE KNOW TELL FOR IS IN A- HOUSE
CRISIS DRIVEN BY A MAN. HOUSING
SHORT- WE'RE SHORT SOMEWHERE BUT
- A ONE IN A AND A HALF HOME
THANKS WERE DATA YOU LOOK- BUT
REALLY. DOESN'T MATTER IT'S
AMASSED. I SHORTAGE THE EXACT.
NUMBER IS AND WE KNOW THAT BIG
CHUNK OF THOSE I'M NOT SURE- ONE
OF TAKEN OFF OF THE ABOVE
APPROACH EVERY KIND OF KNOWLEDGE
- MARKET RATE AFFORDABLE. TO USE
OUR STUDENT HOUSING SENIOR
HOUSING ETCETERA ETCETERA- WE
THAT. A GOOD CHUNK OF THOSE
MILLIONS OF POUNDS OF SHORT OR
AND- WILL RECALL FOR THE HOUSING
THE FOR OUR LOW INCOME.
RESIDENTS TWO- HOW THAT IS SO
SORT- SORT OF WE ARE. YOUR
INCOME LEVEL THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
OF HAVING A IS. I'M BECOMING
HOMELESS AND- AS- I CHECKED
LONGER NOTED WE HAVE. THE STATE
IS MISSING INVESTMENT YEARS I
THINK IT'S A- TO ALWAYS ROOM.
LITTLE WE HAVE TREATED. TREATED
HOUSING- AND I ALWAYS I FOR THE
UP IN THE BACK- YOUNG FAMILIES
I'M NOT QUITE CERTAIN WHAT THEIR
CHARACTERS TO HOSPITAL HOUSING
FOR THEIR FAMILY YOUNG PEOPLE
NOT BEING ABLE TO. STAY IN THE
COMMUNITY WHERE THEY GREW UP ON
PEOPLE WHO ARE OVERCROWDED
HOUSING AND WE SAW THE RESULTS
DURING CORPORATE OF WHAT IT
MEANS TO HAVE OVERCROWDED
HOUSING EXPENSES SPREAD J. JONES
FIVE NEWSROOMS OF LONG COMMUTES. ALMOST US. EVERY PROBLEM THAT
WE PRETTY MUCH OF CALIFORNIA ALL
ALL OF. NEVER STOCKS WERE-
HEALTH POLICY. AND SO THIS IS A
STATE IS AND REQUIRE STATE
PRECIPITATION THE STATE APPROACH
. AND SO IT'S GREAT STATE IS
BROWN'S. ON STAGE INVESTMENT IN
A HOUSING TO PARTNER WITH OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO BUILD MORE
OF THIS I HOUSING WE HAVE TO DO
A LOT MORE- BUT WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT REYES ARE MADE ARE.
INCREASED OUR INVESTMENTS BY
SIGNIFICANTLY AND IT'S TRICKS
TAKE A LOOK TODAY- HOW IS THAT
GOING BUT IN TERMS OF ACTUALLY
CREATING A HOUSING. ON ONE THING
THAT WE WERE SURE ABOUT WHICH IS
A REAL FOCUS FOR ME IS IT'S NOT
ENOUGH. JUST TO INVEST. MONEY WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
MONEY IS BEING DEPLOYED AND
HOUSING IS ACTUALLY. GETTING
BILL IF IT'S SITTING FOUR FIVE
SEVEN YEAR. TO GET AFFORDABLE
HOW BILLS EVEN THE MONEY IS
PLACE. THE END OF MY DOING. I
MEAN BUT- WE HAVE A HIS. AND
HELP. OF ALLOWING IT TO TAKE
MANY YEAR. FIGURE OUT HOW
APPROVED. AND THEN I'M
PARTICULARLY FOR HEALTH. IN
PARTICULAR FOR I WENT WHEN WE
HAVE TO DELAYS CHRIS NEWS AL
DOESN'T EXIST FOR A LONG TIME IT
ALSO MAKES IT. MORE TO BUILD NOW
. NUMBER TICKER FOR HOUSING WHAT
IT TAKES MANY YEARS TO GET A
PERMIT BECAUSE OF NIMBY
OPPOSITION OR RED TAPE OR
WHATEVER- THAT COULD BE THE
DEATH OF THAT PROJECT CAUSE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS
DON'T HAPPEN MASSIVE CASH
MARGINS. CUSTER SERVICE TO BE
ABLE TO. THEMSELVES WE SEE
AROUND THE STATE OF THESE
PROJECTS THAT CITY OFFER EVER.
BOND SO IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO
BILL THAT I INTRODUCED AS A
BRAND NEW CENTER WITH SENATE
BILL THIRTY FIVE. WHICH WAS
PASSED AND SIGNED INTO LAW THE
YEAR- THAT STREAMLINES HOUSING
APPROVALS IT HAS BEEN A HUGE
HUGE. FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
PARTICULAR AND HAS FROM ALLIANCE
IT CONVERSELY. WITH PLANNING THE
- AND WITH A NONPROFIT THE BILL
BEFORE BY HOUSING ON BECAUSE
SIGNIFICANTLY. ACCELERATED
APPROVAL OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BY TAKING A PROCESS THAT USUALLY
WOULD TAKE YEARS SOMETIMES MANY
YEARS I'M TURNING INTO MONTHS TO
GET THIS MONEY WE'RE INVESTING
DEPLOYED ON THE GROUND CONVERTED
INTO HOUSING FOR. REAL HUMAN
BEINGS AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
AND SO I AM DEFINITELY
INTERESTED IN HEARING TODAY
ABOUT THESE PROCESS ISSUES AND
HOW THINGS ARE GOING SO AGAIN MY
ANSWER THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
LOOK. FORWARD TO TODAY'S HEARING
. THANK YOU FOR THOSE INJURED
WERE- YES THIS WILL BE A VERY
IMPORTANT HEARING BECAUSE I
THINK WE ALL WANT TO KNOW WHERE
WE NEED TO GET OUT OF THE WAY
AND WHERE WE NEED TO LEAN IN-
BUT THIS IS OUR OPPORTUNITY TO
LOOK UNDER THE HOOD. SO WE'RE
GONNA GET THIS PARTY STARTED AND
THIS IS HOW IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
THERE'S GOING TO BE TWO PANELS.
OUR FIRST PANEL WILL CONSIST OF
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. THE CALIFORNIA
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS. THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. AND THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY. AFTER
THAT WE ARE GOING TO HEAR FROM
ADVOCATES DEVELOPERS. AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN OUR SECOND PANEL.
SO LET'S START OUR FIRST PANEL
HEARINGS. FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. AND WE ARE
GOING TO HOLD QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. UNTIL AFTER THE
ENTIRE PANEL HAS SPOKEN. SO L.
A. O. R. I SEE YOU I THINK ARE
YOU READY TO BEGIN. GOOD MORNING
SENATORS AND WITH THIS MORALES
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. IF YOU JUST BEAR WITH ME
FOR ONE MOMENT WHILE I BEGAN
SHARING MY SCREEN BERMAN
PRESENTATION. I HOPE YOU CAN
SORT OF SEE THAT HAND OUT
CLEARLY IT'S ALSO AVAILABLE ON
THE ALEJO'S WEBSITE AND EVERYONE
SHOULD HAVE COPIES ON THEIR DESK
AS WELL. YOU'RE GOOD. YEAH
COMMITTEE STAFF TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF MAJOR STATE SPENDING
ACTIONS IN RECENT YEARS RELATED
TO HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS.
WHAT CAN PROVIDE A BIT OF
CONTACT FOR SOME OF THE ON MANY
WEEKS IN RECENT YEARS. HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY THE FEAR AND WHY
CHALLENGES THE STATE AND
CALIFORNIANS A LARGER SHARE OF
THEIR INCOME ON RENT AND
HOUSEHOLD IN THE REST OF THE
NATION OVER ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION LOW INCOME RENTERS FACE
DIRE COST PRESSURES AND THE MORE
THAN HALF OF THEIR INCOME ON
HOUSING. HOMES IN THE STATE COST
ABOUT TWO POINT THREE TIMES THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE AND RENTS ARE
ABOUT 50% HIGHER IN THE STATE
AND THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
WHILE MANY FACTORS HAVE A ROLE
IN TRAINING CALIFORNIA'S HIGH
HOUSING COSTS THE MOST IMPORTANT
IS A SIGNIFICANT SHORTAGE OF
HOUSING. PARTICULARLY IN URBAN
CULTURE COMMUNITIES. THIS
COMPETITION FOR HOUSING
INCREASES- ON HOME PRICES AND
RENTS IN THESE COASTAL URBAN
COMMUNITIES. AND PUSHES SOME
PEOPLE TO INLAND AREAS OF THE
STATE WHICH THEN REDUCES PRICES
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES AS WELL.
WELL WE KNOW THAT HOMELESS IS A-
PROBLEM WITH MANY CAUSES THE
HIGH COST OF HOUSING IS A
SIGNIFICANT FACTOR IN THE
STATE'S HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. FOR
THE STATE'S LOWEST INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS WE SPEND A
SIGNIFICANT SHARE OF THEIR
INCOME ON HOUSING A JOB LOSS OR
UNEXPECTED EXPENSE COULD LEAD
THEM TO HOUSING INSTABILITY OR
HOMELESSNESS. MORE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA THAN ANY OTHER STATE.
YOU SEE SOME DATA POINTS THERE
FROM TWENTY TWENTY UNSCOM WITH
THIS COUNT THE MOST RECENT YOUR
WE HAVE COMPLETE FEDERAL DATA IN
THAT POINT IN TIME THERE WAS ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE THOUSAND.
FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ABOUT 70% OF THOSE
PEOPLE WERE UNSHELTERED. AND
WHILE. ASSOCIATED WITH THE
COMPANY KINDA ME NOW DOT ON AND
PEOPLE NEXT HOMELESSNESS WILL
NOT BE AVAILABLE FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. A WE DO HAVE SOME
DATA THAT FIFTY ONE THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED PEOPLE WERE IN
SHELTERS IN NEXT YEAR. THE
RECENT INCREASES IN THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN THE STATE ARE
DRIVEN BY GROWTH IN UNSHELTERED
HOMELESSNESS. THE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS HAS BECOME MORE ACUTE IN
RECENT YEARS THE STATE HAS TAKEN
A MORE ACTIVE ROLE IN FUNDING
AND SUPPORTING LOCAL GOVERNMENT
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS.
OVERALL THE STATE HAS INCREASED
ITS ROLE BY ADDRESSING ON THE
PROVIDING SIGNIFICANT ALL THOSE
ARE ONE TIME IN TEMPORARY
FUNDING TOWARDS INFRASTRUCTURE
AND FLEXIBLE AID TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN RECENT YEARS.
SIMILARLY AS A HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS HAS BECOME
MORE ACUTE OVER TIME THE STATE
HAS SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED ITS
FISCAL ROLE BY EXPANDING-
EXPANDING EXISTING PROGRAMS AS
WELL AS ESTABLISHING SOME NEW
PROGRAM TO HELP SUBSIDIZE THE
COST OF HOUSING. AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL ONCE AGAIN USING YOUR-
CONTEMPORARY RESOURCES. THIS
TABLE WHICH ON THAT PAGE OF THE
HAND. I'M NEED TO K. THEM DISK.
SPENDING ACTIONS WITH THE STATE
AND TO SEE THAT OUR PRIMARILY
RESPONSIBLE FOR OVERSEEING
HOUSING HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS SO
THE HOUSING COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT
CALIFORNIA INJURY INTERAGENCY
COUNCIL ON HOMELESSNESS THE
CALIFORNIA TAX CREDIT ALLOCATION
COMMITTEE. AND THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY THE TABLE
DOES NOT CAPTURE OTHER SPENDING
ACTIONS RELATED TO HEALTHY
HOMELESSNESS IN DEPARTMENTS THAT
HAVE OTHER PRIMARY MISSIONS FOR
EXAMPLE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES DEPARTMENT. THE TABLE
BEGAN IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
NINETEEN FISCAL YEAR WHEN THE
STATE BEGAN PROVIDING
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES TOWARDS
HOMELESSNESS. THROUGH THE HEAP
PROGRAM. THE MOST RECENT FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AM
AUTHORIZED SOME SPENDING ACTIONS
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
SO YOU SEE IN THOSE REFLECTED ON
THE TABLE HOWEVER THE GOVERNOR
IS ALSO PER PROPOSED ADDITIONAL
SPENDING IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE- SINCE THE LARGEST. TAKEN
ACTION ON THIS PROPOSAL THEY ARE
NOT REFLECTED ON THIS YEAR. SO
YOU SEE SORT OF IN. IN THESE. ON
THEIR OFFICER OTHERS THE STATE
HAS. A LOT THIRTEEN FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS ACROSS THE LAST SEVERAL
SCHOOL YEARS TOWARDS HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS. FINAL HE
TAKEAWAYS FROM THE TABLE- FIRST
OPENING THE STATE'S RECENT ACT
ON HOUSING AND HOMELESS HAVE
BEEN AND SPREAD ACROSS MULTIPLE
AND WHILE THE REFLECTED ON THE
TABLE IMAGINE ARE THEY STILL DO
NOT ALL OF THIS TO SPENDING TO
HOW AND HOME. MUCH OF THE NEW
SPENDING BEEN ONE TIME OR
TEMPORARY EVEN IN MANY THE CASES
WERE FUNDING BEEN PROVIDE IN
MORE. FISCAL YEARS THE HAS OFTEN
BEEN PER. WITH ON A ONE. OR
TEMPER BASIS. THE SIX EIGHT
BILLION IN NEW FUNDING PROVIDED
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO FISCAL YEAR WAS LARGELY
SUPPORTED BY FEDERAL FUNDS.
SPECIFICALLY FEDERAL AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN ACTS- THAT WAS
ASSOCIATED WITH A PANDEMIC. AND
ONCE AGAIN THE- FOR THE HOUSING
- THE FOCUS THE STATE REALLY
BEEN ON EXPANDING EXISTING AND
ESTABLISHING NEW PROGRAMS THAT
HELP SUBSIDIZE THE COST OF
HOUSING WELL FOR HOMELESSNESS
STATE BECAUSE LARGELY BEEN ON
INCREASING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
PROVIDING. AID TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. INTO THE STUFF
CONCLUDE MY PREPARED
PRESENTATION I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
WHEN APPROPRIATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO NEXT WE ARE GOING
TO HEAR FROM THE CALIFORNIA
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS. AND ARE YOU WITH
US. THE NEW ALL RIGHT WELL
HEADED SISTER. WELL GOOD MORNING
TO THE CHAIRS AND MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JULIE
LOW AND I AM THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE CALIFORNIA
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS IN ADDITION TO MY
ROLE. IT WAS DIRECT AND
SUBSTANTIVE EXPERIENCE OF
HOMELESSNESS ACROSS MANY
JURISDICTIONS ACROSS OUR STATE.
WHERE FOR TWO DECADES I LIVE IN
TEMPORARY SHELTER AND
UNSHELTERED SETTINGS AS A CHILD
AND ADULT. I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU TODAY
. IN MY ROLE I HELP DIRECT
EFFORTS OF NEARLY FIFTY STAFF
ACCOUNTING C. H. I'M GRATEFUL TO
SHARE OUR EFFORTS. IN ENHANCING
THE STATE'S HOMELESSNESS
RESPONSE TO THE COUNCIL'S DATA
COLLECTION AND PLANNING EFFORTS
ALONG WITH IMPLEMENTING THE
STATE'S RECENT BUDGET
INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS AND
PREVENT HOMELESSNESS. THE
FOUNDATION OF THE STATE'S
HOMELESSNESS RESPONSES THROUGH
DATA INFORM POLICIES WHICH
INFORMS OUR PLANNING AND BUDGET
INVESTMENTS. IN APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE KELLY C. H. LAUNCHED
THE HOMELESS DATA INTEGRATION
SYSTEM OR H. T. I. S. H. R. DH
D. I. S. IS A STATE WIDE DATA
WAREHOUSE WHERE ALL FORTY FOUR
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES OF CARE
REPORT DATA. MAKING IT THE MOST
COMPREHENSIVE VIEW OF THE
STATE'S HOMELESSNESS SERVICE
PROVISIONS TO DATE. THE
DEVELOPMENT OF EACH YEAR I ASKED
WAS A FIRST FOR CALIFORNIA AND
ENABLES US TO TRACK SERVICE
OUTCOMES AT THE STATEWIDE LEVEL.
PROVIDINGUS THE ABILITY TO
LEARN ABOUT A NUMBER OF SERVICE
OUTCOMES INCLUDING HOUSING
OUTCOMES. TO IMPROVE. POLICY AND
FISCAL DECISIONS. THE COUNCIL'S
AND FOR ARE FOCUSED AT BOTH THE
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL EACH OF
WHICH ARE CRITICAL COMPONENTS TO
OUR STATE'S HOMELESSNESS
RESPONSE. AS PART OF OUR STATE
PLANNING AND COORDINATION EFFORT
IN MARCH OF LAST YEAR HELLO I.
C. H. AT THAT TIME THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL. ADOPTED THE ACTION PLAN
FOR PREVENTING AND ENDING
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA. THE
PLAN CENTERS AROUND FIVE MAJOR
ACTION AREAS AND THEY ARE SYSTEM
STRENGTHENING UNSHELTERED
INTERVENTIONS SHELTERING
PERMANENT HOUSING AND PREVENTION
. ANOTHER AREA WHERE WE FOCUS
OUR WORK IS TO THE STATE WIDE
LANDSCAPE ASSESSMENT. AS PART OF
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGE KELLY C. H. WAS
PROVIDED FUNDING TO LAUNCH THE
LANDSCAPE ASSESSMENT TO TAKE A
LOOK AT STATE FUNDING FROM
RECENT BUDGET YEARS STARTING
WITH THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN YEAR AND ENDING WITH
THE TWENTY ONE. TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET. THE ASSESSMENT WILL
PROVIDE THE STATE WITH A
HOLISTIC UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
STATE PROGRAMS INTERACT WITH
DIFFERENT FUNDING AND SERVICE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS ACROSS THE
STATE. WHICH WILL ENABLE US TO
BETTER ASSESS HOW TO
STRATEGICALLY DEPLOY THOSE
RESOURCES. AND TO GAIN A MORE
REFINED UNDERSTANDING OF
SUCCESSFUL INTERVENTION TYPES
AND STRATEGIES. OUR ONGOING
EFFORTS IN ENHANCING THE STATE'S
DATA COLLECTION AND PLANNING
INFRASTRUCTURE HAVE BEEN A
CRITICAL PIECE OF INFORMING OUR
BUDGET INVESTMENTS. SINCE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CALYCES HAS
ADMINISTERED OVER THREE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS AND
FLEXIBLE LOCAL FUNDING. WITH
EACH INVESTMENT THE STATE'S
CONTINUUM OF CARE LARGE CITIES
AND COUNTIES COMPRISING OF A
TOTAL OF ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
ELIGIBLE JURISDICTIONS HAVE HAD
ACCESS TO LOCAL FUNDING TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES THAT CAN MEET
THE DIVERSE NEEDS. OF
COMMUNITIES ACROSS OUR STATE.
THIS APPROACH TO HAVE SHARED
DECISION MAKING AROUND THE LOCAL
USES A FUNDING COMPLEMENT LONGER
TERM CAPITAL INVESTMENTS SUCH AS
HOME KEEP THAT FOCUS ON THAT. ON
EXPANDING AVAILABILITY OF
HOUSING. IN THE LAST YEAR THE
CALORIES EACH GRANT SCHEME HAS
HAD SEVERAL SIGNIFICANT
ACCOMPLISHMENTS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION OF OUR GRANT
PROGRAMS. THE STATE'S FIRST
ITERATION OF FLEXIBLE BLOCK
GRANT FUNDING AND IT LAST
SUMMER. THE HOMELESS EMERGENCY
AID PROGRAM OR HE PROVIDED FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN BLOCK
GRANTS TO ASSIST LOCALITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA PROVIDING
FLEXIBLE FUNDS TO ASSIST IN
THEIR HOMELESSNESS RESPONSE. A
FORTHCOMING REPORT WILL PROVIDE
A MORE DETAILED ASSESSMENT BUT
AT A HIGHER LEVEL HE DID
CONTRIBUTE FUNDING TO MORE THAN
NINE HUNDRED DIFFERENT PROGRAMS.
OR PROJECTS THAT SERVED OVER
EIGHTY SEVEN THOUSAND PEOPLE.
ADDITIONALLY COUNTY C. H. HAS
BEEN FOCUSED ON ADMINISTERING
OUR HOUSE HOMELESS HOUSING
ASSISTANCE AND PREVENTION
PROGRAM ARE HAPPY. TOTALING FOUR
ROUNDS OF FUNDING- AT NEARLY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS EACH OF
THESE PROGRAMS ARE IN DIFFERENT
STAGES OF DEVELOPMENT. BUT WITH
EACH ITERATION OF HAPPY. THE
COUNCIL IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
CONTINUOUSLY REFINE THE
PROGRAM'S APPROACH BY FOCUSING
ON EFFORTS SUCH AS PROVIDING
SUPPORT FOR REGIONAL
COORDINATION. DEVELOPING LOCAL
CAPACITY AND ENSURING LOCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OUTCOMES.
SPECIFICALLY AS PART OF THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
INVESTMENT AND HAPPY GRANTEES
ARE REQUIRED TO DEVELOP ROBUST
LOCAL ACTION PLANS OUTLINING
LOCAL NEEDS RESOURCES
PERFORMANCE GOALS AND STRATEGIES
TO MEET THOSE GOALS. FOR
PURPOSES OF THESE PLANS THIS TO
SUPPORT CROSS SYSTEM
COLLABORATION TO BRING TOGETHER
ALL NETWORKS THAT CAN SUPPORT
THE GOAL TO END HOMELESSNESS.
WINDS WILL BE DEVELOPED IN
COLLABORATION WITH CALLOUS EACH
STAFF AND MUST BE SUBMITTED AS
PART OF GRANT APPLICATIONS THAT
ARE DUE LATER THIS YEAR ENGINE.
JURISDICTIONS MUST SUBMIT AN
APPROVED LOCAL HOMELESSNESS
ACTION PLAN TO RECEIVE CAL I C.
H. FUNDING AND WILL BE HELD TO
THEIR GOALS I CALYX EACH STAFF.
IN CLOSING THE STATE'S
HOMELESSNESS RESPONSE IS
CONTINUING TO FOCUS ON WAYS TO
LEVERAGE OUR DATA AND PLANNING
RESOURCES IN ORDER TO AND FORMER
ASSESSMENTS. WITH THE GOAL OF
CONTINUING OUR PROGRESS IN
PREVENTING AND ENDING
HOMELESSNESS. THANK YOU AGAIN TO
THIS COMMITTEE FOR INVITING ME
TO ADDRESS YOU TODAY I'LL TURN
IT BACK OVER TO OUR NEXT SPEAKER
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO NOW WE
WILL HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. AND IS THAT USE
THAT. THAT IS ME ALL RIGHT HERE
HIT. THANK YOU EVERYONE- MY
NAME'S ZACH OLMSTEAD I'M THE
CHIEF DEPUTY AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT NUMBER HALF OUR TEAM
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH YOU
TODAY AND SHARE INFORMATION
ABOUT HOUSING HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS FROM PREVIOUS BUDGET
INVESTMENTS. OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS WITH SUPPORT LEGISLATURE
THE GOVERNOR AND STAKEHOLDERS
AROUND THE STATE WE WORK
TOGETHER. ON SEVERAL FRONTS TO
INCREASE THE SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND BLOOD
SOME OF THE WORST IMPACTS THE
HOUSING CRISIS THE TARGET
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PLANNING
GRANTS HOUSING INVESTMENTS AND
ACCOUNTABILITY EFFORTS.
THROUGHOUT THE PAST YEARS WE'VE
DEEPENED OUR PARTNERSHIPS AND
COLLABORATION WITH OTHER
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS TO
ALIGN EFFORTS TO ADDRESS HOUSING
NEEDS. THIS COLLABORATION IS
EVIDENT A CD AND I WORK WITH
COLLEGE AVE THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COUNCIL ON HOMELESSNESS
THE PART OF GENERAL SERVICES AND
IN MANY OTHERS. THESE
RELATIONSHIPS IN OUR WORK AT
WITH FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
PARTNERS WE COLLABORATE TO ME
OUR MISSION. AND SHE BETTER
OUTCOMES TOGETHER. ALTOGETHER WE
IMPLEMENTED BEST TO HELP WITH
THE SPEC OF HOUSE NEED AND
RESPONSE ANGER. OF HOMES. IBM
THIS MEETING LATE LAST WEEK OUR
TEAM WITH THE COMMITTEE CAN A OF
DOC TO PROVIDE DETAILED. ABOUT
OUR PROGRAM. OF WESTERN- AS WE
GET TO MEMBER WE MAYOR WAS TO.
BUT BEFORE THEN I EXCITED TO
PROVIDE A HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW
OF- FOR PROGRAMS IN INTEREST OF
TIME THAT SHOWCASE
OPPORTUNITIES- AND IMPORTANT
OUTCOMES IN OUR PARTNERSHIPS TO
HELP ACHIEVE THESE RESULTS. THE
COMMITTEE IS A FAMILIAR I'M SURE
WITH HUNKY BUT I WANT TO
UNDERSCORE THE SIGNIFICANT
INFUSION OF HOUSING THAT THE
PROGRAM HAS BROUGHT ONLINE. TO
HELP CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN VERY SHORT TIME
FRAMES THE FIRST INFUSIONS OF
HOME HE FACILITATED THE CREATION
OF NEARLY SIX THOUSAND UNITS
OKAY INTERMENT PERMANENT
HOUSING. AND HUNDRED TWENTY
DIFFERENT SITES IN THIRTY FIVE
DIFFERENT COUNTIES WITH EVERY
PROJECT. RECEIVING OPERATING
SUPPORT AS WELL. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BEEN VERY PARTNERS
AND WE ARE EXCITED AS THEY
CONTINUE TO STEP UP WITH
APPLICATIONS FOR HOKEY TO POINT
OUT WHAT WE WANT SEVERAL MONTHS
AGO. IN OVER THE COUNTER FASHION
. A PUBLIC DASHBOARD FOR THE
SECOND OKIE IS AVAILABLE ON EACH
YEAR WEBSITE AND REFLECTS THE
FOURTEEN AWARDS WE HAVE ALREADY
ANNOUNCED. FOR OVER THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION IN
FUNDING WHICH ARE CREATING
TWELVE HUNDRED UNITS. AND A
RECENT MILESTONE OF A JANUARY
THIRTY FIRST DEADLINE TO APPLY
FOR THE GEOGRAPHIC SET ASIDE TO
FUNDS HAS JUST PASSED. AND WHILE
WE'RE STILL ABOUT IT IS THAT
AGENCY I AM PLEASED TO REPORT IN
TOTAL OVER TWO BILLION HAS
ALREADY BEEN REQUESTED FOR THE
ONE POINT FOUR FIVE BILLION
AVAILABLE. FROM THIS YEAR'S
NOTICE OF FUNDING AVAILABILITY.
SO THE STORE. INTEREST HOTELS
AND MOTELS CONTINUE TO BE ONE
POSSIBLE PRODUCT TYPE BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO MENTION
THAT WE OUGHT ARCING CONTINUED
INTEREST IN MODULAR HOUSING.
ACQUISITION OF EXISTING MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING AND OTHER ADAPTER
USES THAT ARE ALSO ELIGIBLE.
ANOTHER PROGRAM I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT IS THE IN PHILLIP
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM
WHICH HELPS FOCUS ON PLACE BASED
SOLUTIONS TO REMOVE BARRIERS TO
INFILL HOUSING CONSTRUCTION.
CALIFORNIA VOTERS AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE BEEN VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS PROGRAM OVER
THE PAST FEW YEARS. WHICH HAS
THE LAST TWO FUNDING ROUNDS
AWARDED A LITTLE OVER FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT MILLION TO
NINETY SIX DIFFERENT PROJECTS.
TWENTY ONE OF THOSE TO SMALL
JURISDICTIONS. THESE AWARDS ARE
STILL TAKING PRODUCTION OF
1-000-080-0407 UNITS OF HOUSING
IN THOSE. AREAS AND THE CO
BENEFIT OF THESE INVESTMENTS AS
A REDUCTION IN GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS WHICH IS WHY I HIGH
KEY IS INCLUDING GOVERNOR
NEWSOM'S PROPOSED BUDGET. AS
PART OF THE STATE'S COORDINATED
RESPONSE THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
CALIFORNIA HOUSING STELLARATOR
IS ANOTHER NEW INVESTMENT
ALLOCATED MR AJIT. THIS PROGRAM
ALLOWS EACH THE TO FIND CHAU
READY. THAT HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO
BEGIN CONSTRUCTION BECAUSE OF
THE SHORTAGE OF FEDERAL TAX
CREDITS IN BONDS. EARLIER THIS
MONTH NINE HUNDRED TWENTY THREE
MILLION IN AWARDS FOR TWENTY
SEVEN FOR THE HOUSING PROJECTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA WERE ANNOUNCED
WITH NEARLY ALL OF THE PROJECTS
EXPECTED TO BREAK GROUND BY THIS
SUMMER. WITH FULLY COMPLETED.
THE PROJECT WILL CREATE TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED HOUSING UNITS FIVE
HUNDRED OF WHICH ARE FOR THOSE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
NOTHING SORRY PRIORITIZE
PROJECTS FOR THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND FOR THOSE BELOW
THIRTY PERCENT. WE CAN AND CAPS
. THE NEXT ROUND OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING STELLARATOR
WILL BE A COMPETITIVE PROCESS
FOR PREVIOUSLY ECT AWARDED ARE
PROJECTS THAT ARE ALL WOULD ALSO
BE SEEKING 4% TAX CREDITS.
GRAHAM WILL INCLUDE REGIONAL
ALLOCATIONS TO ENSURE PROJECT
GRAPHIC DISTRIBUTION OF THESE
FUNDS. AND FOR THE NEXT PHASE.
OF THE PROJECT FOR THE
SONGWRITER AN ADDITIONAL SEVEN
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE MILLION WILL
BE MADE AVAILABLE AND I'LL COME
OUT LATER THIS MONTH. WELL NOT A
PRODUCTION PROGRAM- WE THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT HIGHLIGHT
SOME OTHER SIGNIFICANT
AMENDMENTS MADE IN EACH AND
EVERY CITY AND COUNTY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE IN THE FORMER SEVERAL
ROUNDS OF PLANNING GRANTS. THAT
HELP BUILD CAPACITY OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IN PREPARATION FOR
SIX HOUSING ELEMENT CYCLE. SINCE
TWENTY NINETEEN. SB TWO PLANNING
GRANTS AND WHAT WE CALL OUR LEAD
. AND READ PLANNING GRANTS.
EASIEST RIGHT ALMOST FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO HELP
JURISDICTIONS RESULT AND GET
READY FOR HOUSING ELEMENT
REQUIREMENTS. FOR THESE GRANTS
THERE WAS NO PREVIOUS FUNDING TO
JURISDICTIONS TO ASSIST THEM
WITH HOUSING L. OPERATIONS. WE
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY
PROVIDED TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE OF
PLANNING GRANTS FOR TO CITIES
AND COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. IT'S GOING TO ALSO BE
COMBINED WITH THOUSANDS OF HOURS
OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE-
PERSONALIZE REGIONAL TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PLANTED OFFICE HOURS.
AGENCIES BUILDING BLOCKS GUIDE
TO CREATE A HOUSING ELEMENT.
MEMOS EXPLAINING HOW TO
IMPLEMENT THE NEW HOUSING
ELEMENT LAWS AND CONTINUALLY
GROWING HOUSING HUB WITH
TEMPLATES AND TOOLKITS COVERING
THE MOST REQUESTED TOPICS. WITH
THREE TWO POINT OH FUNDING IN
THIS BUDGET YEAR IS SHE WILL BE
ABLE TO PUT OUT AN ADDITIONAL
SIX HUNDRED MILLION IN PLANNING
INFORMATION GRANT. IMITATION
GRANT EXCUSE ME. THAT CAN HELP
JURISDICTIONS KEEP TO THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENT AND COMMITMENTS.
LEAVING JUST A FEW OF THE
STRATEGIC INVESTMENTS THE STATE
BEEN MAKING. THAT WE BELIEVE
WILL ADD TO THE STATE'S MUCH
NEEDED HOUSING SUPPLY RECORD
YOUR QUESTIONS AND HAPPY TO TURN
OVER TO THE NEXT. THANK YOU FOR
THAT ZACH AND NOW WE WILL HEAR.
LASTLY FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY. AND ARE
YOU READY YES YES HELLO. CHAIRS
ARE KAMLAGER AND WIENER MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FELLOW
PANELISTS- MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
MY NAME IS FRANCIS MARTY AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATION AND
POLICIES FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK.
TODAY AS MANY YOU KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA FUNDING AGENCY OF. IS
THE STATE'S FOR HOUSING UNDER WE
ARE OURSELVES AND WE HAVE THE
STATE GOVERNMENT. WHICH GIVES US
A HIDING OF LIKE IN A THE- WE
ALSO HAVE A SEPARATE RATING THAT
ALLOWS US DIRECT TO THE PRIVATE
CAPITAL MARKETS ENCORE LINES OF
BUSINESS ARE ONE WE HELP FIRST
TIME HOME BUYERS WITH DOWN
PAYMENT ASSISTANCE TO. WE DO
LANDING AND BOND ISSUANCE FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
RENTAL HOUSING. SO ALTHOUGH
COUNTY TO FACE CORE BUSINESS
RELIES ON RAISING SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT OF PRIVATE CAPITAL SINCE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. THIS HAS
BEEN SUPPLEMENTED BY VARIOUS
INVESTMENTS INCLUDING ANNUAL
REVENUE PROVIDED BY. THE
RECORDING FEE INDUSTRY TO. US SB
. ONE HOW BOND FUND AS WELL AS A
THAT RESOURCES ALL GENERAL FUND
. THANKS AND THROUGHOUT THIS
ACCOUNT IF YOU HAS ANY BEING
FORTY WITH OTHERS DEPARTMENTS
INCLUDING H. AND TRASH TREASURE
OFFICE LAST FRIDAY MARK THERE
ARE. AND ARE PARTNERS. IN ORDER
TO EFFECTIVELY MORE LICENSEES
AND. SO NOW GO TO THE SLIDE. AND
IN THE NEXT LADY YOU CAN SEE A
SUMMER OF AMOUNT FROM THE
SOURCES THAT WE HAVE A DEPLOYED
OVER THE LAST WEEK ENDING THE
FISCAL YEAR. THAT THIS LAST JUNE
THIRTIETH YOU'LL ALSO SEE A UNIT
CALL THE PRODUCTION FOR EACH. AS
YOU SEE WE DEPLOYED OF THREE
HUNDRED MILLION OVER WHICH IS
FINE. ABOUT SIX THOUSAND UNITS
OF HOUSING. OUR FIRST TIME HOME
BUYER PROGRAM ACCOUNTS LOS. IT
ALL SEVENTEEN. HOMEBUYERS HOW
BEEN A SAID. WITH THE FIRE FROM
MY BY. PROP ONE HAS THREE OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. I'M FIRST
HOME BUYER PROGRAM WELL FIRST
DANTE ASSISTANCE SUPPORTED WITH
STATE. GEN ABOUT. A HUNDRED TO
TWO MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR WHICH
SPARED WITH. FEDERALLY
CONFORMING FIRST MORTGAGES
DRYING ON THE SECONDARY MARKET
PRIVATE CAPITAL GENERALLY
BETWEEN TWO AND FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR DEPENDING ON
WHERE WE ARE IN THE REAL ESTATE
MARKET CYCLE THAT'S A LEVERAGES
ALL OF TWENTY PRIVATE DOLLARS
FOR EVERY. DOLLAR IN STATE
SUPPORT AND I NEED AT LEAST
VOLUMES WE ARE ABLE TO HELP
BETWEEN SIX THOUSAND AND
THIRTEEN TIMES. HOUSEHOLDS EACH
YEAR AGAIN DEPENDING ON WHERE WE
ARE IN THE REAL ESTATE MARKET
CYCLE A WHICH IS A REAL BOSS 10%
OF THE MARKET SHARE OF FIRST
TIME. HOME BUYERS IN CALIFORNIA
. SO IN TERMS OF ARE THE L. OF
THIS PROGRAM. DRESSING THE UP
FRONT CASH. TO BUY A HOME AND
COVERING THE CLOSING WE APPROVED
BY AND ON RAMP TO HOME FOR UNDER
GROUPS. WHICH WE MAKE THE FOR
BETWEEN GETTING UP- BUYERS INTO
THEIR HOME. AND WE ARE PROUD
THAT WE ARE DIRECTLY ADDRESSING
OUR STATE RACIAL WEALTH GAP
ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED TEN
HOUSEHOLDS WE SERVE ON FROM
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. 53% OF OUR
BORROWERS ARE LATINO AND 8% ARE
BLACK. WE ESTIMATE THERE ARE
BORROWER HOLD. HOW TO. IT RAFI
SOME PER. IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS
GENERATING OVER A HUNDRED SIX
THOUSAND AN ADDITIONAL EQUITY.
ON AVERAGE FOR EACH OF THESE
HOUSEHOLDS WE HAVE HELPED BUY
THEIR FIRST HOME AND- 74% OF
HOUSEHOLDS SERVED ME UNDER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
AND 75% ARE UNDER THE AGE OF
FORTY FIVE. SO OVER THE LAST
THREE YEARS WE ALSO DEPLOYED.
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED MILLION IN
OUR MIXED INCOME PROGRAM OR
CULTURAL TO HIS NECK. WHICH
PROVIDES FINANCING FOR
AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOUSING
SHIPPING INCOMES FROM 30% THEY
APPLY 280% THERE MIGHT WITH AN
OPTION TO GO. ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY. WE HAVE DEPLOYED THIS
FUNDING FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS AND HAVE PRODUCED YOU
SHY OF FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED UNITS
WITH THESE RESOURCES AND AFTER
THREE YEARS OF RUNNING THIS BILL
WHEN WE HAVE A FEW LESSONS THAT
WE'VE LEARNED AND LIKE TO SHOW
THE COMMITTEE. I PROJECTS HAVE
GONE CONTROL. NEARLY FIVE AGO
COMPARE BROAD ARE PROJECTS STATE
. THANK ABOUT TWELVE MONTHS GET
TO CAN WE IS GENERALLY. FOR THE
HOUSING- MOST OF FOUR HOUSING.
AND THE RUNNING THE BROAD RANGE
INCOMES THAT ARE STRONG BY A-
NOT. SUPPORT MORE. LIVING BY BUT
ALSO GIVE NOT PRODUCE ALONG
LONGER TERM FOR JUST. WHICH
MEANS THEY'RE LESS ALLOW. TO
COME TO THE STATE FOR. FUNDING
ON THE LINE. LEASE IS ALMOST
ACTUALLY- HELLO BY NOT COME OF
HOUSING. AGENCIES WHICH IS
NATIONAL. WHEN THEY ARE RIGHT.
BECAUSE NEXT BROKE AND GET A
MEASURE WORK FOR IT. I NOW WILL
TURN TO OUR LAND DEPLOY A-
REMAIN FUNDS OVER THE- NEXT
YEARS. SO GOING TO FACE OF BE.
SIXTY FIVE MILLION A IN NEARLY
PROVIDED AS AS TWO WEEKS.
CHARLIE I'M GOING. TO FIND CAN
YOU. BROAD WITH OUR MEXICAN AND
ALSO GOING TO BE IN VOTING-
SEVENTEEN MILLION THAT WERE A
REMAINING. IN AB ONE OF ONE ONCE
SOON TO BE DEPARTING FOR THIS.
HELLO THAT IS SIX TO UPGRADE
ABOUT. FIFTEEN HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL UNITS- ON THE
HOMEOWNER FROM YOUR ALSO ROLLING
OUT A FEW NEW ANISH. WE'RE GONNA
USED HE AMY. PROVIDING IN
PROVIDED A IN STATE'S BUDGET-
YOU CAN A BRAND NEW HOLD
ASSISTANCE. ON YOUR DOORS NO AND
- OF THE WHOLE BUYER INCOMES.
AND WE ARE ALL GOING TO BE ABLE
OUT IN PHASE OF A SPECIALIZED.
FOR CURRENTLY LIVING IN- AS OUR
S. SEVEN PROPER IN. ENGLISH
ANGELES. EIGHT TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR GRANT TO HOLD
AND BUILD AN EIGHTY YOU. AND IS
ALSO EXPECTED TO PRODUCE. OF
FOUR THOUSAND EIGHTY YEARS OVER
THE NEXT FEW YEARS. WELL WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH OUR COLLEAGUES
AT H. R. THAT- THAT PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AROUND THEY
USE AND WE ALSO ONBOARDING
LENDERS FROM THIS PHONE PROGRAM
AND WE'VE ACTUALLY JUST REACHED
ACT CRITICAL MASSES UNDER
PARTICIPATION WHICH CAN ALLOW
THIS PROGRAM TO. FILL UP VERY
QUICKLY IN THE NEXT WEEKS AND
MONTHS. I LIKE TO NOTE DOWN THE
STATE INVESTMENT OF KARL MUCH
LARGER. SWEET I'M FINE TOOLS
THAT KIND HAS DEPLOYING BUT THIS
. THANK YOU AND INCLUDING I
LARGE AMOUNTS OF CARD. HAS A
MAJOR. MORTGAGES FROM SOME YOU
MUST TREASURY PRO. AS WELL AS
HOME AS FAR. FOR THANK FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE JUST DATE
THE PRO OF OUR PRO AND ARE HAPPY
TO TAKE QUESTION OF THE- TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MARTI SO-
THAT CONCLUDE. ALL OF OUR-
PANELISTSAT PRESENT. AND SO NOW
WE'RE TO OPEN IT TO- THE CA I.
WILL STE WITH A COUPLE OF- AND
THEN I WILL ALSO POINT TO DO TO
SEE. WIENER WHO MICHAEL CHAIR
AND THEN OPEN IT UP- THE REST OF
THE- MEMBERS HERE. SO THIS
QUESTION IS FOR CAL I C. H. OF
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
REQUIRED- H. HAPPY RECIPIENTS TO
DEVELOP COMPREHENSIVE
HOMELESSNESS PLANS AND YOU ALSO
TALKED ABOUT THESE ACTION PLANS
OUTLINING NEEDS- YOU DID MENTION
THAT THE PLAN WILL BE DEVELOPED
IN DUE BY JUNE MY QUESTION IS.
WHAT ARE THE QUANTIFIABLE GOALS
OR OUTCOMES THAT YOU ARE LOOKING
FOR- THAT WE NEED TO SEE IN
THESE PLANS BECAUSE I WILL TELL
YOU FOLKS ARE TIRED OF PLANS
THAT DON'T HAVE SOME KIND OF
QUANTIFIABLE METRIC THAT RESULTS
IN PEOPLE NOT BEING ON THE
STREETS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION AND- I'M ALSO JOINED
TODAY BY A GRANT STRUCTURE
VICTOR DRAWN BUT SORT OF-
QUICKLY AND BRIEFLY ANSWER THAT
QUESTION- THERE ARE TWO
COMPONENTS TO THE LOCAL. ACTION
PLANNING PROCESS THERE IS THE
PLAN THAT'S MORE ROBUST THAT
HAS- SORT OF THE INTERVENTION TO
THE STRATEGIES IN THE AND AN
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT IS NEEDED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL THE SECOND
COMPONENT IS AROUND. WHAT ARE
BEING REFERRED TO AS THE SYSTEM
PERFORMANCE MEASURES THOSE ARE
QUANTITATIVE MEASURES THAT WE
ARE CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
BUILDING UP A BASELINE FOR TO
PROVIDE IN OUR LOCAL PLANNING
PROCESS WITH. OUR GRANTEES AND
BASED ON THE BASELINE DATA THEY
WILL BE PROJECTING I'M QUANAH
QUANTITATIVE MEASURES. I'M AND
GOALS. OKAY IN THE WORKS IS WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING YES- INDEED YEAH
SO CAN YOU ALSO SPEAK TO SOME OF
THE INVESTMENTS THAT LOCALS ARE
USING FOR TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTH
THAT IS A HUGE PERCENTAGE OF OUR
HOMELESSNESS POPULATION. YES AND
LET'S NOT EVEN DON'T TURN TO
VICTOR DERON WILL BUILD THE
SPEAK. I'M MORE DEEPLY ABOUT
THAT ISSUE. VICTOR YOUNG THEY
ARE. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE SO GOOD
TO BE HERE- SO. WE'VE SLOWLY
BEEN RAMPING UP SOME OF THEIR
REQUIRED INVESTMENTS FOR
TRANSITION AGE YEARS BEGINNING
WITH HE- WAS THE FIRST A LARGE
FLEXIBLE BLOCK GRANT PROGRAM
THAT REQUIRED ALL OF OUR GRAND
CHIEFS TO SET ASIDE A MINIMUM
AMOUNT OF FUNDING SPECIFICALLY
FOR SERVICES FOR YOUTH I WANT TO
MAKE THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN
SERVICES THAT. INCIDENTALLY
SERVE YOU AND SERVICES THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO BE DEVELOPMENTALLY
APPROPRIATE FOR USE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND AS THESE
INVESTMENTS HAVE CONTINUED WE
HAVE SLOWLY INCREASED AT THE
REQUIRE SET ASIDE- STARTING WITH
5% WITH OUR HE PROGRAMMES AND
NOW TO TEN PERCENT. WITH THE
HALF THREE IN A HALF FOR. THAT
WERE ALSO TO- THAT IN HE WHICH
WAS LOW MENTION BE FORTHCOMING
NEXT MONTH- WE SEE REFLECTED
SOME REALLY INNOVATIVE WORK
AROUND SERVICES FOR YOUTH AND OF
THAT OUR GRANTEES EXCEEDED THE
MINIMUM SET ASIDE TRANSACTION
SERVICE. OKAY THANK YOU. I'M
THIS QUESTION IS FOR H. S. CD
THE ARM HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. YOU TALKED A LOT
ABOUT THESE COORDINATING EFFORTS
BETWEEN H. C. D. N. T. C. A. C.
IN OTHER STATE HOUSING PROGRAMS
LOTS OF ACRONYMS. CAN YOU SHARE
SOME OF THE LESSONS LEARNED-
BECAUSE- I THINK WE WANT TO KNOW
WHERE THE STATE CAN FILL A GAP
AND WE'RE STATE WHERE THE STATE
CAN BRIDGE THE GAP. AND
COORDINATION SEEMS TO BE. A BIG
ISSUE- I'M FOR THE STATE AND
IT'S ALL OF THESE MUNICIPALITIES
- INYO COORDINATION IS NOTHING
NEW FOR EACH CD MOST OF WHERE
THAT OCCURS IS THROUGH OUR-
PROGRAMS THAT WE THAT WE OPERATE
THAT ARE REALLY A PRODUCTION
FOCUS SO YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR
WITH THE VETERANS HOUSING
HOMELESS PREVENTION. PROGRAM
FUNDED THROUGH- BY VOTER
APPROVED BONDS RIGHT WE BELONG
COLLABORATIVELY CALUMET ON THAT
FOR EXAMPLE SO WELL WE HAVE THE
EXPERTISE FOR EXAMPLE ON THE-
HOUSING COMPONENTS OR THE REAL
ESTATE COMPONENT APPLICATION
THERE AND- CAL THAT IS
EVALUATING THOSE SERVICE THE
SERVICE PLANS- IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THIS PLAN YOU KNOW WITH
THOSE PROPOSALS. AND OUT TO MAKE
SURE THEY ARE FOCUSED AND RIGHT
AND APPROPRIATE FOR VETERANS
POPULATION THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM IS A COLLABORATION ST
GROWTH COUNCIL- SO WE AGAIN
ACTUALLY ADMINISTERS THAT
PROGRAM BEHALF OF THE COUNCIL
BUT THE COUNCIL THEIR COURSE
DELIBERATING ON ON HOW THAT
PROGRAM IS ADEQUATELY
ADDRESSING. A ST STE CALDERON
CLAIM IT AS WELL. SO DOES IT OF
COURSE BEEN PROGRAMS THERE'S A
EXAM. AMONG MANY- IN TERMS OF
WHERE WE COME SO- ONE LET AND
THEN THE THERE'S A NEW. OF MAYBE
THIS IS THE POINT OF MAKE INTO
OF A LESSON LEARNED- WHERE WE
ARE DEPLOYING ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU TALK WE WANT ONE SPEAKS TO
FEDERAL FUNDS WERE DEPLOYING THE
FUNDS DOWN TO THE COMMUNITY
LEVEL. THEY'RE OFTEN TO ARM
ARGUMENT CONTINUES OF CARE
NURSING HOMELESSNESS- AND I
THINK WE HAVE TRIED TO COMBINE
THOSE WITH ROBUST TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THIS CONTAINS OF CARE
AS I KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA I C.
H. HAS- BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
REALLY. THIS IS AN OBSERVATION-
WE HAVE REALLY DILUTES THOSE
ENTITIES WITH QUITE A BIT OF
FUNDING OR THE LAST COUPLE YEARS
RIGHT IT TAKES TIME TO BUILD
THAT CAPACITY- MANY OF THEM MAY
BE UNDER RESOURCE FOR MANY YEARS
AND JUST IN THE IN THE COURSE OF
THE LAST FEW YEARS. I MEAN WE'RE
PUTTING BILLIONS INTO THE
SYSTEMS. AND I THINK- PART OF
THE FRUSTRATION OF THE SLOAN IS
THAT MANY OF US FEEL LIKE WE YOU
KNOW WE'RE RESPONSIBLE TO THE TO
THE FACTS FOR EXAMPLE ON ON HOW
THOSE LOCALS IN TORRANCE AND LOS
FINES- AND WE HAVE TO. DO I
THINK THE OBSERVATION THERE
RIGHT IS IT'S TAKEN THEM SOME
TIME. IN A COMPETITIVE
ENVIRONMENT IN AN ENVIRONMENT.
WHERE IT'S BEEN DIFFICULT TO
MAYBE ATTRACT. YOU KNOW. NOT
PROP EMPLOYMENT AND ALL THE SORT
OF- THEIR RAMP UP. AND I THINK
THAT SOME TO KEEP IN MIND AS WE
THINK ABOUT A LOT OF THESE
RESOURCES THAT ARE FLOWING DOWN.
LOCAL LEVELS- IT WAS VERY
ENTITIES YOU KNOW ARE ALSO
TRYING TO BUILD CAPACITY HAVE
BEEN OVER THE PAST COUPLE YEARS.
AS WE'VE GIVEN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT SOURCES RIGHT. I WILL
SPEAK TO THE I. C. CHOICES BUT
HE'S KEEPING HALF OF COURSE FOR
THOSE ENTITIES. WE A CD. S.
SIGNIFICANT FUSION. TO THE
CARRIAGE ACT- THAT WAS A SUCH A
GOOD THE MERCY SOLUTIONS GRANT
PROGRAM OVER THREE HUNDRED
MILLION ATTENDED ALSO FLOWED. TO
THOSE ENTITIES. I SEE A LOT OF
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS WITH
FEDERAL FUNDS OR STATE FUNDS AND
SO YOU'D THEY'RE DEALING WITH A
LOT OF THAT- SO THAT IS A LESSON
LEARNED I DON'T TO BE TOO. TOO
LONG IN MY ANSWER BUT I THINK
IT'S SOMETHING TO KEEP IN MIND-
THAT TO THE TO THE POINT I HEARD
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MONEY
ALONE IS NOT THE ANSWER THAT'S
WHAT WE THINK WE HAVE. YOUR
ROBUST TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS TO SEND TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES OVER THE PAST COUPLE
YEARS TO HELP NOT. ALL THE PLANS
FIGURE OUT HOW TO SPEND THOSE
MONIES. BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
FROM A CAPACITY STANDPOINT-
THERE STILL BUT DON'T GET
DRESSED. THEY'RE STILL RAMPING
UP AS WELL. SUCH AS ONE OF
PROBABLY SEVERAL LESSONS LEARNED
BECAUSE I THINK. THE PARTNERSHIP
WE TALK ABOUT WE'RE PRETTY I
THINK IT'S PRETTY GOOD AT THAT
AT THE STATE LEVEL ACROSS
DEPARTMENTS CERTAINLY IS ALWAYS
WITH YOU CAN IMPROVE UPON. BUT
THE LOCALS ARE PARTNERS HERE-
WILL YOU SUPPLY COUNTY WE NEED A
WILLING LOCAL PARK. WE'VE BEEN
THRILLED THE DIFFERENCE SO MANY
ONE LOCAL PARTNERS. RIGHT THERE
HAS TO BE THE WILL TO DO THOSE
EFFORTS THERE HAS TO BE THAT.
THE ATTENTION AT THOSE LOCAL
LEVELS. TO ALSO HIGHER UP. AND
WORK WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITY
BASED PROVIDER. A COMMUNITY AND
ALL THAT SORT OF STUFF SO THAT'S
ONE LESSON LEARNED IF I DIDN'T
GO. TO ACTUALLY LIKE HAPPY TO
EXPAND ELSEWHERE. NO THAT WAS
FINE I THINK IT'S HER FOR
NUMBER. TO COME. WHEN THEY FEEL
LIKE THEY'RE PART. ARE WORKING
AT CROSS. YOU KNOW DO. PLAN ARE
GREAT. AND IF FEEL LIKE THOSE
OTHER ENTITIES AREN'T TALKING TO
EACH OTHER AND WORKING TOGETHER
IN A COORDINATED FASHION IT
MAKES IT HARD FOR THE PEOPLE ON
THE STREETS. TO DO WHAT FOLKS
NEED TO SEE HAPPEN. BUT THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND THEN LASTLY MY
QUESTION TO CAL H. F. HEY WAS
YOU. SHARED SOME VERY EXCITING
INFORMATION AND GOOD NUMBERS- SO
WHAT HAVE YOU SEEN THAT WOULD
ALLOW US TO LEVERAGE YOU KNOW
YOUR FINANCING ABILITY. AT THE
STATE LEVEL TO LOWER
CONSTRUCTION COSTS FOR THESE
BILLS SO THAT WE CAN INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF FOLKS WHO ARE
HOUSED EITHER THROUGH UNIT SIR
OR IN HOMES. BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE YOU HAVE A VERY STRONG
LEVERAGING ABILITY FOR THE STATE. THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION-
YES- WE DO RELY ON LEVERAGING A
LARGE AMOUNTS OF- PRIVATE
CAPITAL AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING- THE MIXED INCOME
PROGRAM IS THE BEST EXAMPLE OF
THAT AND THE- AND THE MULTI
FAMILY LEVEL ON THE SINGLE
FAMILY FRONT ALL WE ALSO
LEVERAGE FIGHT LARGE AMOUNTS. OF
PRIVATE CAPITAL- ASMARA DON'T
THIS IS. UP ARE ARE BOTH OUR
PROGRAMS RELY ON PARTNERS WITH
PRIVATE- FOR EXAMPLE IN IN THE-
AND ON THE SINGLE FAMILY FRONT.
ALL LENDING DONE THROUGH FEDERAL
CAN FOR. LOANS DAD- WE CAN- DRAW
ON SECOND MARKET PRIVATE. AND
THAT'S IMPORTANT RIGHT. HE
MANAGED A EIGHT ONE TO TRY LEVEL
RATIO. IN THE FOR A STATE GUY WE
ARE WE SEE FOR PAYMENT WE ARE
ABLE TO. TWENTY DOLLARS I. DOWN
THE MESSAGE AND THE- ONLY REASON
WE'RE TO DO IS BECAUSE WE HAVE A
MODEL WHERE OUR LITTLE ARE
UNDERRATED. TO OF SAN CAN.
STANDARDS I SO THEN WHERE TO
PACKAGE FIRST MORE. AND SALAS IN
THE IN THE MORE TRILLION DOLLAR
- YOU KNOW NICE. MORE THAN SIX
MARKET UNTIL IS A IT'S A VERY
AND- YOU CAN HAVE SIZE THAT IF
WE WANT TO FIND. YOUR KIND OF
LOOKING FORWARD FROM MOBILE AND
NOT A COMMITTEE THAT I. LOOKING
ON FROM- DAD HOW WE- LOOK AT
SOME THAT. ARE GOING TO ATTRACT
PRIVATE CAPITAL AND THAT FOR. IN
A SINGLE TIME FRONT CONFORM TO
THESE FEDERAL STANDARDS WE CAN
DRAW ON THE ON THIS. MARKET
THAT'S LIKE THAT'S A BIGGER. TO
LEARN AND THEN ON THE- MORE
FAMILY FRONT OUT HOW CAN JUST
FROM FOR. ONE OF THEM EXCITING
THING WE ARE. WE'RE DOING TO
ATTRACT- CAPITAL. HE'S A NEW
RECYCLE BONTA- WE- IN I'M NOT
THIS. IS HE- AS OLD- BY OUTLOOK
CENTERS YOU KNOW YEAH. THE STATE. HE I THINK IT'S AN BOTTOM FOR.
IS ONE OF THE ST WE HAVEN'T- WE
YOU ALL DOLLAR. AND WE RESTS
THEM FOR A NEW. RIGHT AND THAT
ALLOW US THE NEW PART TO NOT
COUNT TOWARDS THIS. DAYS BIG
CONTENDERS LEMON DONE STATE AND
WE ABLE TO THIS. THE CANNOT COME
GONNA DOWN THAT WE'VE SET-
COMMITTEE ON ACTUALLY- TO BRING
WITH SOME LOCAL LIKE SEND AND I
COME FROM. TO NEXT- AND YOU KNOW
DISCUSS OF FINANCIAL MAKE WE
ABLE. TO OPPONENTS AG AND OTHERS
ARE DOING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M SO GLAD TO CLARIFY THAT
BECAUSE WHEN YOU SAID RECYCLING
BOND PROGRAM I WAS THINKING
BOTTLES AND I WAS LIKE WELL HOW
DOES THAT PLAY INTO HOMELESSNESS
MONEY SO. THANK YOU FOR THAT SO
NOW SENATOR WIENER I'M SURE YOU
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO ASK- THANK YOU- I'M-
SORRY SIR BUT- THE PERSON TERMS
OF. OUR PROJECT- HOME SHE- COULD
- YES IT SHOULD BE COMMENT ON-
IN TERMS OF TRANSITIONAL
OVERSEAS. HOUSING BREAK DOWN
THERE. YEAH HAVE YOU TO DO THAT-
THAT COCA UP THE ACTUAL EXACT
NUMBERS IF YOU LIKE FROM THE
FIRST GO ROUND- THERE'S A BLAND
AS WAS MENTIONED- OF WHAT WE
ALLOWED FOR ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
SPEED WITH WHICH WE'RE TRYING TO
OPERATE. OF THE INTERIM HOUSING
VERSUS PERMANENT HOUSING AND WE
ALSO SAW A NUMBER OF- PROJECT
ESSENTIALLY BEING RUN AS INTERIM
HOUSING THAT INTEND TO CONVERT
TO PERMIT HOUSING OVER TIME AND
THAT'S A GREAT FLEXIBILITY WE
THINK ABOUT THE LOCAL LEVEL
RIGHT BECAUSE THEY HAVE. THE
LUXURY OF HAVING SEVERAL OF
THESE PROJECTS YOU CAN KIND OF
PHASE THEM INAPPROPRIATELY- AND
MAKE SURE YOU'RE YOU'RE QUEUING
PEOPLE TO THEIR TO THE RIGHT-
THE WRITER MENTIONS SO TO SPEAK-
SO IN THE FIRST IN THE HOPE YOU
ONE POINT- THE NEXT. UP THE DATA
HERE. WE SAW- TWO THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY OF THE WERE PER
UNITS THOSE IMMEDIATELY COME OF
PERMITS. HOUSE AND NOT MY- ONES
FOUR NINE OR INTERIM AND THE
REMAINDER ARE GOING TO BE
INTERIM TO PERMANENT UNITS
220-005-0040 TWO- WE DO HAVE A
WE HAVE PUT UP A PUBLIC
DASHBOARD FOR WHOM HE TWO POINT
NO WE CAN ALSO SEE THE DATA AS
WE GO- BURKE. SECOND GO AROUND-
AND SO WE'RE WE KNEW WE
TYPICALLY SEE THAT. SEE THAT
KIND OF MAKE- ISSUES AT A PRICE
. IT'S NOT- AT LEVEL USUALLY ONE
THOSE INNER. RIGHT SO IF YOU'RE
DOING EIGHT ACQUISITION OF A
MULTI FAMILY BUILDING WITH WE'RE
NOW SEEING- IT IN GREATER
NUMBERS YOU'RE DOING A MOTEL
HOTEL CONVERSIONS. TYPICALLY
YOU'RE RUNNING THAT EITHER
INTERMENT PERMANENT IT'S NOT
LIKE HALF THE GENERAL MIN
HAPPENS PERMITTED IT'S ALL ONE
TYPE OF USE- IS THAT ADEQUATE
YOU HAVE ANY. THANK YOU SIR. A
GOAL FOR WHAT THE MIX. SHOULD BE
OR ABOUT. LONG RUNNING BOTH ROB
SUPER. IMPORTANT BUT THIS- WHAT
- SHOULD YEAH I MEAN WE AS YOU
MAY KNOW WE WERE TRY TO DRY A TO
PREVENT HOUSE- WE KNOW THAT.
THIS IS YOU KNOW HOW ALSO- AND
SO WE REALLY TO DRIVE A THAT WE
OF COURSE WITH OUR PARTNERS YOU
KNOW THE DO THEY GET OUT FOR THE
FLEX OF HERE. AND I THINK WE'RE
PRETTY PLEASED THAT MANY OF THE
ARE. EVEN IF THEY'RE GONNA RUN
AS INTER- INITIALLY ARE THE OVER
TO- THERE'S NOT WE DID NOT
PRESCRIBE A RECALL. KIND OF NEXT
THEIR BUT WE THROUGH THE PROGRAM
AT STRUCTURE ASSEMBLY DRAW. HOME
TO INCENTIVES TO PERMANENT HOUSE
SO- YOU'LL SET YOURSELF ABOUT.
ABOUT PERCENT OF THE GO AROUND
WAS ENTERING. ONLY AND I THINK
AS WE EVALUATE TO AS AS AS-
APLIK COMING IN IT DOES MATTER
ON THE COMMITTEE LED RIGHT YOU
SAW SOME. JURISDICTIONS COMING
FOR ONE HOME HE WENT NO THAT HAD
NEVER DONE EVEN IF HOUSING
PROJECT BEFORE. LET ALONE- HOW
DO HAD MY SHELTER SOONER HOUSING
MODEL ACTUAL ALLOW THEM TO A
THEY HAVE AN OFFICE SOME OF
EARLIER. WE LOOK AT SOME OF THE
WORD WE WILL DO TO NEED FROM
TRIBE. YOU KNOW- YOU KNOW SOME
COME IN THERE DON'T DO NEEDS SO
- WE DID TRY TO UP LIKE- BUT TO
GET YOUR QUESTION WE ARE TRYING
TO DRY BOOKS THE- SOLUTIONS. SO
WE HAVE A SKI THIRTY FIVE. WE
HAVE BEEN HOME SHE HAS ITS OWN
STREAMLINING. LEGISLATION US
STREAMLINED SPECIFIC SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING- IF HE'D SEE CITIGROUP
COMMENTS. YOU'RE NOT JUST FOR
HOMES HE WHICH HAS GONE. BUT THE
DECISION ON KEEP JUST IN GENERAL
WHAT IS FUND GOING OUT WHAT
WE'RE SEEING ON THE GROUND I
DON'T NEXT TITLE WILL HAVE BEEN
APPROVAL HOUSING BUILDER SURE
COMMENTS DETAIL BUT WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IN TERMS OF THE. YEAH
HELLO WHETHER THE APPROVAL
PROCESS ACCELERATED AS WE. TO
YEAH MEAN I THINK IT ALL CALLED
EXAM RIGHT- OUR ABILITY TO THE
FUNDS ON THE HOUSE CALIFORNIA
HOUSE CELERY YOU KNOW THAT WAS
THE BILLS WERE PROJECT THAT WERE
NOT STUCK YES IT'S ALL ABOUT
LOCAL. BUT BY THE FINAL PIECE OF
FINE TUNING SO IN BEING ABLE TO
MAKE THOSE AWARDS WAS ACTUALLY
FOR WITH THEY WOULD HAVE SOUGHT
FOR TAX RATES ARE BONDS THOSE
PROJECTS ARE GONNA BREAK WITHIN
SIX MONTHS RIGHT SO THAT'S THE
SAME REQUIREMENT THAT THEY HAVE
AT THE TAX CREDIT ALLOCATION
COMMITTEE AND SO WE'LL SEE A LOT
OF SPEED THERE AND OF COURSE AS
WE EVALUATE READINESS IN THOSE
PROGRAMS WERE MAKING SURE THEY
HAVE ALL THEIR ENTITLEMENTS AND
ALL THAT. STUFF ON THE BROUGHT
IN YOU KNOW THE HOKEY I MEAN. I
WILL JUST. REITERATE THE LOCAL
LAND USE CONFORMITY WAS VERY
INTEGRAL AND THE SPEED OF THOSE
PROJECTS IN TERMS OF SAYING THAT
ANY PROJECT. AUTOMATICALLY
COMPLAINTS THE LOCAL LAND USE
AND SO. NOT NOT TO GET TOO IN
THE WEEDS BUT THAT IS YOU KNOW
AWAY YOU KNOW IT CAN READ IT.
RIGHT A LOT OF- YOU KNOW WHAT
TYPICALLY MEMBERS OF THE BEARS
TO DELAYING HOUSING- ON THE ON
ON THE WHOLE. I MEAN I THINK I
THINK THE BEST THING TO TALK
ABOUT HERE'S OUR WORK WITH OUR
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY- D. YOU
KNOW OUR OUR STORIES ARE
FORTUNATE ORTIZ UNDER NUMBER OF
LAWS. ARE GOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL THE VARIOUS
STREAMLINING EFFORTS SB THIRTY
FIVE AND OTHERS. ARE HERE TO AND
USE PROBABLY ALREADY SEEN THAT
IN SOME OF SOME OF THE-
COMMUNICATIONS WE'VE HAD WITH
JURISDICTIONS SO FAR WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO BREAK. LOOSE
SEVERAL HOUSING PROJECTS. THAT
BY AT LEAST BEGINNING WITH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
REMINDING THOSE RESTRICTIONS OF
THEIR OBLIGATIONS- IN SOME CASES
HAVING TO ESCALATE- YEAH I THINK
IT. IS GOING TO BE QUITE HELPFUL
BECAUSE I THINK WHAT WE DO SEE
AN- A NUMBER OF STREAMLINING
MEASURES HAVE PASSED. AND OUR
CURRENT LAW. IS SO- ENFORCING
THOSE LAWS WILL BE QUITE
IMPORTANT. AS WE HIT THE NEXT
HOUSING ELEMENT CYCLE WHICH WERE
ALREADY IN- WE SEE THOSE
COMMITMENTS. AND THOSE RESOUNDS
AS A CONTRACT. YOU KNOW AND NOW
THAT WITH THE ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITIES WE HAVE. YOU KNOW
WE'RE GONNA HOLD COMMITTEES THAT
CONTRACT. AND WHILE- WELL OF
COURSE. THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
DO NOT HAVE TO BUILD THE HOUSING
THAT YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY WERE MOVING. DATE AFTER
AGAIN IF I ALL BARRIERS WITHIN
THEIR LOCAL PROCESS SHE'S. AND
THEY HAVE TO PROGRAMS THAT. WERE
AND SO NOW WITH BIRTH AND
PORTSMOUTH FORTY WE WILL BE A TO
CHECK. REGULARLY IF THERE IS A
IF THEY'RE HEARING TO WHAT
AGREED TO AND THERE PROTEST. AND
SO- THAT'S IS A COUPLE COUPLE
THINGS I'D SAY I'M I THINK. IT'S
A IT'S GOING TO BE A CONTINUED
AFTER I WOULD SAY OKAY REFERENCE
LEVEL ME SHE- TO ACT. A ARE
FORTUNATE ORTIZ OF COURSE ALWAYS
STARTING WITH TO. BUT ESCOLA WE
NEED. I THANK THANK YOU. FOR
THAT I DO JUST WANT TO. KNOW WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH DATA. ABOUT
HOW HOUSING. ARE BEING. SOME
WERE IF BIG DATA SOME AREAS WE
DON'T. WE HAVE TO WORK TO OUR TO
TRY TO. ARE ACT TO DATA- WORSE
LAST YEAR WE ARE A BILL SENATE
BILL FOR SOME SEVEN TRY TO FIX
OUR GOING. TO CORRECT OUR FUTURE
ARMSTRONG TO WITH THAT DECISION
BUT THE BASED WAS THAT IT SHOULD
BE AS- DOING ITS OWN DO PROCESS
- SO THE RESULT LITTLE BIT OF
TURF STUFF. ON BUT SO BE A LONG
AS- GETS COLLECTED. AT AM SO
WHERE ARE WE WITH- BUT- IT
SHOULD BE DATA COLLECTIONS PLANS
SO THAT WE HAVE COMPREHENSIVE
DATA ON. ALL OF THE STREAMLINING
ISSUED SOME AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF CIVIL WHERE
ARE WE SUPPOSED TO COME OUT IN
JANUARY. FILE YEAH UM YOU KNOW
STUFF HAPPENS- WHEN IS IT GOING
TO COME OUT WHAT IS IT GOING TO
LOOK LIKE- IT'S GOING TO INCLUDE
ALL THE ELEMENTS OF SP. FOR
SEVENTY SEVEN SINCE WE NEVER
HEARD OF POLICY OBJECTION. TO
THOSE- STUDIED- IT WAS MORE
ABOUT I THINK- BUT SERVICE YEAH
THANK. SO- SORRY SHOULD COMMENT
ON THAT. SURE I'LL NOTE-
ESPECIALLY IF A ARE NOT A- WE
I'VE BEEN TAKING A TEST APPROACH
TO DATA TURN AS WELL SO HAVE A
AND- I DON'T THINK PORTAL ON OUR
WEB THAT I FOLKS TO GO TO
BECAUSE HS A THE A PRO REPORT.
DE THESE DATA GOING AVAILABLE
YES I REALLY DO ENCOURAGE FOLKS
TEAMS THAT AND WE'VE SEEN AT
DEFINITELY GREATER INSURANCE TO
THAT REQUIREMENT TO SUBMIT THOSE
REPORTS OVER TIME CITIES AS THE
REQUIREMENTS HAVE GROWN AND SO
THAT IT THAT IS VERY HELPFUL FOR
DATA PERSPECTIVE WE WILL HAVE
AMPLE OUR STATE WHAT HOUSING
PLAN AND THE STATE DOES STRATEGY
OUT VERY VERY SOON- AND SO YOU
CAN LOOK FOR THAT IN THE COMING
WEEKS- AND- THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
AT WITH THAT WE WERE TRYING TO
ALIGN THE RELEASES OF THOSE TWO
THOSE TWO ACTORS BECAUSE WE
THINK THEY THINK THEY ARE. THEY
GOING COMPLIMENTS SO WITHOUT BE
OUT VERY SOON AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
OFFICE ON IT AFTERWARDS- OKAY SO
NOW WE WILL GO TO MEMBERS IN THE
COMMITTEE I SEE SENATOR COVER
HEROES MY GRAZED AND SENATOR
RON. MIKE REYES. THE SENATOR
CABALLERO AS MIKE WAS RATES
FIRST. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ASK A COUPLE QUESTIONS FIRST I
MEAN JUST THEM SAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY- WE HAVE PUT A LOT OF
MONEY INTO CIRCULATION AND I
THINK ARE A REAL ISSUE IS-
PRODUCTION. WHAT WHAT WHAT WHERE
HAVE WE GOTTEN THE BEST BANG FOR
OUR BUCK SO LET ME JUST START
OFF BY SAYING- THANK YOU AND
THAT THAT IF THERE ARE RESOURCES
THAT COME FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT HAVE TO BE. A
BIT HAVE A- A TIME LINE TO THEM
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE SPEND
DOWN TO THE PENNY- I DON'T WANT
TO SEE S. RETURN MONEY. OUGHT TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT
DAVE- AWARDED THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO HELP US DEAL WITH
OUR MOST INTRACTABLE ISSUES
BECAUSE OF KOVIN. I DON'T WANT
TO SEE S. NOT USE THAT MONEY SO
THAT'S GOING TO BECOME REALLY
IMPORTANT AND IF WE'VE- GOT
MONEY OUT TO OUR- CITY AND
COUNTY PARTNERS. WE'VE GOT TO BE
**** IT TO KNOW THAT THEY'RE
USING AT ON TIME AS WELL BECAUSE
WE CAN'T DEAL WITH THEM. SAYING
OH BY THE WAY I GOT A MILLION
BUCKS AND I DIDN'T USE IT- I WE
JUST COULDN'T USE IT IN TIME SO
THAT'S NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO IS-
THE KELLY CHIPPED A FIRST TIME
HOME BUYER PROGRAM- I'M
WONDERING IF YOU CAN GIVE US. A
MAP BY REGION. OF WHERE YOU'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DEPLOY. YOUR FIRST
TIME HOME BUYER PROGRAMS THE
DATA YOU GAVE US IS REALLY
EXCELLENT- BUT I HAVE HEARD FROM
SOME OF THE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT BUILD HOUSING
THAT. ACCESSING THE FIRST TIME
HOME BUYER PROGRAM HAS BEEN
PROBLEMATIC AND SO IT MAY BE
THAT IT. THAT IT'S BY THAT IT'S
BECAUSE OF SOME OF THE-
REQUIREMENTS THAT BETTER THERE
AND I'D I'D LIKE THIS TO
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT BETTER.
ON TO THE QUESTIONS- THIS ONE IS
FOR THE INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS IN EACH CD. THE
SACRAMENTO BEE REPORTED THAT-
THREE ROOM KEY PROJECTS ARE SET
TO CLOSE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
WHICH TOGETHER. TOGETHER
TEMPORARILY HOUSE THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THREE HOMELESS
PEOPLE. THE COUNTY STAFF ARE
REPORTEDLY TRYING TO FIND OTHER
HOUSING OPTIONS ARE HOTELS FOR
THOSE BEING DISPLACED AND SO.
THAT'S REALLY DISTRESSING- IF WE
ALL WORK UP HERE SO WE
UNDERSTAND AND SEE. THE SEVERITY
OF THE HOMELESSNESS PROBLEM HERE
LOCALLY- AND IT'S JUST A
MICROCOSM OF WHAT YOU SEE ALL
OVER THE STATE AND- TO. TO HAVE
COME UP WITH A SOLUTION THAT.
PUTS PEOPLEIN HOUSING FOR A
YEAR OR TWO AND THEN BASICALLY
TO NOT HAVE A SOLUTION A LONG
TERM SOLUTION IS. I THINK
UNACCEPTABLE AND- THE PUBLIC IS
JUST NOT GOING TO UNDERSTAND IT
I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT FRANKLY SO
I'M WONDERING IF. IF IF THERE'S
A STRATEGY. FOR THE FACT THAT
THOSE RESOURCES MAY BE ENDING
AND SHOULD WE HAVE BEEN PLANNING
BETTER. FOR A TRANSITION INTO
OTHER KINDS OF HOUSING AND- AND
BASICALLY WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. THAT AS
WE TALK ABOUT HOUSING THAT WE'RE
NOT. WE'RE NOT CREATING
TEMPORARY SOLUTIONS THAT DON'T
GET US ANYWHERE DOWN THE ROAD. I
CAN START A SLUSH SO I'M
DEFINITELY AGREED AROUND THE NET
THE IMPERATIVE TO HAVE A FULL
CONTINUUM OF SOLUTIONS I THINK I
MENTIONED EARLIER IN OUR ACTION
PLAN FOR PREVENTING AND ENDING
HOMELESSNESS IT WAS INCLUSIVE
OF. A RANGE OF SOLUTIONS
INCLUDING EMERGENCY TEMPORARY
AND LONGER TERM HOUSING OPTIONS
I WILL SAY THAT THE ROOM KEY.
SIMILAR BY OUR PARTNERS AT CVS
SO I DON'T TO PRESUME. OR I'M
SPEAK ON THEIR BEHALF ON WHAT
PLANS THE NINE. DOWNSHIFT
EFFORTS. BUT I WILL SAY THERE
ARE A COUPLE OF THAT I THINK-
MARK ARE SORT OF OUR GRANTS WORK
IS ABLE TO DO IS TO PROVIDE OUR-
PARTNERS WITH THE ABILITY TO.
REPROGRAM FUNDS SO THAT THEY CAN
. AS NECESSARY THE- ON WHAT THE
SOLUTION MIGHT BE. SO I GUESS I
TAKE FROM THAT THAT IT'S UP TO
THE LOCAL LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
COME UP WITH THE PLANT AND I
GUESS- ONE OF THEM. ONE OF THE-
I UESS SEVEN POINT I'D I'D PUT
ON IT ACT. I UNDERSTAND
COMPLETELY THAT WE HAVE PUT OUT
FUNDS. IN A REALLY RAPID. ON A
REALLY RAPID BASIS AND THAT MANY
OF THE- CCA'S DID NOT HAVE A
PLAN A LONG TERM PLAN. FOR WHAT
NEEDED TO HAPPEN IT WAS IT WAS
IT WAS EMERGENCY- GET PEOPLE
INTO HOUSING IMMEDIATELY WITHOUT
THE LONG TERM PLAN OF OKAY NOW
WHAT ONCE ONCE WE HAVE AMEND THE
HOUSING WHERE DO THEY MOVE. THAT
PROVIDES A SEMI PERMANENT OR
PERMANENT SOLUTION FOR A WHILE
SO I GET THAT IT IN MANY WAYS
IT'S REALLY NOT FAIR BUT I
REALLY THINK. THAT THE PLANNING
THAT ALL OF THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE GOING TO BE
DOING. AROUND HOME THE HOMELESS
ISSUE. HAS TO INCLUDE HOW MANY
PEOPLE HAVE WE GOTTEN OFF THE
STREETS AND ARE THEY OFF THE
STREETS. ENOUGH ENOUGH. IN A
PERMANENT AS MUCH AS YOU CAN SAY
PERMANENT- SOLUTION BECAUSE- I
THINKALL OF US ARE FEELING
REALLY FRUSTRATED THAT THE
PROBLEM SEEMS TO GROW BIGGER
EVERY DAY DESPITE THAT THE-
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT WE'VE
PUT OUT. AND AND MY FRUSTRATION
PERSONALLY IS THAT IT'S REALLY
HARD FOR ME TO GET REPORTS FROM
MY CCA'S LOCALLY IT'S DONE BY
COUNTY AND SO I HAVE SIX
COUNTIES IN TRYING TO GET
INFORMATION ON. ON REAL DATA
WHAT HOW MANY PEOPLE HOW MANY
FAMILIES- HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO
ASSIST IS GOING TO BE REALLY
IMPORTANT SO IT'S NOT JUST HOW
MANY HOURS OF SERVICE OR- HOW
MANY. TONS OF- PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS HAVE WE PASSED OUT IT'S
REALLY IT HAD REALLY HAS TO DO
WITH HOUSING AND I'M NOT I'M NOT
I'M TRYING NOT TO BE CRITICAL
BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
THAT WE PUT OUT ALL THIS MONEY
AND NOW WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO BUILD A CAR- AND
WE'VE DRIVEN IT A LITTLE BIT-
BUT I REALLY HOPEFULLY THE
PLANTS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
COMING OUT. THE LOCAL ACTION
PLAN TO BY JUNE WILL WILL HAVE
SOME REALLY GOOD QUANTITATIVE
MEASURES SO WE CAN EVALUATE.
WHAT WELL SO THAT WE CAN SAY.
WHO'S DONE IT WELL. BEYOND AND-
HOW HAVE THEY DONE IT AND CAN WE
REPLICATE IT IN OTHER PARTS OF
THE STATE- BECAUSE- THIS THIS IS
. IT'S A IT'S A AND I KNOW YOU
KNOW IT'S A HUMANITY ISSUE AND
IT'S AN ISSUE THAT WE HAVE TO
GET OUR ARMS AROUND. EVEN IF
IT'S GOING TO TAKE US A LONG
TIME WE'VE GOT TO START HAVING
SOME SUCCESSES SO I GUESS I'M I
WON'T WILL BE THIS TOO MUCH MORE
BECAUSE I. I THINK YOU'RE DOING
A GREAT JOB BUT I REALLY DO WANT
TO SEE THE PLANS AND I WANT TO
SEE- WHERE DO WE NEED TO PUT OUR
RESOURCES SO WE'RE ACTUALLY
BUILDING. THANK YOU RIGHT I
DON'T HAVE ANY MORE QUESTIONS
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SENATOR AND
NOW WE ARE GOING TO HEAR FROM
SENATOR RAWSON AN AXE AFTER THAT
I SEE THAT SENATOR- CHILLED BOWL
HAS HER. A MICROPHONE UP WHOLE
KATIE AND THEN SENATOR CORTESE.
SENATOR ROB. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR YOU KNOW- WE TALK ABOUT
THE- THE HOMELESSNESS SITUATION
WITH REGARD TO THAT DISCUSSION I
JUST HAVE A QUICK QUESTION A
COUPLE QUICK OTHER ONES. WITH
RESPECT TO THE HOMELESSNESS
SITUATION DO WE DO WE KNOW WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF OUR HOMELESS
POPULATION IS NOT INTERESTED IN
. PERMANENT BRICK AND MORTAR
HOUSING. AS SOON AS PRETTY LOW
BUT I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THE QUESTION AND WITH REGARD TO
THAT POPULATION WHAT DO WE
PROPOSE TO DO ABOUT THEM. WOULD
SOMEONE LIKE TO TAKE A CRACK AT
THAT I DON'T THINK HE WAS ASKING
ME. I'M HAPPY TO. START US OFF
SO I THINK TO THE TO THE- MORE
COMPLEX ISSUE OF- WHAT WHAT
FOLKS SORT OF SOMETIMES REFERRED
TO AS SERVICE RESISTANCE I THINK
IT'S A MUCH MORE COMPLEX ISSUE.
AND ONE THAT WE CONTINUE TO-
WORK TOWARDS UNDERSTANDING SO
ONE OF THE THINGS TO BE THAT WE
OFTEN THINK OUR IN OUR
HOMELESSNESS ROUTE IS- WE MUST
ENSURE THAT THERE ARE SERVICE
RICH ENVIRONMENTS THAT FIRST AND
FOREMOST START OFF WITH HOUSING.
THAT PROVIDE A RANGE OF SERVICES
THAT ARE PROGRAMS THAT
INDIVIDUAL SO THAT THE HELP THAT
WE ARE PROVIDING IS INELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUAL THAT NEEDS AT A WIN
THAT MEANS IS THAT. PEOPLE ARE
ABLE TO ACCESS THE CARE THEY
NEED ASKING YET. YEAH I THINK
THE SORT OF THE ART OF MAKING
THAT HAPPEN IT'S A VERY COMPLEX
ENDEAVOR- WELL NOT COVERED
WITHIN THE PURVIEW OF WHAT WE
DISCUSSED TODAY. I DO THINK THAT
THE RANGE OF INVESTMENTS IN THE
SERVICE PORTION OF HOMELESSNESS.
THE SERVICE PORTION OF THE
HOMELESSNESS RESPONSE SYSTEM
WILL AID IN ASSURING A WIDER
VARIETY OF SERVICE OPTIONS ARE
AVAILABLE. BUT YOU KNOW TO THE
TO THE SORT OF YOUR CORE
QUESTION AROUND WHETHER WE ARE
CERTAIN OF WHAT. PROPORTION OF
PEOPLE ARE OURS TO REFUSING
SERVICE ARE UNABLE TO APPROACH
THAT I THINK WE TEND TO THINK OF
IT AS JUST I'M- MORE OF A OF A
MATCHING OF SERVICES TO THE NEED
ISSUE WE DO OUR POINT IN TIME
COUNTS AND TO TRY TO DETERMINE.
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY
HOMELESS IN. IN COMMUNITIES AND
COUNTIES I'M JUST WONDERING IF
WE- ACTUALLY TRY TO DETERMINE
HOW MANY OF THOSE WHO ARE
HOMELESS ARE HOMELESS BECAUSE
THEY'VE LOST THEIR JOBS. AND
THEY REALLY WANT A HOUSE OR AN
APARTMENT OR WHATEVER. HOW MANY-
HAVE NOT HAVE JOBS BUT AREN'T
ABLE TO AFFORD A HOME OR AN
APARTMENT. IN WHAT AN INCH OF
THOSE PEOPLE. WE ON STREET OR
OTHERWISE. WHO ARE PERFECTLY
CONTENT WITH THEIR LIVES WHETHER
WE'RE CONTENT WITH THE TYPE OF
LIFE THAT THEY'VE CHOSEN. FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS- I WOULD
THINK THAT WOULD BE IMPORTANT.
IN TERMS OF MAKING FUNDING
DECISIONS AND WHERE WE PUT OUR
MONEY. AND I GESS THE ANSWER IS
WE DON'T COLLECT THAT DATA IS
THAT CRIMINALS. SO I'M A FOLLOW
UP TO THAT THERE IS A SERVER
THAT'S CONNECTED TO THE POINT IN
TIME COUNT THE PREVAILING
KNOWLEDGE IS NOT THE PRIMARY
REASON FOR HOMELESSNESS IS THE
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS THAT
CONTINUES TO BE THE DRIVING
SOURCE OF HOMELESSNESS. AND THE
BARRIERS AND THE REASON WHY
PEOPLE BECAME HOMELESS IN THE
FIRST PLACE. SO THAT THAT THAT
IS WHAT WE UNDERSTAND THE ISSUE
DRIVEN BY WELL I CAN TELL YOU
FROM AN ANECDOTAL STANDPOINT
THE- REVEREND PEOPLE- SOME
VETERANS. THAT I HAVE. SPOKEN TO
ON THE STREET WHO ARE HOMELESS-
VERY INTELLIGENT PEOPLE. A
COLLECTION OF LIBRARY BOOKS OR
THEIR OWN BOOKS WHICH IS A
LIBRARY IN THE SHOPPING CART
THAT THEY READ WHEN THEY'RE ON
THE STREET. WHAT MADE A
CONSCIOUS DECISION TO REMAIN
THERE AND I THINK WE PROBABLY
OUGHT TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
BUT- I DON'T WANT TO BELABOR
THIS QUESTION EITHER. ME S. MICE
MY SECOND ONE YOU KNOW. FOR
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE AT THAT
HAVE A HIGH PERCENTAGE OF
COLLEGE STUDENTS. BUT THE
COMMUNITIES SEEK TO HOUSE AND I
REALIZED THAT STUDENTS ROLL OVER
EVERY. FOUR OR FIVE OR SIX YEARS
BUT THE NUMBER GENERALLY REMAINS
CONSTANT. HAS ENTERED AS ABILITY
MOVEMENT TO. COUNT THAT
ADDITIONAL HOUSING THAT
COMMUNITIES ATTEMPT TO PROVIDE
THOSE STUDENTS. AGAINST THE
COMMUNITY RINA ALLOCATION. I
BELIEVE THAT THE QUESTION FOR
CAN DORMITORIES COUNT TOWARDS A
COMMUNITIES ARENA WELL I THINK
THAT'S IT'S A LITTLE MORE
NUANCED THAN THAT BECAUSE WE ALL
UNDERSTAND WHAT A DORMITORY IS
BUT THERE ARE CERTAIN TYPES OF
HOUSING THAT COULD BE
CONSTRUCTED OFF CAMPUS. WHICH
MAY OR MAY NOT MEET THE EXISTING
AT LEAST AS I UNDERSTAND IT
DEFINITION OF HOUSING THAT
COUNTS AGAINST RINA STUDENTS MAY
NEED A DIFFERENT TYPE OF
HOUSING. THAN SOMEBODY IN THE
FAMILY WHO WORKS OR OF C. PERSON
WHO WORKS- WITH OR WITHOUT
FAMILY. IF IT IS PERMANENT
HOUSING OFF SITE WORKS
REPRESENTS A LEASE IT'S ALWAYS
GOING TO BE ELIGIBLE. TOWARDS A
RENEWAL. IS IT HAVE TO MATTER
LOOK. DOES IT HAVE TO HAVE A
FULL KITCHEN. DOES IT HAVE TO
HAVE COULD HAVE SHARED BATHROOM
FACILITIES- THOSE ARE LIKE I
MEAN I THINK THOSE OF THE- CITY
I THINK THOSE ARE THE OBSTACLES
AT LEAST AS I UNDERSTOOD. THAT
IT OR UNDERSTAND IT AND MY
QUESTION IS WHERE YOUR STUDENT
POPULATION IS CONSTANT. FOR
EXAMPLE THE LARGEST CITY IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. HAS FOR
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES WITHIN
AS THE CITY LIMITS. SO OBVIOUSLY
SOMEONE HAS TO PROVIDE THAT
HOUSING BECAUSE THE UNIVERSITIES
AND COLLEGES ARE UNABLE TO FULLY
PROVIDED AND WHEN THE COMMUNITY
DOES. WHICH TAKES UP A LAND
WHICH TAKES OF RESOURCES DOES
THAT HOUSING. KALYAN'S THE
REALLOCATION. SO JUST A
CLARIFICATION THE REALLOCATION
IS ABOUT WHAT NEEDS TO BE ZONED
FOR SO WE'RE EVALUATING HOW-
HOUSING- IT'S ABOUT WHAT HAS TO
BE ZONED TO ACCOMMODATE THAT THE
ULTIMATELY WHAT IS NOT THERE
WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
JURISDICTIONS TO MAKE SURE
COMPLIANCE- BUT TO BE CLEAR IT'S
THE ZONING THAT IS REQUIRED SO
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE HIS OWN
THAT LAND TO ACCOMMODATE A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF PARCELS OR
HOMES- WHEN THEY GET TO THE
SITE'S INVENTORY IN ORDER TO BE
COMPLIANT WITH THREE. DAN HOW
THE NEED THAT REMAINS WHAT
THEY'RE PERMITTING IS A LITTLE
BIT OF A SEPARATE PROCESS BUT
HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
JURISDICTIONS AS THE KIND OF A
BILL THAT CONTRACT ON THE READ
IT TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
COMPLIANT WELL GOOD I'LL WILL
FOLLOW UP ON AN ISSUE AND
FINALLY. ONE ONE LAST QUESTION.
WITH REGARD TO THE VERY PROGRAMS
THE LOW INCOME. HOUSING TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM THE HOME BUYING
ASSISTANT PROGRAM ANY OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT. THEY WERE LISTED
IN THE L. A. O.'S- DISCRETIONARY
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
SPENDING AUGMENTATION- LIST HOW
DO WE ENSURE THAT THERE IS
FUNDING EQUITY WITH REGARD TO
THESE PROGRAMS AMONG THE VARIOUS
REGIONS IN THE STATE I'M TALKING
COASTAL URBAN VERSUS INLAND. MAY
NOT BE TO TAKE THAT EVERY EACH
AND EVERYONE OF OUR PROGRAMS AS
GEOGRAPHIC TARGETS- IN THE DATA
WE PROVIDED THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS WHICH I'M HOPING YOU
SEEN HAVEN'T YOU KNOW HOPE WILL
BE SHARED WITH YOU SOON- WE
OUTLINED WHAT THOSE BREAKDOWNS
ARE. SO YOU KNOW I WAS HERE JUST
A COUPLE ANECDOTES- YOU KNOW I
MENTIONED HUNKY THIRTY FIVE
DIFFERENT COUNTIES MANY COUNTIES
THAT NEVER EVEN PARTICIPATE IN A
FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY DIFFERENT
SITES AND- POINT OVERSEEING
THIS. A REALLY GREAT GEOGRAPHIC
SPREAD THERE. IN ORDER TO INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM AS
I MENTIONED WE HAVE WILL BE
SMALL COMMUNITIES AND A LARGER
SUCCESSFUL JURISDICTION A LARGE
JURISDICTION SET ASIDE. AND OF
COURSE HAVE TARGETS BETWEEN ON
NORTHERN SOUTHERN AND CENTRAL OR
OR MORE RURAL AREAS SOME OF OUR
PROGRAMS HAVE SPECIFIC RULES SET
ASIDES- OFTEN FOR OVER THE
COUNTER PROGRAMS AS WE DON'T
WITH COMPLETELY IF WE SET
REGIONAL SATISFIED. UP UNTIL A
POINT TO ALLOW THEM TO SENSUALLY
TAP INTO THOSE DOLLARS JUST IN
THE REGION. OF FIRST BEFORE
THEY'RE DEPLOYED TO KIND OF A
GENERAL COMPETITION POOL AND-
YOU MAY TOTALLY RIGHT AT HOME
KEY- EACH AND EVERY REGION WAS
OVERSUBSCRIBED AND WE'RE ABLE TO
ALLOCATE WITHIN THOSE REGIONS
AND SO- THERE IS A VERY
INTENTIONAL EFFORT. TO DO THAT
AT LEAST WITH AN H. P. PROGRAMS
AND HAVING SPEAKING PROGRAM.
SPECIFICS WHAT ARE THE TARGETS
POPULATION BASED DURING THIS
TRAINING I MEAN. YOU CAN HAVE
TARGETS AND YOU CAN ASSIGN A
TARGET TO REGIONS AND THAT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN THERE'S
FUNDING EQUITY BETWEEN THE
REGIONS AND SO I'M JUST SORT OF
CURIOUS AS TO. HOW THE PROCESS
WORKS YES THOSE ARE ALL DRAWN
BASED ON POPULATION AND
DEPENDING UPON THE PROGRAM
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE SOME. SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS WHEN YOU MAY THINK
ABOUT OUR FORMER POPULATIONS WE
MIGHT SEE. A DIFFERENT TYPE OF
POPULATION OR NEEDS BASED
ANALYSIS ON WHAT THOSE LAWS- THE
SPREADING TO BE. SO EVERY
PROGRAM IS DIFFERENT WE DO HAVE
A NUMBER OF TARGET CAN EACH
PROGRAMS FOR SPECIFIC
SUBPOPULATIONS SO WE TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THOSE. THOSE
SUBPOPULATION DATA. OF THE FOR
GENERAL PROGRAMS. IT IS.
CONTENDED PICCOLI EQUITABLE IT
AND ALL ALL KEY WE'RE- REQUIRED
TO DO THAT I STATURE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SPONSOR THANK YOU MA'AM
FOR YOUR- THANK YOU SENATOR ROB
SO NOW WE WILL. FROM SO. OR GOOD
MORNING AND WE'RE- LIKE TO THE
POWER FOR. THEIR TESTIMONY
MORNING. SURE THIS GRANT. FIRST
OF ALL I LIKE TO THINK UP
SENATOR FROTHING COVER YOUR FOR
THE QUESTIONS I SHARE THE SAME
CONCERN THE SAME THOUGHT PROCESS
THAT YOU FOLKS HAVE EXPRESSED
THIS MORNING TO THANK YOU FOR
SHEREEN ARE ASKING THOSE
QUESTIONS. MY QUESTION WOULD BE-
FOR THE- FOR THE FIRST PANEL OF
COURSE THE- QUESTION IS AS
FOLLOWS WHEN ANALYZING THE ROOT
CAUSES OF HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH WHICH STATE
PROGRAMS HAVE PROVEN TO BE THE
MOST EFFECTIVE AT ASSISTING
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. SO I DON'T
KNOW OF THE L. A. O. THE OFFICES
ON BUT THEY TOO COULD ALSO MAYBE
HELP ADDRESS THAT. BECAUSE OF
COURSE I'M SURE EACH PANELIST
WOULD SAY IT WAS THERE BUT- OF
COURSE I ALSO SAW MS LOW SO IF
YOU WANT TO TAKE A CRACK AT IT.
FEEL FREE. THANK YOU I'M SORRY I
DO WANT TO FIND A COUPLE. THINGS
THAT TELL A CH IS UNDER WAY
WITH. I THINK IT BACK WILL.
IMPART ADDRESS SOME OF THE SOME
OF THE SORT OF. WHAT DRIVES THAT
QUESTION SO AS I MENTIONED IN
MY- EARLIER TESTIMONY ARE
WORKING ON A STATE WIDE
LANDSCAPE ASSESSMENT THE PURPOSE
OF THAT ASSESSMENT. IS TO FIRST
UNDERSTAND- SORT OF- THE
RESOURCES THAT WERE- DEVELOPED-
THROUGH THE- FUNDING FOR THE
STATE'S FUNDING FOR LAST SEVERAL
YEARS. AND THEN A SECOND
QUESTION ABOUT RESEARCH WILL BE
CONDUCTED ON SPECIFIC
INTERVENTIONS- IN LOOKING AT. A
LOCAL SYSTEMS OF CARE SO WHILE.
I THINK I'LL I'LL I'LL DEFER TO
OUR PARTNERS ALEJO I THINK WE'LL
HAVE. WILL BE ABLE TO STEP BACK
TO PROVIDE A BROADER PICTURE OF
WHAT THEIR VIEWS ARE ON THIS.
AND WE ARE EAGER TO BRING FORTH. THE RESULTS BACK LATER THIS
YEAR. AND MORNING ONCE AGAIN AND
HAS MORE HONEST WITH THE L. L.
AS PASSED. A MAJOR DRIVER OF
HOMELESSNESS IN THE STATE IS THE
AFFORDABILITY HOUSING CRISIS.
AND SENSITIVE OVER TIME TO
BUILDING MORE HOUSING- SO THAT
PRICES HAVE. COME DOWN ON PRICES
AS HIGH AS THEY HAVE BEEN IN
RECENT YEARS WILL BE SORT OF THE
ROOT- ROOT RESPONSE TO
ADDRESSING THOSE UNDERLYING
ISSUES- OVERTIME. IN THE NEAR
TERM WE KNOW THAT WE NEED FOR
THE SHORT TERM SOLUTIONS TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS. IMMEDIATE
BEFORE THE STATE. AND- AS- JUNE
JUNE LOWERED HER MENTION HERE
THERE- IT'S AN SS BEING DONE
THAT WILL COME AND FOR. WHICH
PRO HAVE SORT OF. MOST OF TODAY
AND WILL HAVE GUIDE. TO OVERTURN
- THE CHALLENGE THAT THERE IS
LIMITED DATA ON EXACTLY HOW.
FUNDING HAS BEEN USED- THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PRODUCED A
REPORT ON THE FIRST YEAR. HE
SPENDING FROM TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND WE HAVE SOME
INITIAL DATA FROM THE FIRST YEAR
IT. HAPPENED TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY OF THESE ARE ONLY INITIAL
ASSESSMENT OF HOW FLEXIBLE
FUNDING. TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE BEEN USED AND WE ALSO KNOW
THAT. THE STATE HAS MODIFIED
WHAT'S ABILITY TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN RECENT YEARS
WE'VE TALKED A LOT TODAY ABOUT.
HAVING MORE LOCAL ACTION PLANS
THAT ARE SHOULD HAVE ROUTED IT
IN DATA SO THAT WE CAN TRACK
ACCOUNTABILITY OVER TIME. IT
WILL TAKE. TAKE TAKE TIME FOR
OUR- FOR THAT DATA TO BE
AVAILABLE TO THE STATE. PERFECT
I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THAT
THE- COLLECTION THEY DO THAT.
JUST GATHERING AND ON THAT NOTE
I DO HOPE THAT- WE DO SOMETHING
WITH- ANSWERING SENATOR ROBERTS
QUESTION. AND IT'S ANOTHER
COUPLE YEARS I DID WANNA MENTION
REALLY QUICK THAT THERE IS A-
THAT THERE IS A GROUP IN MY IN
MY DISTRICT THAT HAS BEEN
INTERESTING JOB THE COST IN
HOMELESSNESS. IN GETTING PEOPLE
INTO AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND THEN
DOING- PROVIDING WRAP AROUND
SERVICES- TO HELP INDIVIDUALS
LEARN- FINANCIAL LITERACY. AS
WELL AS AB GETTING JOB SKILLS
TRAINING- TO GET HIM INTO
EVENTUALLY WHAT WOULD BE
PERMANENT HOUSING AND THEY'VE
BEEN VERY VERY SUCCESSFUL
SOMETHING THAT WE MIGHT WOULD
NOT LOOK AS A MODEL- IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE BUT IT IS MY
DISTRICT ARE BE MORE THAN HAPPY
TO SHARE THAT INFORMATION WITH
ANYONE WHO MAY BE INTERESTED. IN
CONNECT THEM. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR- OTOBO SOLD NOW WE
WILL HAVE QUESTIONS FROM SENATOR
CORTESE AND THEN AFTER THAT
SENATOR NELSON SENATOR CORTESE.
THANK YOU MEASURE AND- I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS A COUPLE
COMMENTS. ONE OF THEM IS- AS TO
THE QUESTION THAT THOSE SENATE
ROTH WAS. WAS BRINGING UP- IT'S
NOT MY ROLE TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION ON. A STATEWIDE BASIS
BUT CERTAINLY IN OUR COUNTY
SANTA CLARA COUNTY THE POINT IN
TIME COUNT THE CENSUS THOSE. A
PRESENT THE QUESTION- AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT- THE DION HOUSE
INDIVIDUALS WILLING TO- ENROLL
OR IN INTO HOUSING- DESPITE THE
FACT THAT THERE'S NO HOUSING
AVAILABLE FOR THEM AT THAT
MOMENT THEY ARE ASKED THAT
QUESTION THAT. THAT HAS BEEN
RUNNING THE LAST FEW YEARS AT
APPROXIMATELY 3% NO 97% YES- BUT
IT'S NUANCED IN TERMS OF FOLKS
WHO ARE WILLING TO GO INTO GROUP
COULTER'S VERSUS FOLKS WERE
WILLING TO GO AN INDIVIDUALIZED
- RESIDENTIAL SETTINGS- LAKE.
INDIVIDUALIZED TINY HOMES OR- OR
SUCH- SO I BELIEVE TO. THAT
INFORMATION MAY BE AVAILABLE IN
OTHER COUNTIES ARE DOING POINT
IN TIME CENSUS- MODELING. ALONG
THE SAME TYPE OF Q. AND A TO THE
TO THE UN HOUSED INDIVIDUALS AT
THEIR ENCOUNTERING IN THE FIELD
AND THAT INFORMATION SHOULD BE-
SHOULD BE. SORT OF TRICKLING UP
OR UP LOADED THE TO THE
STATEWIDE DATA I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION TO UNDERSTAND
AS WE- CONTINUE TO TRY TO
DETERMINE. WHERE THE INVESTMENT
SHOULD GO IN IN TERMS OF- OF THE
SHELTER SIDE OF THINGS
PARTICULARLY- IT WHETHER OR NOT
- HERE PUTTING ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS INTO INTO. A GROUP TYPE
STUDIES IS GOING TO GET US UP
MUCH LESS RETURN ON INVESTMENT
SO TO SPEAK SO I DON'T KNOW-
THAT THAT RESPONSE HEALTH CENTER
ROTH AT ALL BECAUSE YOU PROBABLY
ALREADY KNOWS THAT ROLE TO HIS
TO HIS OWN HOME TURF BUT I THINK
THE REAL ISSUE IS- IF WE DON'T
HAVE THAT INFORMATION AT THE
STATE AND I THINK HE SAID THAT-
THAT WE SHOULD BE GATHERING THAT
WE HAVE FROM THE LOCAL COUNTY
SO. WHICH IS IT A COMMON UNLESS
SOMEBODY WANTS TO RESPOND- ALONG
THOSE LINES. I'M TO CONTINUE IF
YOU DON'T BUY MELCHER- I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT. THIS GRAPH ON
PAGE THREE OF. THE L. A. O.'S-
HANDOUT. WHICH IS RECENT TRENDS
IN PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. YOU KNOW IN EIGHT
EITHER OBVIOUSLY OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S BEEN RELATIVELY
SPEAKING- SOME SUCCESS IT IT
REDUCING- OR SHELTERING PEOPLE-
YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF KEEPING.
KEEPING NUMBERS FLAT BUT THE
UNSHELTERED NUMBERS HERE. OUR.
YOU TO MOVING UP AT A PRETTY
RAPID PACE IN IT MY CONCERN IS.
HOW ARE WE MAKING DECISIONS
BUDGET WISE TO GET BACK TO WHY
WE'RE HAVING THIS HEARING IN THE
FIRST PLACE. IN TERMS OF THIS
GOING BACK THIS ISSUE INTERIM
HOUSING OR SHELTER. A PERSON'S
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING-
THAT'S THE QUESTION IN IMAGES
THAT ADDITIONAL BACKDROP REAL
QUICKLY- I KNOW THE- WE'VE HEARD
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT ALREADY
- I KNOW THAT HIDE FOR EXAMPLE
HAS SINCE THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION PUT A TREMENDOUS
- PREMIUM ON PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING VERSUS
SHELTER- BUT ALSO NOTE THAT. UP
FROM HIS THE MANY MANY- OF OUR
OUR PEER CITIES IN THIS REGARD
IN OTHER STATES THE- IT WAS
REALLY DRIVEN BY AN EAST COAST
MENTALITY WHERE PEOPLE. HAVE
BEEN SHELTERED HAVE BEEN
WAREHOUSE FOR LONG PERIODS OF
TIME IN VERY COLD WEATHER STATES
WHERE THEY COULD NOT LEAVE THE
ON HOUSING SHELTERED. IN THAT
PUSH. UP FOR SO CALLED HOUSING
FIRST OR PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING- WAS INTENDED TO. TWO
ELITE V. EIGHT- THAT WAREHOUSING
OF PEOPLE AND GET THEM INTO
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING OUT
OF SHELTERS INTO PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING HERE
CALIFORNIA. AREN'T SHELTERED AS
EVIDENCED BY THIS GRAPH AND ALL
KINDS OF OTHER INFORMATION
BEFORE US ARE RIPARIAN CORRIDORS
CREAKS UNDERPASSES- SIDEWALKS.
IT EITHER WE OBVIOUSLY DON'T
HAVE- WE DON'T HAVE ANYWHERE
NEAR THE CAPACITY WE NEED IN
TERMS OF SHELTER WE'RE NOT WE'RE
HOUSING PEOPLE IN SHELTERS WHERE
WE'RE HOUSING PEOPLE IN CREEK
BEDS TYPICALLY- IN SO I'M
CONCERNED THAT. ALTHOUGH SOME OF
THIS PIECE WE HEARD SOME OF
THESE DOLLARS ARE AND I TOOK
THAT AS BEING PROJECT HOME CARE
BEING ALLOWED TO GO IN THE
INTERIM HAS EITHER 20% CLIP-
THAT WE'RE LOSING GROUND AT THAT
RATE. CAN YOU RESPOND TO THAT.
WELL AS I NOTED WE TRY TO DRIVE
FOLKS TO PERMANENT HOUSING- SO
IT DEPENDS ON THE COMMUNITY
THERE'S A LOT OF THEM BIG PUSH
TO HAVE FLEXIBILITY WITH FUNDS I
ONCE BECAUSE HE PER HAPPENS THEY
KNOW THE CONTINUUM OF WHICH
SERVER IS ALL THE WAY FROM
SHELTER UP TO PERMITS FOR
HOUSING- A CELL LIKE AS I
MENTIONED ARE COMMUNITIES THAT
HAD LITERALLY NO PLACE FOR THE
ON HOUSE TO GO. AND THEY MAY
HAVE CHOSEN AN INTERIM HOUSING
MODEL BUT WHAT IT WAS WHAT HOME
HE WAS DOING TO BE CLEAR WAS
BRINGING NEW CAPACITY ONLINE IT
DID NOT EXIST BEFORE SO EVERY
SINGLE UNIT WHETHER ENSURE
PERMANENT WAS BRINGING SOMEONE
IN BOOKS. WITH EVERY DOOR OR
UNIT CREATED. WHETHER WAS
INTERIM PERMANENT SO IN SOME
COMMITTEES A MAN MADE THE CHOICE
TO DEVELOP A CONTINUUM OR- USE
THAT FLEXIBILITY TO ACQUIRE
PROPERTY AND RUN IT IS AN DRUM.
IN THE NEAR TERM SO THEY COULD
BRING THOSE FOLKS INDOORS WHILE
THEY- WORKED ON PERMANENT
SOLUTIONS- THE DALLAS LARGELY
ALLOWING LOCAL NEEDS TO HELP
DRIVE THAT AFTER. AND IN HOCKEY
ONE POINT OH THE PRIORITY WAS
GIVEN TO THOSE THAT WERE REALLY
PERMANENT HOUSING FOR CONVERSION
TO PERMANENT HOUSING. IN THAT
HIERARCHY ALL NOTICES THAT THE
FLOOR HERE YOU KNOW THAT WAS
USING FEDERAL FUNDS WEEK BUT
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
DOLLARS AND WE CAN PUT MORE INTO
IT. DUE TO THE DEMAND- I WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT ACD IS INDIAN BY
HEART IS THE NUMBERS ARE STATE
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN THE NUMBER
ONE STATE. EXPENDITURE OF CDBG
FUNDS. AND OTHER FEDERAL DOLLARS
SINCE JULY TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO
WE ARE DEFINITELY PULLING
EVERYTHING. WITH YOUR CONSENT
NEEDS. FOR THIS CRISIS AND OUR
PARTNERS ARE DOING THE SAME THE
LOCAL LEVEL SO- I THINK THE AS
YOUR QUESTION IS LARGELY. GETS
TO WHAT WE MAY SEE IN SOME OF
THOSE LOCAL PLANS AS HARRY
ACCOMMODATING BOTH YOUR NEEDS
ARE YOU DRIVING ALL YOUR
RESOURCES INTO. INTERIM OR
TEMPORARY SOLUTIONS AND WHAT'S
THAT BALANCE IT'S GOING TO VARY
BY COMMUNITY- MY CANADIAN CELL
IN THE CASE OF MONKEY THOUGH.
THAT'S BRINGING ON NEW CAPACITY
WORK DIDN'T EXIST IT'S NOT ABOUT
PUTTING MORE MONEY INTO.
EXISTING SHELTER SPACE. IT'S
BRING. UP BUILDING THAT CONTINUE
WHETHER ONE NINE IN. I JUST TO
SEE IT AGAIN IT'S CENTER-
OPINION- AGAIN IN THE CAR OF- I
CULTURE AND IN THE HUNDRED. NINE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
PONDERED SANTA CLARA COUNTY IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN- STRICTLY FOR
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
NONE FOR SHELTER IT'S VERY
TYPICAL OF OTHER COUNTIES IN THE
BAY AREA ALAMEDA. A TO SOME
DEGREE SAN FRANCISCO- SIX YEARS
LATER WE'VE GOT FORTY FOUR
HUNDRED PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING UNITS- AND THERE'S MORE
IN THE PIPELINE SO THAT MONEY IS
WORKING FOR FROM THIS BOARD OF
HOUSING SIX YEARS LATER OUR
UNSHELTERED POPULATION IS OVER
TEN THOUSAND IT'S INCREASED NOT
DECREASED. IN ITS FROM OF A
PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY STANDPOINT
IT'S NOT WORKING BECAUSE PEOPLE
ARE ARE PAYING THE BOND. BUT THE
DRIVE TO WORK AND SEE. UP MORE
TENSE MORE A SHELTERED IN EIGHT
EIGHT I CAN'T EMPHASIZE ENOUGH
THAT. WHATEVER THE RADIUS OF THE
RATIO OF DOLLARS AT THE STATE
LEVEL BETWEEN NINE CHILDREN
PERMITS SUPPORT OF HOUSING. IS
NOT ALLEVIATING THAT PROBLEM AT
A LOCAL LEVEL AND IT'S CREATING
SEVERE BACKLASH IN OUR
COMMUNITIES SO. YOU KNOW YOU
COULD ARGUE THAT I'VE BEEN PART
OF THE PROBLEM BECAUSE I PUT
UPON TOGETHER THAT WAS ONLY FOR
FROM SUPPORT OF HOUSING- BUT
THERE'S ALWAYS TIME TO CORRECT.
THEY MAKE COURSE CORRECTIONS IN
THAT SO THAT'S ALL I'M
SUGGESTING AT THIS POINT BEFORE
YOU KNOW WE HAVE AN EVEN GREATER
A PUBLIC BACKLASH FROM OUR
COMMUNITY OR COMMUNITIES PLURAL.
LASTLY COULD YOU SPEAK SOMEONE
SPEAK ONE MORE TIME ON WHAT
WE'RE DOING. OR HOW WE'RE TRYING
TO GET TO. INCREASED TAX CREDIT
- HOUSING TAX CREDITS AND- IN
THE OTHER CAL EACH OF THE
PROGRAMS- OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE
OVERSUBSCRIBED I JUST DIDN'T
HEAR THE PART ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
DOING ABOUT. THE OVERSUBSCRIBED
HERO UNDER CAPACITY IF YOU WILL
A RELATIVE TO NEED FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS. SURE THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION CENTER I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER THAT SUGGESTS JUST TO
CLARIFY- KELLY TO SAY- IS NOT
ADMINISTER THE STATE PROGRAM
THAT COMES TO MIND IS- TAX
CREDIT COMMITTEE- MANY
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS LOCATION
COMMITTEE ON MESQUITE KAKA
CITRUS OFFICE. BUT I CAN
SPEAKING BROADLY- I SHOULD BE WE
ARE ONE AND MAIN USERS OF STATE
OF THE PROGRAM AND ALL ALL THE-
HOUSE MARKET AROUND. BY THE SIX
COMMITTEE. ON THE- DELANO CASE
YOU CAN SAID LACK SO- IN. OF ALL
- THE STATE. OVER CITRIX ALL
HOUSING BONDS AND THE- WHEN.
PRESS AND GO TO FUNDS WHICH- ARE
THINK THAT THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
TO. DEFINITELY IS PART DAY THE
NUMBER- FINANCING COMES TO MORE
. HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA THE
SINGLE MOST EFFECTIVE SOLUTION
TO THAT PROBLEM IS FEDERAL-
TANKING. WAS ACTUALLY INCLUDED
IN THE- LASTED REYES ARE THE
BILL BACK BETTER. NOW IS BEING
CONTINUE BY CALL. LATE INTO THE
TWENTY ONE. INCLUDE COMING TO
PAY ANIMAL CORNERS AND
ADMINISTRATION AND OTHERS STRONG
FOR THE FOR DISCRIMINATION THAT
WOULD ALLEVIATE HI ARMONK
CONSTRAINTS IT'S A PROVISION
CALLED LOWERING THE 50% TEST A
LOWERING IT 225% WHAT IT
ESSENTIALLY DOES JUST TO BOILING
DOWN. IN DOUBLES THE CAPACITY OF
THE STATE'S FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
HOUSING MOM LIMIT DOUBLES ITS
CAPACITY TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SO IF RIGHT NOW IN BILLS
ABOUT SEVENTY THOUSAND UNITS PER
YEAR YOU IN DOUBLES AND- WITH
EXPLANATION SO THAT IS A SORELY
NEEDED. A SOLUTION- WHILE. WE
ARE WAITING FOR THE FEDERAL. AND
CERTAINLY FAME. I STARTED A
WHAT'S CALLED A MORE RESIGN
PROGRAM AND IT IS ONE OF THE
ONLY OTHER WAYS THAT CAN KIND OF
GO AROUND- THEY SET A- HOUSING
CAN AND WENT I HEARD THAT PART
DID MUCH TO HAVE TO REAP THE
YEAH HEARD THEIR BODIES SO PIECE
. IS CALCUL THAT ANYBODY DONE AS
TO IT WOULD TO IN TERMS OF STATE
FUNDS TO DOUBLE DOWN ON THE
CAPACITY- EVEN ON A ONE TIME
BASIS IF SO I DON'T NEED THAT
NOW BUT I WOULD ASK TO BE
DISTRIBUTED TO. YOU KNOW TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES- SO
THAT WE KNOW. RELATIVE TO OUR
OVERALL BUDGET. WHAT THE NUMBER
WOULD LIKE. AND I SUPPOSE I
SHOULD JUST ASK FOR IT BECAUSE
SOMEBODY WOULD BE ABLE TO GIVE A
SET NUMBER SO UNLESS I'M WRONG
IS THAT- SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
EXPECT TO GET. YES THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU- I SAID LAST
LEAVE MANAGER I DID HAVE A
QUESTION FOR SENATOR WINNER AND
IT WOULD BE MY LAST QUESTION OF
THE OF THE MORNING IF I CAN ASK
IT- CENTER WINTER STILL
AVAILABLE HE STILL OF THIS GREAT
SENATOR- IS YOU KNOW- DESPITE
THE FACT THAT I WASN'T YET IN
THE SENATE A WELCOME AND LONG
TIME SUPPORTER BUT SB THIRTY
FIVE ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT
WE'RE RUNNING INTO. BY WHICH I
HAVE WELL DOCUMENTED- THROUGH
CONSTITUENT SERVICES AND IN MY
DISTRICT OFFICES THAT WE HAVE
LOCAL CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS IN
THE LARGEST CITY IN MY DISTRICT
SAN JOSE- TELLING CONSTITUENTS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO HAVE COMMUNITY
MEETINGS AROUND SIMPLY COSMETIC
ISSUES- ABOUT PROJECTS- HOW MANY
TREES ARE PLANTED WITH THE VIEW
SHEDS ARE GOING TO BE- TYPICAL
NEIGHBORHOOD CONCERNS ARE BEING
TOLD THAT- TALK TO YOUR STATE
SENATOR BECAUSE- UNDER SB THIRTY
FIVE- WE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO HAVE
SUCH MEETINGS AND I KNOW THAT
WASN'T THE INTENT OF THE BILL OR
FOR WAS YOU CAN STRAIGHTEN ME
OUT. OF HERE ANY THOUGHTS ON. ON
ON HOW WE CAN RESPOND TO THAT A
- I GUESS I'LL JUST. STOP THEIR
- ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU SELLER
BECAUSE INVITES FOR SUPPORTING
SB THIRTY FIVE ONE IF THERE
COUNCIL MEMBERS ARE TELLING
CONSTITUENTS OF THEY'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO HAVE COMMUNITY ABOUT
SB THIRTY FIVE BOB PROJECTS- WE
GET SURPLUS DRILLING IN THE
BACKGROUNDS- ST I THOUGHT THAT'S
NOT ACCURATE- THEY CAN ACT YOU
NEEDING. AND. NINE EXAMPLES
NUMBER. WHERE MORE THAN TWO
THOUSAND UNITS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND ANTI PERMITTED ON
THE REST THIRTY FIVE. FIVE DID
THEY SAW COMMUNITY- GO THE
LOSSES IN MAY XCUSE MEETING BUT
THEY DO AND SOME A NEW WINS AND
I THINK BY TYPICALLY AS A AS A
BUILDER WATER FOR HOUSING OR
MARKET RATE. IT IS ALWAYS IN
YOUR INTEREST TO HAVE FRIENDLY.
A CITY- AND SO WHAT WE FIND IS A
LOT OF TIMES BILLS WILL GO TO
THE CITY AHEAD OF TIMES AND THIS
IS WHAT WE WANT TO DO- AND- WORK
THROUGH ISSUES ARE WORK FOR
EXCUSE WITH NEIGHBORS AND THEN
SUBMIT AN SB THIRTY FIVE-
APPLICATION. AND THAT'S I THINK
THIS SMART THING TO DO- AS A AS
A BUILDER BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
CITIES IF THEY REALLY WANT TO BE
HOSTILE NINE CAN FIND WAYS TO
MESS WITH THE. PROJECT ON I'M
HAPPY TO- CHAT ABOUT THIS MORE-
ALL- BECAUSE OUR GOAL IS NOT
BEEN SO NOW HAVE USE MEANT. BUT
RATHER AVOID THESE AND THEY
PROCESSES SO I RIGHT WITH
ACTUALLY TO LEARN MORE FROM IN
TERMS WHAT YOU'RE- IN A PRETTY
DIVERSE EMOTIONAL CERTAINLY YOU
UP ON THAT OFFLINE IN. I THINK
IT'S AN EDGY- EFFORT IF ANYTHING
THAT'S NEEDED AND IT MIGHT. WILL
BE DONE THROUGH ARKANSAS-
COMMUNICATION SYSTEMS- LCMS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT IF WE HAVE THE
RIGHT. A BERBER THE RIGHT
MESSAGE THAT'S AVAILABLE TO
LEGISLATORS TO PUSH OUT A TO
CONSTITUENTS- A TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE EDUCATED THEY KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE THE RIGHT. TO ASK
THEIR LOCAL REPRESENTATIVES- FOR
THOSE KIND OF COMMUNITY MEETING
SOME SOUL FOR TALKING THE
OFFLINE AND MANAGER THANK YOU
FOR- TOLERATING MY SEVERAL
QUESTIONS- APPRECIATED. IN THANK
YOU FOR CONDUCTING THE HEARING
TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
HAVE FINALLY SENATOR NIELSEN
YOUR- THE PHONE HAS BEEN UP
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THE- ANY
QUERY OF THE LEGEND HONEST. I
WAS ATTRACTED TO- THE SAME.
CHART THE MY COLLEAGUES FROM SAN
JOSE HAS MENTIONED. FOR THE
LONGEST PERIOD OF TIME. AS I
WATCHED THE- STATE AND LOCAL
RESPONSE TO. HOMELESSNESS WERE
SHELTER LISTS THIS. I LIKEN IT
TO A- AN ABSTRACT ARTIST WHO
COMES INTO A- WHITE PAINTED ROOM
WITH A BUCKET OF PAINT. AND A
PAINT BRUSH. AND JUST START
FLUSHING THE PAINT. ON THE WALL. CONDENSING THAT TO A SIMPLE.
QUESTION. THE LEGEND LIST HAVE
WE EVER. IN DEALING WITH THE
HOMELESS POPULATION. REQUIRED OF
STATE AND FEDERAL STATE STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. TO ASSESS
THE INDIVIDUAL NEEDS OF THE
HOMELESS PERSON THE HOMELESS
INDIVIDUAL. AND WHAT I'M GETTING
AT IS SOMETHING THAT I BELIEVE
HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL FOR DECADES
DEALING WITH K. TWELVE. STUDENTS
WHO ARE CHALLENGED. IT'S CALLED
I. E. P. INDIVIDUAL EDUCATION
PLAN. WHERE THOSE STUDENTS ARE
ASSESSED. IN A PLAN IS LAID OUT
. IN CONCERT WITH THEIR FAMILIES
. TO HELP ADDRESS SOME OF THE
NEEDS. THEY HAVE THAT USED TO BE
MORE FUNCTIONAL SUCH AS DEALING
WITH DYSLEXIA. PUT THE ANALYST
WITH THE HOMELESS POPULATION. DO
ANY AGENCIES OF STATE AND NORTH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT EVER MAKE THOSE
INDIVIDUALIZED ASSESSMENTS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE HOMELESS
INDIVIDUAL AND THEN DO WE FOLLOW
UP AND DIRECT THEM TO RESOURCES
TO HELP THEM ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THEY FACE. SUCH AS
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DO WE DO THAT DO
WE HAVE I. E. PLEASE. FOR
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS. NOT YOUR
QUESTION SENATOR I WOULD DEFER
TO THE COUNCIL ON HOMELESSNESS
OR PERHAPS SOME OF THE LOCAL
PARTNERS UNDER HER THE NEXT TIME
TO TALK SPECIFICALLY ABOUT WHAT
INTAKE LOOKS LIKE AS THINGS ARE
CONNECT WITH A PERSON
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS BETTER
SPEAKING TO HAVE MORE BROADLY
THE FUNDING IS PROVIDED THE
PROVIDED IN RECENT YEARS FOR
HOMELESSNESS HAS BEEN TO QUITE
ROD TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS INTO
THE INTENT IS REALLY TO PROVIDE
A CONTINUUM OF SERVICES THAT
REALLY SORT OF MEET THE NEEDS ON
THE GROUND AND SO. THE INTENT OF
LEGISLATIVE ACTIONS WHAT WOULD%
BE T RELEASE OF STAR OF THE
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS- BASED ON CERTAIN
THE COMPLEXITY THAT THEY MIGHT
BE FACING- I SEEN THAT CERTAIN
STERLING- WHO HAS CONTACTED A
DIFFERENT HER TO TALK ABOUT MORE
ABOUT WHAT THAT INTAKE MIGHT
LOOK LIKE THANK YOU AND IN THE
SECOND PANEL PANEL CENTER
NIELSEN WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
SOME DEVELOPERS AND ADVOCATES-
WHO WORKING IN THE SPACE SO THEY
MAY. BE ABLE TO HELP ADDRESS
THAT AS WELL. WELL THAT WOULD BE
IN I DO THINK THAT THAT'S A TO
BE A PART OF THE- OF THE FUTURE
TO ADDRESS. ADULT METALURH LIKE
TO TERMINATE THE FUNDAMENTALIST
. THAT ARE CAUSING. ANOTHER
OBSERVATION. AND IF ANALYSTS OR
ANYONE WISHES TO RESPOND THEY
MAY. BUT FOR SEVERAL YEARS OVER
A DECADE AT LEAST. A MOVEMENT OF
THE STATE TOWARDS WHAT'S CALLED
REALIGNMENT HAS BEEN IN PROCESS. I SUMMARIZED REALIGNMENT AS
BEING TAKING STATE
RESPONSIBILITIES AND DUMPING IT
ON LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. OFTEN
WITHOUT THE RESOURCES TO DEAL
WITH. THE QUESTION WOULD BE AS A
PRODUCT OF REALIGNMENT IN
CALIFORNIA. HASN'T THAT
CONTRIBUTED TO THE HOMELESS
CRISIS THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OR HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
NOW FITTED TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AS THEIR PROBLEM. HASN'T THAT
BEEN ONE OF THE CONTRIBUTING
FACTORS. HOMELESSNESS IS A VERY
COMPLEX PROBLEM ARCHITECT YOU
KNOW HISTORICALLY THAT ONE OF
THE MAJOR DRIVERS IS THE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES ACROSS
THE STATE- WHERE AN INDIVIDUAL
SPENCER OF A LARGE SHARE OF
THEIR INCOME ON HOUSING AND SO
UNEXPECTED EXPENSE OR JOB LAST
WEEK COULD PUSH SOMEONE TO
HOUSING AND- HOMELESSNESS THERE
. OTHER REASONS WHY IT WHY
SOMEONE MIGHT EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS AS WELL AS YOU
MENTIONED YOU THEIR NUMBER OF
AREAS WHERE THERE IS A SORT OF
STATE LOCAL ON REALIGNMENT OF
SOME SERVICES- THE LOCAL
COUNTIES IN PARTICULAR ARE
PRIMARILY RESPONSIBLE FOR
DELIVERY TO MANY OF THE OF THE
STATE'S. HOUSING AND I'M SORRY-
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS AND SO THERE HAS
HISTORICALLY BEEN TO THE
MECHANISMS FOR THE STATE TO
PROVIDE FUNDING TO COUNTIES FOR
THOSE SERVICES- AS I MENTIONED
IN THE PRESENTATION OF THE TABLE
THAT WE DEVELOPED REALLY FOCUSES
ON FUNDING WITHIN CERTAIN THE
CORE HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS.
PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED BY THE
STATE THERE HAS ALSO BEEN TO
THE- FUNDING IN THE ORDER OF
SERVICE I THINK LOW BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS PROVIDED TO OTHER STATE
ENTITIES PARTICULARLY WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THAT SORT OF AIMS TO
GET AT SOME OF THE MORE SORT OF
COMPREHENSIVE ISSUES WHERE
SOMEONE MIGHT BE- EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS THAT THEY TO. GET
GET THAT YOUR QUESTION WERE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE YOUR OFFICER TO
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT.
INVESTMENTS IN THE SPACES. THANK
LAST ONE MEMORY STICK IN MY MIND
OF A ADVOCATE TESTIFYING AT A
FORM AND AREA THAT I REFER. AND
THIS PERSON WAS VERY ADAMANT
THAT. WE COULD CONSTRUCT
SHELTERS. FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE HOMELESS. IF WE EXPEDITED
PERMITTING. GETS TO THE OMINOUS
WORDS SEQUEL- PROCESS SIX. SHE
WAS VERY ADAMANT THAT WE COULD
REDUCE THE COSTS OF PROVIDING A
HOUSING VERY SUBSTANTIALLY
THICKER FIGURE SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER UNIT. IF WE
ADDRESSED SOME OF THE REGULATORY
IMPEDIMENTS OR IN POSITIONS. I
DON'T SEE IN MANY OR IF ANY OF
THESE PROPOSALS OVER THE YEARS.
NORTH CURRENT. ANY MENTION. OF
EXPEDITING THE PERMITTING FOR
HELP HOMELESS SHELTERING. IS
ANYONE AWARE OF ANY ATTEMPTS TO
EXPEDITE PERMITTING FOR LOW
INCOME AND OR PARTICULARLY
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS SHELTERS OR
HOUSING. SO I WOULD LIKE TO ADD
THAT THIS- OBVIOUSLY DOESN'T
TALK ABOUT THINGS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY HAPPENING OR EXPLORE
PROPOSED TO HAPPEN THIS YEAR
THERE WAS A BILL THAT WAS PASSED
A FEW YEARS AGO THAT WOULD
EXPEDITE- THE CONSTRUCTION OF-
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING AND
SHELTERS IN LOSSING AND LOS
ANGELES COUNTY IT WAS- CARRY
BAG. OF AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND
I DON'T KNOW MAYBE SENATOR
WIENER CAN I'M NOT SHARE IF IT
WAS KIND OF THE WHOLE STATE YEAH
. YEAH I THANK YOU ARE CYNICAL
ORDER ON THE CENTER NIELSEN- AND
WE ACTUALLY. ALL OF THE
STREAMLINING BILLS- WE DISCUSSED
TODAY- FIFTY TWO YEAR IS
PROJECTS OUT OF STEEP ONE ON NOT
LIKE. SUPER STREAMLINED CIRCLE
LITERALLY REMOVED SEQUEL SO SB
THIRTY FIVE PROJECT IS COVERED
BY SB THIRTY FIVE WHICH RIGHT
NOW I'M LOW INCOME HOUSING
SUPPORTED HOUSING THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THE CENTRAL IS COVERED BY
SB THIRTY BUCKS IT'S SIMPLY NOT
SUBJECT TO SEE WHAT ALL. WE ALSO
- I HAVE CARRIED LEGISLATURE
THAT WAS SUITABLE EIGHT- ON THAT
STREET BUT REMOVES I WILL RECALL
NAVIGATION CENTERS LOW LOW
BARRIER HOMELESS SHELTERS. OUT
OF SEQUENCE FINALLY THAT ENDED
UP TO BE PASSED AS PART OF THE
BUDGET. ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU. SO WITH US. AND
LEGISLATURE ON AUTHORED A LAW
THAT SPECIFICALLY TALKS RECORDED
HOUSING. OUT OF SHE BROUGHT SO
WE DEFINITELY- TRUSTS YOU CAN
ALWAYS DO MORE. THE ISSUE OF THE
SUIT BROUGHT DELAYING THE
PRODUCTION ON THE PERMITTING OF
COURSE WERE WHILE STAYING.
HOMELESS SERVICE WHO WAS
SERVING. USES LIKE SHELTERS IN
SUPPORT. OF WORKING WITH THE.
ARE YOU DONE YES OKAY GREAT
PROVIDE YOUR MICROPHONE WAS DOWN
. SO THANK YOU TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR QUESTIONS AND
ALSO THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE PANEL. SO SENATOR KABBADI
HERO WAS GOING TO INTRODUCE THE
PANEL- AND IF SHE IF IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME. THIS COMMITTEE
WILL BE. THIS PANEL WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT- INVESTMENTS THAT
WE'RE SEEING FROM THE
PERSPECTIVES OF- DEVELOPERS AND
ADVOCATES IN THIS SPACE AND WE
HAVE THREE MEMBERS AND I'M SORRY
WE HAVE THREE PANELISTS THAT
WILL BE PRESENTING. AND I DON'T
- MAYBE WE CAN. I THINK SO WE'RE
GOING TO BRING UP SHARON
RAPPAPORT REPORT AND SILVER
BURKE AND STEPHANIE DIETZ AND
ARE YOU ALL QUEUED UP. AND YOU
WOULD. UNDER NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES YOU WOULD NOT BE
HEARING ME YOU WOULD BE HEARING
SENATOR WIENER- AS CHAIR OF
SENATOR HOUSE OF SENATE HOUSING
MAKING THESE INTRODUCTIONS SO
CENTER COMING YEAR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO. BRIEFLY INTRODUCE OF
THE SECOND PANEL. ABSOLUTELY
MADAM CHAIR THE MINUTE I DECIDE
TO GO TO THE RESTROOM THAT TIME
READY TO MOVE ON HOW I. PRESHEAF
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO
CONTINUE THIS HEARING. OF COURSE
NOT ALL MY PAPERS ARE MESSED UP
. SO THAT PASSED THE SECOND
PANEL IS THE LOCAL EXPERIENCE
WITH STATE FUNDING PROGRAMS AND
OUR FIRST PRESENTER IS SHERIN
REPORT. WHO IS THE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA STATE POLICY
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTED
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. THE MIKE IS
YOURS. REPORTING FEATURES
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR HOLDING
THIS HEARING AND INVITING ME TO
SPEAK- MY NAME IS SHARON UPWARD
OMINOUS CENTER CAPITO SAID I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA STATE
POLICY FOR THE CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. C. S. H. IS
A NATIONAL NONPROFIT AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION WE WORK WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENTS TO IMPROVE RESPONSES
THE HOMELESS. I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
TALK TODAY ABOUT GAPS IN THE
STATE'S RESPONSE. WHEN I
CONSIDER WHERE THE STATE WAS IN
TERMS OF FUNDING FOR HOUSING AND
SERVICES JUST FIVE YEARS AGO I'M
AMAZED AT THE PROGRESS THE STATE
HAS A- LONG TERM VISION CAN NEXT
WEEKEND REVERSING INCREASES IN
HOMELESSNESS WHICH- AND DECADES
IN THE MAKING. IF WE UNDERSTAND
THE ROOT CAUSE OF HOMELESSNESS
AND STRATEGICALLY- GAPS HOUSING
SERVICES CAPACITY RESOURCE
COORDINATION AND PREVENTION.
MOST IMPORTANTLY WE NEED ONGOING
FUNDING AT A SCALE TO MEET NEED
AN ONGOING STATE COMMITMENT
ALLOWS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
RECEIVING STATE MONEY LIKE THE
HOMELESS HOUSING ASSISTANCE AND
PREVENT. PROGRAMMER HAVE TO
INVEST IN EVIDENCE BASED LONG
TERM SOLUTIONS WHEN THEY KNOW
DOLLARS WANT RIGHT NOW. WELL
PROGRAMS LIKE HAVE HAVE BEEN
CRITICAL RESOURCES FOR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT ON GOING
SPENDING MANY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE USED HOW MANY
ARE SHORT TERM INTERVENTIONS
THAT MAY BE NEEDED LIKE SHELTER
STAYS BUT THAT WON'T REGION'S
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCE
CONCERNS. TO RESPOND TO SENATOR
CRITICISES COMMENT. HOUSING
ACTUALLY DOES FREE UP SHELTER
SPACE IF WE HAVE MORE HOUSING
OPTIONS FOR PEOPLE IN SHELTERS
THEY ARE BETTER ABLE TO LEAVE
RATHER THAN REMAINING IN THE
SHELTER FROM NINE TO TWELVE
MONTHS WHICH FORCES US TO CREATE
MORE SHELTER BEDS MEET THAT NEED
OF UNSTRUCTURED HOMES. ARE
AMONGST US. IN FACT THE ONLY
TIME I CAN. A STATE OR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS MADE
PROGRESS IN REDUCING
PLANNED PROGRAMS OFFERING
ONGOING AND- THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR EXAMPLE REDUCED
HOMELESSNESS AMONG VETERANS BY
FORTY PERCENT. THROUGH ONGOING
HOUSING SUBSIDIES PAIRED WITH BA
SERVICES. BOTH MICHIGAN AND NEW
JERSEY SUBSTANTIALLY REDUCED
HOMELESSNESS THEIR ONGOING
FUNDING AS WELL. FILLING GAPS
MEANS FIRST INVESTING IN HOUSING
RESEARCH SHOWS THE COSTS OF
HOMELESSNESS IS A LACK OF
HOUSING HOUSEHOLDS WITH ACUTELY
LOW INCOMES CAN'T AFFORD. FOR
THIS REASON WE MUST INCREASES OF
FIVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SPECIFICALLY FOR PEOPLE- AT
GREATEST RISK AND EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS THE PRIVATE RENTAL
MARKET NO LONGER MANAGES
APARTMENTS- BETTER AFFORDABLE
FOR INDIVIDUALS ON FIXED INCOMES
AND FAMILIES WITH PARENTS MAKING
MINIMUM WAGE. RAISING OUR
STATE'S RENTAL HOUSING AND IS
NOW THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
PUBLIC SECTOR AT A SCALE WE HAD
NEVER SEEN OR- WE HAVE MADE
GAINS IN CREATING MORE HOUSING
PARTICULARLY WITH INVESTMENTS
AND HONG-JI AND STATE LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDITS. AND
PROGRAMS LIKE THE ACCELERATOR
PROGRAM THAT SACCONE STATEMENT
SHOULD BUT SOME OF OUR CAPITAL
PROGRAMS LIKE THE MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING PROGRAM AND NO PLACE
LIKE HOME ARE RUNNING OUT OF. WE
CAN ALSO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS
QUICKLY BY PAYING FOR HOUSING
SUBSIDIES AND EXISTING HOUSING
AND THE NONPROFIT AND PRIVATE
MARKETS. THE FEDERAL SECTION
EIGHT OR HOUSING CHOICE VOUCHER
PROGRAM IS AN- EXAMPLE OF THE
PROGRAM THAT HAS BEEN HUGELY
SUCCESSFUL IN REDUCING
HOMELESSNESS. BAKERSFIELD IS A
PERFECT EXAMPLE OF THAT THEY
WERE ABLE TO END CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS AND BAKERSFIELD
THREE STRATEGIC INVESTMENT AND
ONGOING FEDERAL HOUSING SUBSIDY
IS. DEDICATED TO PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS. STATEWIDE A
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR COULD
HOUSE CLOSE TO FIFTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS. THAT LAUNCHED THEM
THE MOST- THAT HAVE I'M SORRY
THE MOST RECENT ROUND OF HAVE
PROVIDES INCENTIVES TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS JEANS HALF DOLLARS
FOR HOUSING AND SETTING
BENCHMARKS REDUCTIONS AND
PERMITS. HOWEVER LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE RELUCTANT TO
COMMIT HOP FUNDING FOR SOMETHING
LIKE HOUSING SUBSIDIES WHEN THEY
MAY BE ON THE HOOK FOR FUNDING
THOSE SUBSIDIES REHAB FUNDING
RUNS OUT. ACCORDING TO THE
TWENTY TWENTY HAVE RECORD ONLY
3% OF HOP RUNS IN ROUND ONE WAS
USED FOR HOUSING SUBSIDIES WHERE
IS 92% WAS. USED TO FIND
SHELTERS- THAN ELEVEN PER SERVED
EXIT HOME TO HOUSING NOT. ORDING
TO THAT REPORT. THANK WE NEED TO
CAPACITY AMONG OUR HOUSING AND
HOMELESS SERVICES SECTORS WHICH OUT THE STATE'S
WORK TO ADDRESS THE CRISIS
HOUSING AND SERVICE PROVIDERS
TYPICALLY RELY ON PAYMENT RATES
THAT HAVE AN INCREASE FOR OVER
TEN YEARS STAFFER BURDENED BY
POOR PAY AND BURN OUT FOR
TRIBULATIONS. THAT WAIT TILL
THIS GAP WITH THE RELATIVELY
MODEST INVESTMENT IN THE
CAPACITY OF HOMELESS RESPONSE
SECTOR. SOME JURISDICTIONS ARE
USING HOW MANY PASSED LAST YEAR
FOR THIS PURPOSE WHILE THEY'RE
CREATING THEIR PLANS AND HEART
ROWNTREE. INSIDE ONSTAD MENTIONS
TECHNICAL TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
J. APPLY FOR FUNDING WHICH HAS
BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL. I HAVE
SUPPLEMENT THOUGH COULD ENSURE
NONPROFIT PROVIDERS ARE PREPARED
TO IMPLEMENT THE INCREASE STATE
FUNDING SUCCESSFULLY ON AN
ONGOING BASIS. COLLUDING FOR
HIRING AND RETAINING STAFF.
THIRD A LACK OF ADEQUATE
SERVICES FUNDING REMAINS ONE OF
THE BIGGEST BARRIERS FOR PEOPLE
TO ACCESS HOUSING TO ASSESS
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS AND FOR SOME
TERM MAINSTAY OF GREENHOUSE.
BLACK OF SERVICES FUNDING HAS
CONTRIBUTED TO PEOPLE LEAVING
PROJECT ROOM KEY INSIGHTS KNOW
WHERE TO GO. THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES CALTRAIN
REFORMS TO MEDICARE ALL PROMISES
TO FIND SOME SERVICES BUT ONLY
FOR A FRACTION OF CALIFORNIANS
WHO NEED. MOST MANAGED CARE
PLANS CARRYING OUT CAL AIMED
FUNDING THESE SERVICES REPORT
THEY'LL PAY FOR SERVICES FOR
ONLY SHORT PERIODS AND FOR ONLY
AS LONG AS THEY CAN DEMONSTRATE
RETURN ON INVESTMENT. WE COULD
FOLLOW THE LEAD OF OTHER STATES
AND CREATE A MEDIC CAL HOUSING
SUPPORT SERVICES BENEFIT. MAKING
SERVICES AVAILABLE TO ALMOST ALL
NEEDING AND WANTING SERVICES AND
TAPPING INTO 5290% FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THOSE. FOR US
TO MAKE THIS ALL WORK AT THE
SYSTEMS LEVEL. AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS COULD WORK MORE
COLLABORATIVELY COLLABORATIVELY
AS YOU MENTIONED SENATOR
CONQUER. CHILI LOHAN'S ACT
ONSTAD TALKED ABOUT ADVANCES IN
COLLABORATION AND COORDINATION
AND THE BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES IN HOUSING AGENCY
PRIMARILY THROUGH- THE
CALIFORNIA INTERAGENCY COUNCIL
ON HOMELESSNESS DRAFTED A VERY
THOUGHTFUL STATE ACTION PLAN.
THE NEXT STEP SHOULD INCLUDE A
FORMAL PROCESS FOR STAFF WORKING
ACROSS DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES
REGULARLY TO COURTNEY- THIS
PROCESS WE CAN SECURE
PHILANTHROPIC FUNDING FOR
INNOVATIONS. WE CAN ACCESS
PROGRAMMATIC OUTCOMES AND JUST
AGGREGATE DATA BY RACE TO
DETERMINE WHO BENEFITS FROM
STATE PROGRAMS. WE CAN MAKE IT
EASIER FOR A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
NGOS FIVE FOR FUNDING BIGELOW
STABBER STANDARDS THAT
RECOGNIZED EVIDENCE OF
SUCCESSFUL MODELS OF HOUSING AND
SERVICES. AND WE COULD AVOID
DUPLICATING STAFF WORK MAKING
RESOURCES MORE ACTIVE. FINALLY
BEFORE LEGISLATORS CAN
REASONABLY EXPECT DECREASES IN
HOMELESS NUMBERS WE MUST STOP
THE INFLOW. THE LOS ANGELES
HOMELESS RESPONSE REPORTED THAT
EIGHTY THREE THOUSAND MORE
PEOPLE BECAME HOMELESS AND
TWENTY TWENTY THEN IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. SO EVEN THOUGH THE
HOUSE MORE THAN DOUBLE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN TWENTY
TWENTY THAN THEY HAD FIVE YEARS
BEFORE THANKS IN LARGE PART DUE
TO STATE FUNDING. THEY WERE
OVERWHELMED WITH PEOPLE FALLING
INTO HOMELESSNESS AND THAT IS
TRUE FOR MOST OF OUR LOCALS. FOR
ANY PREVENTION PROGRAM THE STATE
SHOULD INCORPORATE THE
CALIFORNIA POLICY LABS RISK
IDENTIFIERS TO TARGET PREVENTION
RESOURCES TO THOSE MOST LIKELY
TO BECOME. AND NOT A GREAT BROAD
EVICTION PREVENTION WITH
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION. I KEEP
PREVENTION STRATEGY IS ALSO
DISTURBING DISCHARGES FROM OUR
INSTITUTION INTO HOMELESSNESS
CDCR STAFF REPORT THAT BETWEEN
2230% OF PEOPLE LEAVING PRISON
WILL BECOME HOMELESS PEOPLE
LIVING IN FOSTER CARE ARE FIVE
TIMES GREATER RISK OF CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS- THEN THE GENERAL
PUBLIC. AND OVER ELEVEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN OUR NURSING HOMES HAVE
NOWHERE TO GO WHEN DISCHARGED.
THESE SETTINGS ARE NOT ONLY
DRIVERS OF HOMELESSNESS THEY
CONTRIBUTE CONTRIBUTE TO
DISPROPORTIONATE RATES OF
HOMELESSNESS AMONG AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND INDIGENOUS PEOPLE
. CALIFORNIA IS INVESTING IN
MEDICAID INNOVATIONS THAT
PROMISE SOME REDUCTION IN
INSTEAD. SURE INCLUDING AMONG
PEOPLE WHO WERE- EXITING JAILS
AND VICTOR DERON SPOKE AT C. B.
C. S. H. INVESTMENT IN YOUTH
EXPERIENCE. THESE INVESTMENTS
ARE PROMISING BEGINNINGS BUT OUR
INSTITUTIONAL SYSTEM SHOULD NEXT
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR MAKING
SURE PEOPLE DOES CHARGING WITH
NO PLACE TO GO OUT SOMEWHERE TO
LIVE THAT DOES NOT LIMIT THE
LENGTH OF STAY AND IF NEEDED
RECEIVE SERVICES PROMOTING
TRAUMA INFORMED EVERY. PLENTY OF
DATA SHOWS HOUSING WITH SERVICES
IS HIGHLY EFFECTIVE AND FAR LESS
EXPENSIVE THAN PAYING FOR A
RETURN TO AN INSTITUTION.
TELLING THESE FIVE GAPS WITHIN
WITH THE POLITICAL WILL TO MAKE
IT HAPPEN AND I'M EXCITED ABOUT
THE PROGRESS MADE SO FAR. I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. CAN WE HAVE A
MICROPHONE FOR CENTER COVER YOUR. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY IT'S- REALLY HELPFUL
AND I APPRECIATE IT WE'RE GONNA
GET WAIT TO THE VERY END TO TAKE
QUESTIONS AND SO WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON. TO END SILVERBERG WHO
IS THE CEO OF NOR CAL. DIVISIONS
RELATED CALIFORNIA. MY KISS
YOURS. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I ON A ROLL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEES- I AS WAS JUST STATED
THAT MY NAME IS DAN SILVA BURKE
AND I'M THE CEO CARL RELATED
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA NORTHWEST
AFFORDABLE DIVISIONS- IN MY ROLE
I'M CURRENTLY OVERSEEN THE
CREATION OF ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND
UNITS OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
OUR ORGANIZATION IN ITS THIRTY
YEAR HISTORY AS THE RESPONSIBLE
FOR DEVELOPING OVER SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND- UNITS IN THE STATE-
FIRST AND FOREMOST I'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY GRIEF GRATITUDE TO
THE LAWMAKERS AND STAFF MEMBERS.
OF BOTH OF THE COMMITTEES FOR
YOUR CLEAR COMMITMENT TO
COMBATING ARE SEVERE HOUSING
CRISIS- THE LAWS AND THE
POLICIES THAT YOU WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO DESIGN THE PAST TO
IMPLEMENT EEN CRITICAL
ABILITY TO ADDRESS THE
INTERCONNECTED CHALLENGES OF ALL
HOUSING AND CLIMATE RESILIENCY
IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE STARTING TO
SEE IT'S REALLY MAKING A
DIFFERENCE- TOGETHER WE FACE AN
ENORMOUS TASK- TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
PERMANENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
NEAR BASIC AND FUNDAMENTAL
SERVICES EUROPE PLAMEN
OPPORTUNITIES HIGH QUALITY
TRANSIT- AND IT'S A CHALLENGE
WHILE WE'RE ALSO INTERESTING
ADDRESSING THE SYSTEMIC CAUSES
OF RAPIDLY CHANGING CLIMATE-
WITHOUT POLICIES LIKE SB THIRTY
FIVE AND FUNDING PROGRAMS SUCH
AS A SAKE I A I G. M. H. P. OUR
WORK IS DEVELOPERS ARE
PRACTITIONERS TODAY WOULD BE
PRACTICALLY IMPOSSIBLE THESE ARE
EXAMPLES NOT JUST A PROMISING
POLICY IDEAS BUT A WELL DESIGNED
INTENTIONAL BONTA- TOOLS THAT WE
ARE USING AND CONSISTENTLY RELY
ON TODAY TO CREATE AFFORDABLE
HOMES FOR CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. I'M
GONNA GIVE YOU A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES OF THESE TOOLS IN
PRACTICE- AND THEN- HIGHLIGHT A
COUPLE OF CHALLENGES AS WELL SO
MY FIRST EXAMPLE. IS OUR SUGAR
PINE VILLAGE DEVELOPMENT IN IN
THE CITY OF SOUTH LAKE TAHOE- WE
WERE ABLE TO USE. THIRTY FIVE TO
FULLY ENTITLED TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY EIGHT AFFORDABLE WORKFORCE
HOUSING UNITS IN LESS THAN SIX
MONTHS THIS IS THE LARGEST
HOUSING- A HOUSING PROJECT
APPROVED IN THE CITY'S HISTORY.
AND WILL- OF COURSE MY DOGS
WALKING AND IN THIS MOMENT I
WILL GO A LONG WAY TO ADDRESS
THE PRESSING NEED FOR NEW
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THIS
COMMUNITY- IT'S BEEN
PARTICULARLY HARD HIT IS COBIT
NINETEEN HAS CAUSED. EVEN MORE
SHORTAGES AS PEOPLE ARE MOVING
INTO THE AREA BECAUSE OF
CURRENT- SUGAR PINE VILLAGE NOT
ONLY BENEFITED FROM SB THIRTY
FIVE IN THE STREAMLINING IT ALSO
HAS BEEN A BENEFICIARY OF
CRITICAL FUNDING SUPPORT. FUND
SOME OF THE FUNDING PROGRAMS
THAT I'VE ALREADY MENTIONED
INCLUDING PROPOSITION ONE AND H.
P. PROGRAM I G. SB TWO PLH A
PROGRAM AS WELL AS STATE HOUSING
TAX CREDITS. THESE FUNDING
PROGRAMS ALL WORK TOGETHER TO
ENSURE THE FEASIBILITY OF THIS
PROJECT AND TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN DELIVER THESE AFFORDABLE
UNITS IN THE COMMUNITY. MANY
GIVE YOU A SECOND EXAMPLE OF A
PROJECT THAT IS UTILIZING THE
TOOLS BUT IS CHALLENGES I
MENTION. ON THIS PROJECT IS ONE
THAT WE'RE WORKING ON WITH MERCY
HOUSING IN SAN FRANCISCO IT'S A
REVITALIZATION OF THIS ANY JAIL
PUBLIC HOUSING PROJECT IT'S A
VERY VERY LARGE FIFTY ACRE LONG
TERM UNDERTAKING THAT AIMS TO
WRITE MORE THAN FIFTY YEARS OF
DISINVESTMENT IN PUBLIC HOUSING.
AND WE'RE LOOKING TO CREATE A
DYNAMIC FLOURISHING AMENITY RICH
COMMUNITY FOR THE STUDY DALE
RESIDENTS NEEDLESS TO SAY THIS
IS AN INCREDIBLY HIGH PRIORITY
FOR US AS AN ORGANIZATION FOR
THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
FOR THE RESIDENTS. AND WE'VE
BEEN WORKING TOGETHER TO SECURE
THE FINANCING THAT'S NEEDED TO
MOVE VARIOUS PHASES OF THIS
PROJECT BOARD INCLUDING A
RECENTLY AWARDED I. I. G. AND
EASY FUNDING FROM EACH CD- I'M
FOR THE ONLY. THE PRICE IS FOR.
A THAT IS NOT UNIQUE TO THIS
PROJECT BUT MANY OTHER PROJECTS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
ALREADY HAS BEEN REFERENCED
TODAY IN THIS DISCUSSION. AND
THAT'S THE CONTINUED BACKLOG OF
LIMITED FEDERAL TAX EXEMPT BONDS
AUTHORITY WITHOUT THAT AUTHORITY
THIS PROJECT FUTURE PHASES IS
STALLED AND CANNOT MOVE FORWARD
DESPITE FULL FINANCING- THE
INTRODUCED LAST YEAR IS A
NATURAL FIT FOR THIS PROJECT-
BUT BECAUSE THE DOLLARS ARE
LIMITED IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT
SUNNYDALE OR OTHER PROJECTS LIKE
THIS WILL BE ABLE TO ACCESS THE
FUNDS- THIS IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE
OF THE CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF
THE ACCELERATOR PROGRAM.
ACCELERATOR FINDS A PROVEN TO BE
A CLEAR SOLUTION TO THE STATE'S
LIMITED BOND AUTHORITY AND WE-
ENCOURAGE YOU AS YOU ARE
CONSIDERING ALL OF YOUR VARIOUS
APPROACHES THAT YOU CONSIDER
ONGOING SUPPORT FOR THE
XCELERATED PROGRAM- THAT WAY
PROJECTS LIKE SUNNYDALE AND MANY
OTHERS THAT ARE STALLED WILL BE
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD. THE
ACCELERATOR IS THE ONE A SOURCE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TODAY
THAT REALLY INCREASES THE SIZE
OF THE PIE REALLY ALLOWS US. TO
DELIVER MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE
POSSIBLE GIVEN THE LIMITATIONS
OF THE FEDERAL TAX EXEMPT BONDS-
IN ADDITION TO ACCELERATOR I'D
LIKE TO JUST- ENCOURAGE ONE
OTHER THING FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. WHICH IS THE FACT
THAT PROP ONE APPROVED FUNDING-
IS RUNNING OUT SO VERY IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS LIKE NO PLACE LIKE HOME
LIKE MHP ARE RUNNING OUT YEAH
AND NOT ONLY ARE THOSE IMPORTANT
FOR IT THAT FINANCING OF OUR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS. THE
CONSISTENT PREDICTABILITY OF
THOSE FUNDING SOURCES IS
CRITICAL FOR OUR PLANNING FOR
THE EFFICIENT DELIVERY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE STATE.
SO AGAIN AND WE REALLY REALLY
APPRECIATE THE PARTNERSHIP OF
OUR LAWMAKERS THE GOVERNOR- AND
ALL OF US AS WORK CONSIDERING
HOW WE ATTACKED THIS. LARGE IN
THIS OF CALIFORNIA WE REALLY
ENCOURAGE THE ONGOING SUPPORT OF
INVALUABLE PROGRAMS LIKE AYE AYE
G. A. SIX C. HOUSING CREDITS AS
WELL AS THE ACCELERATOR PROGRAM
AND THOSE FUNDING PROGRAMS THAT
WERE FIRST APPROVED BY VOTERS
WITH PROP ONE. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR VISION AND SUPPORT AND
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY. FOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR YOUR TESTIMONY-
REALLY APPRECIATE IT AND- BY THE
LAST MEMBER OF OUR PANEL IS
STEPHANIE D. TO THE CITY MANAGER
FOR MY OWN CITY OF MERCED.
FORGERS THANK YOU SENATOR CAVIAR
FOR THAT KIND INTRODUCTION AND A
GOOD MORNING TO ALL OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND ARE CO
CHAIRS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE A LOCAL
EXPERIENCE TODAY AND I'M HONORED
TO REPRESENT NOT ONLY THE CITY
OF MERCED AS WE TALK ABOUT THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUT ALSO TO REPRESENT-
TWELVE DIFFERENT LOCAL PARTNER
AGENCIES IN OUR COLLECTIVE
APPROACH IN RE DESIGNING AND RE
IMAGINING HOW WE NEED TO THE
NEEDS OF THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS LIVING ON THE
STREETS OF MERCED COUNTY- BACK
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAY HOW TO VISION. OF
BRINGING LOCAL LEADERS TOGETHER
TO REIMAGINE THE WAY WE PROVIDE
SERVICES TO OUR HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
HE CHALLENGED US TO REALLY TAKE
A STRONG LOOK AT WHAT WE WHAT WE
WERE DOING IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AND HOW WE COULD DO THAT MORE
EFFICIENTLY AND MORE
COLLABORATIVELY AS A COLLECTIVE
PARTNERS AND SO WITH THAT
CHALLENGE HE ALSO WAS ABLE TO
WORK WITH ALL OF YOU AS
LEGISLATURES IN COMING UP WITH
ONE TIME FINDING A SEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO INVEST
IN THE ONE TIME CONSTRUCTION OF
CAPACITY AND THAT WAS THEIR
SEVERAL DIFFERENT TYPES OF
HOUSING OPTIONS IT WAS THROUGH A
NAVIGATION CENTER AND SHELTER
BEDS. IT WAS THE PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND ALSO
CHALLENGE US TO START LOOKING
INTO THE CONSTRUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE TOOK A
HOUSING FIRST APPROACH MODEL WE
AT BOLSTERED OUR OUTREACH
ENGAGEMENT EFFORTS WE BUILD
OTHER SUPPORT OF NETWORKS AROUND
ARE HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
INCLUDING OUT- IMPLEMENTING A
LOCAL HOMELESS COURT PARTNERING
WITH CALTRANS TO ADDRESS THEIR
RIGHTS OF WAY IN AND AROUND OUR
COMMUNITIES THEIR DELEGATED
MAINTENANCE AGREEMENTS
ESTABLISHED HOUSING- TRAINING
PROGRAMS WITH LOCAL NONPROFITS
AND THEN WE WERE SUCCESSFUL. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN AND BEING
AWARDED THIRTEEN POINT NINE
MILLION IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES GRANT
WHICH IT REALLY INTRODUCED THE
FIRST THIRTY UNITS OF PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IN OUR
COMMUNITY. AND I CAN HONESTLY
TELL YOU OVER LAST FIVE BEING
TRICKLED OF THIS. WE'VE SEEN OUR
HOUSE ARE UNSHELTERED NUMBERS GO
FROM FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT THAT
POINT IN TIME COUNT. TO THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR COUNTY
WIDE WHICH IS A 29% DECREASE AND
JUST IN THE CITY OF OUR SIDE WE
HAD TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR
UNSHELTERED LIVING ON OUR
STREETS. LAST YEAR AND THIS YEAR
WE'RE AT A HUNDRED AND NINETY
WHICH IS A 15% DECREASE. SO
COLLECTIVELY AND OVER A FIVE
YEAR PERIOD WE'VE REIMAGINE OUR
SERVICES WITH THE CREATING
CAPACITY FOR ALL TYPES OF
BALANCE. AND TO MEET THE NEEDS
pSTARTING TO SEE SUCCESS AND
THROUGH THIS PARTNERSHIP WE
ESTIMATED AT. HOME HE HAD NO
PLACE LIKE HOME APPLICATIONS FOR
OVER A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
BEDS AND NOT WILL TARGET I'M
JUST IN THE CITY MERCED THAT'LL
TARGET THE REMAINING INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. EIGHT
I DO WANT TO SHIFT INTO THE
HOUSING CONVERSATION BECAUSE I
DO THINK IT'S- EXTREMELY
RELEVANT TO DISCUSS HOW
EXPEDITING THE PATH TO
ENTITLEMENT. IS REALLY THE KEY
TO UNLOCKING THAT CALIFORNIA'S
AFFORDABLE HOUSING POTENTIAL.
LAST YEAR TE CITY COUNCIL SPEND
AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF TIME
DECONSTRUCTING ITS GENERAL PLAN.
IN ALLIANCE WITH A LOT OF THE
POLICIES THAT YOU AT THE STATE
HAVE ADOPTED RECOMMENDED TO THE
GOVERNOR AND HE APPROVED. TO
ENSURE THAT WE WERE MEETING THE
LOCAL BEACH HERE AND NOT
CREATING ANY UNDUE BARRIERS TO
ENTITLEMENT. AND REALLY THROUGH
THAT PROCESS LOCALLY WE ADOPTED
THIS MOTTO. HOUSING DELAYED IS
HOUSING DENIED. OVER THE LAST
FIVE YEARS WE'VE SEEN THE
CONSTRUCTION UP TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED UNITS IN THE CITY OF
MERCED. THE TEN YEARS PRIOR TO
THAT WE BUILT ON THE TWO HUNDRED
FAMILY SINGLE FAMILY AND MULTI
FAMILY UNITS COMBINED. SO WE
UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND HOUSING
OF ALL TYPES AND THERE REALLY IS
NO WAY OF RUNNING SOLUTION TO
THE HOUSING CRISIS AND HERE IN
THE CITY OF RIVERSIDE WE'VE.
EMBRACED ALL OF THESE POLICY-
OPTIONS IN LOOKING REDUCE OUR TO
PLAN TO INCLUDE ALL OF THE
ELEMENTS. WE'RE COMMUNITY THAT
THE GREAT RECESSION SOL PROBLEMS
THE LEAST AMOUNT OF INVESTMENT
THE PRIVATE SECTOR IS ANY OTHER
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA. AND NOW
WE'VE SEEN THE CONSTRUCTION OF
UNITS INCREASED BY A THOUSAND
FOLD. AND FOR US HERE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT. IT TAKES A LONG
TIME TO GET TO ENTITLEMENT IN IN
A TRADITIONAL FASHION. THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES PROJECT WAS A
HUNDRED IN NINETEEN UNIT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WITH THIRTY
AND- THIRTY OF THOSE UNITS OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE AND IT TOOK
US FIVE YEARS. TO GET TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE APPLICATION. DOES THREE
BUT YOU HOME KEY AND ONE NO
PLACE LIKE HOME THANKS TO SOME
OF THE POLICIES AND INCLUDING SB
THIRTY FIVE. THAT WERE ADOPTED
LAST SUMMER THAT TOOK US LESS
THAN FOUR MONTHS. THAT TRULY IS
THE KEY FROM A LOCAL
JURISDICTION PERSPECTIVE IN
UNLOCKING THE POTENTIAL TO BUILD
HOUSING AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AT
ALL LEVELS AND ANY HOUSING THAT
WE CAN OFFER INTO OUR COMMUNITY
ALL HOUSING TYPES ARE NEEDED.
WITHIN THE LAST TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS WE'VE REACHED A POINT IN
OUR COMMUNITY WHERE THERE WERE
ONLY FORTY UNITS AVAILABLE ON
THE MARKET. WE NEED ANY AND ALL
AND THERE IS NO WRONG SOLUTION
FOR US. IN LOOKING AT OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES AND REDESIGNING
OUR GENERALPLAN WE'RE ALSO
OFFERING ACCESSORY DWELLING UNIT
PLANS THAT ARE SHOVEL READY
READY TO GO TAKE THEM THEY'RE
ALREADY PRE APPROVED. YOU CAN
START ACTION IF YOU COME IN AND
USE OUR PLANTS. WE'VE ADOPTED OF
THE RESIDENTIAL DENSITY AND
WE'RE INTEGRATING THAT IN OUR
REDESIGN OF THE GENERAL PLAN
ALONG WITH STREAMLINING
ENTITLEMENT PROCESS THESE. LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE HISTORICALLY
PUT THINGS IN- THAT CREATE
CONFLICT YOU'RE NOT WRONG IN
THOSE STATEMENTS. AND SO WE'RE
WE'RE UNPACKING THOSE AND WE'RE
SEEING HOW WE CAN MAKE THOSE
MORE EFFICIENT. SOME THINGS ARE
DOING LOCALLY OR ELIMINATING THE
NEED FOR INTERFACE EVALUATION
AND CREATING STANDARD CONDITIONS. OF APPROVAL. WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT HOW CAN WE BE MARK
FLEX. AFFORDABLE BY THE- OUR
GENERAL RESTORE THE SIZE OF
SINGLE LOTS. AND YOU CAN'T BUILD
SMALLER WE NEED TO BE GOOD
PARTNERS IN THIS CONVERSATION
AND RETAIN REDUCE THOSE
RESTRICTIONS WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO ACCOMMODATE DENSER
DEVELOPMENT. BUILDING THAT MORE
CLOSELY TOGETHER AND AT HIGHER
LEVELS. HISTORICALLY CENTRAL
VALLEY COMMUNITIES DON'T LIKE TO
SEE THOSE TYPES OF DENSE
DEVELOPMENTS AND IT'S TIME THAT
WE ENTER INTO THIS SPACE. IN
ADDITION TO ALL OF THAT WE SAT
DOWN WITH OUR BUILDING COMMUNITY
BECAUSE AS HAS BEEN STATED
BEFORE THE CITY'S DON'T
CONSTRUCT HOUSING WE WORK WITH.
DEVELOPER PARTNERS IN ORDER TO
BUILD A WE ASK DARKEN OUR
CONTRACTORS IN OUR DEVELOPERS
WHAT ARE WE DOING RIGHT. AND
WHAT ARE WE DOING WRONG AND OUT
OF THAT CAME A LIST OF OTHER
SUGGESTIONS THAT WE'VE BEEN
IMPLEMENTING AND WE DO THAT
RECALL THAT CONVERSATION
ANNUALLY. SO WE'RE NOT JUST
MEETING WITH OUR HOMELESS
ADVOCATES AND INDIVIDUALS THAT
USE OUR SERVICES WERE ALSO
MEETING WITH THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
BUILD HOUSING IN OUR COMMUNITY
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE AREN'T THE
ISSUE. AND WE'RE NOT STANDING IN
THE WAY. ON THE FOREFRONT OF.
WHAT'S COMING N THE CITY OF OUR
SIZE OUR CITY COUNCIL HAS MET.
THAT COMMITMENT A POLICY CHANGE
WITH FUNDING MUCH LIKE YOUR
DOING IT CONSIDERING TO ADD
TODAY IN YOUR DIALOGUE. BY
TAKING THEIR ANNUAL ALLOCATION
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING SUBSIDIES
FROM THREE MILLION TO FIFTEEN
MILLION ANSWER AS A RESULT OF
THE ARK OF FUNDING WE RECEIVED
HERE OCALLY. AND THEY'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF PREPARING ANNEXATIONS
OF YOU SEE MORE SAD. AND THEY
TO. CONTINUE ITS PROPERTIES AS A
RESULT OF THE APPROVAL OF AB
THREE THREE ONE TWO TO ANNEX I
THOUSAND MORE ACRES RESULTING IN
EIGHT THOUSAND MORE UNITS THAT
WILL BE. PRINCIPALLY PERMITTED
AS THEY COME IN TO THE CITY
THROUGH ANNEXATION. WE KNOW THAT
THIS IS VERY- THIS THIS IS A
COMPLEX ISSUE DEALING WITH A
COMPLEX SYSTEM. AND WE'RE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT THE BEST WAY TO
BREAK DOWN THE SILOS AND TO
BUILD PARTNERSHIPS LOCALLY. I
CAN ALSO TELL YOU THAT THE BEST
APPROACH FOR US HAS BEEN LOOKING
WITHIN. OUR COMMUNITY AT A
REGIONAL LEVEL. I DON'T HAVE SO
SIR. TO A TO MY- INTO TO THE
PARKING. LIVING ON THE STREET MY
K. IN MY O. C. HAVE THEM SIR.
WITH THAT PARTNERS I CAN'T MEET
THE NEEDS TO WRAP AROUND
INDIVIDUALS. SIMPLY PUTTING THEM
IN THE HOLE IN A HOME WITHOUT
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES IT SETTING
SOMEONE UP. TO FAIL AND SO WE
NEED TO WORK TOGETHER IN DOING
SO AT A REGIONAL LEVEL. WE'RE
TAKING THAT NEXT STEP IN
EVALUATING ARENA. GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES IN POLICY WE'RE
BUILDING OUR FIRST MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL RINA IN HOUSING
ELEMENTS THAT WERE WORKING ON
TOGETHER. AND NOT NEXT STOP WILL
TRANSITION INTO A REGIONAL
HOUSING TRUST. I'M THE ONLY
ENTITLEMENT CITY WITHIN MY
COUNTY. MY FELLOW CITIES AND THE
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITY NEED TO
GET THEIR HANDS ON THESE TYPES
OF RESOURCES SO WE'RE COMING
TOGETHER COLLECTIVELY. INCREASED
OUR LOCAL CAPACITY AND THE
FUNDING THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE.
ALMOST IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
I'LL STOP THERE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS WHEN THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH M. IT EXCELLENT
PRESENTATION APPRECIATE- YOU'RE
PARTICIPATING HERE TODAY- LET ME
JUST START OFF BY SEN I BY
SAYING THAT- ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT HAS. COME UP OVER AND OVER
FOR ME AND NOW MY DISTRICT IS I
HAVE A NUMBER OF SMALL RURAL
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE DESPERATE TO
BUILD HOUSING THERE. AREN'T
READY TO DO IT BECAUSE- THE
RETAIL. STORES AND PHARMACIES
LOOK TO HELP WHAT'S THE
POPULATION BASE IN ORDER TO COME
INTO A COMMUNITY IN THE WAY THAT
THEY BUILD ECONOMICALLY IS TO
BUILD A HOUSING WHICH WILL THEN
BRING THE RETAIL AND- AND THE
PHARMACIES- SO THE PROGRAMS THAT
DO NOT WORK WITH SMALL RURAL
COMMUNITIES ARE OF CONCERN TO ME
AND IN PARTICULAR- IT'S A IT'S
BEEN NEED THE I. G. IN THIS. THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY PROGRAM SO
I'M REALLY HERE GLAD TO HEAR
THAT MERCED BEEN ABLE TO ACCESS
THOSE RESOURCES I KNOW THERE IS
A SET ASIDE FOR RURAL
COMMUNITIES WE MIGHT WANT TO
LOOK AT THAT AND INCREASE THE
PERCENTAGE JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THAT THE COMMUNITIES
REALLY THAT ARE READY TO BUILD A
HOUSING HAVE THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO DO THAT- SO I'M I'M
REALLY GLAD TO HEAR YOU WERE
ABLE TO ACCESS SOME OF THOSE
FUNDS- MY- THOSE THAT THOSE ARE
JUST STATEMENTS MY FIRST COURT
MIKE MY QUESTION IS ON. THE-
WHAT WHAT KIND OF INVESTMENTS
SHOULD THE SENATE BE CONSIDERING
IN ORDER TO BUILD. UPON RECENT
INVESTMENTS TO AND THEN PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS AND TO PROVIDE MORE
CERTAINTY FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS SO WE KNOW WE NEED TO
BUILD. HOUSING THAT IS
AFFORDABLE. AS WELL AS DEAL WITH
THE HOMELESS POPULATION. BUT
WHAT WHAT SHOULD WE BE FOCUSING
ON IN TERMS OF THE OUR FUNDS AND
I THINK ONE OF THE ISSUES IS DO
WE START SOMETHING NEW OR DO WE
GO BACK AND- MAKE SURE THAT THE
RESOURCES THAT WE PUT OUT THERE.
THAT THERE'S RESOURCES THAT ARE
CONTINUING. TO FOLLOW IN THOSE
IN THOSE CATEGORIES SO YOU
HAVEN'T- ANYONE ANYONE ON THE
PANEL THAT CAN ANSWER THAT. WHY
DON'T I START AND THEN MAYBE
OTHERS CAN JOIN IN. I WOULD-
THERE ARE A MYRIAD OF FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES AND WHAT I WOULD
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONSIDER AS YOU DELIBERATE THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET IS. AN ON GOING
SUSTAINABLE SOURCE OF FUNDING
FOR SERVICE PROVIDERS. AND THEN
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN FUNDING
THAT HELPS- MATCHED OUR LOCAL
FUNDS TO OFFSET THE COST OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THOSE ARE THE
TWO AREAS. AND YOU CAN DO THAT
BY FUNDING- CREATING THESE ONE
TIME POTS OF MONEY EITHER
THROUGH KEEP SASH OR READ AS AN
ONGOING ALLOCATION THROUGH THE
COCS AND COUNTIES. OR YOU YOU
CAN REIMAGINE AND DIED BUT I
WILL JUST GO SOME OF WHAT THE
OTHER TWO SPEAKERS BEFORE ME AND
SAID. WE NEED TO TRANSITION OUT
OF ONE TIME FUNDING INTO
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING WE'RE
CREATING THE SYSTEMS OF CARE AND
WITH THE ONE TIME INVESTMENT
THAT WE RECEIVED WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY A MILLION DOLLARS
LEFT WHICH MEANS IN A YEAR. AND
A YEAR TO TWO YEARS WILL RUN OUT
OF MONEY TO SUPPORT THESE
HUNDRED A HUNDRED AND NINETY BED
SET UP IN CREATED IN OUR COUNTY.
WE'RE REALLY STRUGGLING WITH
SUSTAINABILITY BECAUSE A LOT OF
THE FUNDS WERE USING LOCALLY ARE
ONE TIME. ON THE CONSTRUCTION
SIDE OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING ONE
TIME FUNDING WORKS WELL ONCE WE
GET THINGS UP AND MOVING WE CAN
FIGURE OUT THE SUSTAINABILITY.
OF THOSE PROJECTS THAT'S WHAT
THE LOCALS HAVE- THAT'S WHAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO UNLOCK THE
POTENTIAL OF WITH A DOCTOR TO
FEE REDUCTION PROGRAM. THAT WAS
JUST DONE LAST MONTH SO WE'RE
WE'RE GOING INTO THE ABILITY OF
BEING MORE ADVANTAGEOUS WITH ONE
TIME FUNDING BUT IF YOU'RE
LOOKING AT PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE-
SERVICES AND HOUSING. THOSE ARE
THINGS THAT WE REALLY. NEED TO
FOCUS TO STAND ABILITY EFFORTS
ON. VERY GOOD- I CONDITION IN AS
- I THINK IT AN AXLE QUESTION I
I'D THINK THAT IN TERMS OF- BIG
BANG FOR BACK HOUSING SUBSIDIES
IS A REALLY GOOD WAY TO GO TO
PREVENT PEOPLE FROM BECOMING
HOMELESS AND REALLY TARGETING
THOSE SUBSIDIES. THE PEOPLE MOST
LIKELY TO BECOME HOMELESS- AT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SYRIAN IS GOING
TO BE INTRODUCING A BILL THAT
WILL. OFFER PREVENTION RESOURCES
TO OLDER ADULTS WHO ARE AT RISK
OF BECOMING HOMELESS. AND WE
HAVE SEEN STUDIES AT OF SAN
DIEGO THAT. SOME OLDER ADULTS
JUST NEED TWO OR THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH. TO MAINTAIN
THEIR HOUSING THAT WITHOUT THAT
FUNDING WITHOUT THAT MONEY THAT
YOU KNOW AT TWO THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH THEY ME. THEY
ARE LIKELY TO BECOME HOMELESS
AND SO. I DO THINK THAT IS ONE
PIECE TO KEEP IN MIND AND TO. TO
TO FIND I DO THINK THAT THAT
PROBABLY DOES REQUIRE A NEW
PROGRAM- JUST BECAUSE- NONE OF
OUR EXISTING PROGRAMS REALLY
LOOK AT. PREVENTION AND REALLY
FOCUS RESOURCES ON PREVENTION-
I'M IN A TARGETED WAY- BUT I DO
AGREE COMPLETELY WITH STEPHANIE
THE OTHER- THE OTHER PIECES THAT
SHE MENTIONED I THINK ARE ALSO
CREDIT. THE KEEPING. IN MIND
WHEN IT COMES TO PREVENTION. IF
I AM I ADD A THOUGHT FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE OF THAT FOR MANY.
ONGOING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
THE DELIVERY OF THAT HOUSING I
YOU KNOW THERE THERE'S THERE. IS
I CANNOT EMPHASIZE ENOUGH THE
IMPORTANCE OF A STABLE ONGOING
SOURCE OF FUNDS THAT STREET FOR
OPERATING SUBSIDY AND SERVICE
DOLLARS BUT IT IS TRUE FOR THE
CAPITAL PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE
USING TO DELIVER THE HOUSING
BECAUSE- THE FEAST OR FAMINE OR
THE NEW PROGRAM AND JUST STATE
THAT BROKE. THAT DEVELOPMENTS
TAKE A VERY VERY LONG TIME THEY
GET STRUCTURED AND THEN IF
THERE'S A CHANGE THAT AND IT'S
VERY INEFFICIENT AS THEY SIT AND
WAIT OR THEY ARE RESTRUCTURED
SO. HAVING PROGRAMS THAT ARE
FUNDED ON A CONSISTENT ONGOING
BASIS IS REALLY REALLY HELPFUL
WILL TAKE WILL TAKE ALL
SOLUTIONS ALSO LESIONS ARE
WELCOME OF COURSE BUT THESE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE ABOUT TO
EXPIRE OR THESE PROGRAMS THAT
ONE TIME ONLY IF THEY CAN BE
RENEWED I THINK THAT WOULD BE
VERY VERY HELPFUL FOR THAT. FOR
THE INDUSTRY DELIVERING THE
HOUSING. WHAT YOU FOR THAT AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS BECAUSE
WHEN WE- WHEN WE ESTABLISHED A
NEW FUND. THEN THE PARAMETERS OF
THE FUND HAVE TO BE DEVELOPED
AND THAT TAKES TIME. AND IT
MEANS EVERYBODY'S GOT A SHIFT
AND- I'M- PART OF WHAT I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT IS I'VE HEARD
OVER THE YEARS THAT THE I. G. IN
THIS AND THE- AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY PROGRAM
DOESN'T WORK REALLY WELL AND
RURAL CALIFORNIA. AND IT'S ONE
OF THE REASONS WE'VE DONE. SOME
SET ASIDE OR A SPECIAL CRITERIA
FOR THE FOR RURAL COMMUNITIES BE
ABLE TO ACCESS THE FUNDS I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT. IN AREAS
WHERE YOU CAN SEE YOU CAN STILL.
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PERMANENT HOUSING THAT WE HAVE
THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE FOR THAT
ABOUT TO BE ABLE TO HAPPEN. SO
I'M DONE WITH MY QUESTIONS-
MADAM CHAIR I BELIEVE- MIGHT
CARE OF HOUSING. I MAY HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS AND THEN I'LL JUST
TURN IT OVER TO YOU TO BE ABLE
TO CALL ON PEOPLE SINCE YOU HAVE
A BETTER VIEW OF THAT OF THAT
ROOM. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS TODAY. THANK YOU
BYE. VENTURE ON. THAT'S THE
THANK YOU FOR REALLY STRONG
PRESENTATIONS I'M JUST A QUICK
QUESTION FOR MISSISSAUGA BURGER-
AND THANK YOU FOR TALKING ABOUT-
THE IMPACT OF. THIRTY FIVE IN
GETTING OUT SIGNIFICANT REALLY
STRONG PLUS EXTRAORDINARY THAT-
GREAT WHAT'S A NEW TITLE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF A LARGE
GROUP HOUSING PROJECT IN A
COMMUNITY THAT THERE WASN'T A
LOT OF THAT KIND OF HOUSING
HAPPENING. UNLESS I'VE BEEN
SOMEWHAT SOME SIX MONTHS BUT
JUST OVERALL- SO SHOULD I WAS
HOMELESSNESS MONTH. I KNOW YOU
CAN PREDICT AN ALTERNATE
UNIVERSE HOW LONG DOES WOULD SIT
DOWN UP SOME. LIVE STREAM- BUT
BASS ON YOUR EX. BUT HOW LONG
WOULD KIND OF PROBLEM WITH YOUR
EXPECTED THAT KIND OF PROJECT TO
TAKE HIM TO GET. IT'S A VERY
GOOD QUESTION WE'RE SEEING TIME
IN AGAIN THAT THAT TIME TO
ENTITLE USING SB THIRTY FIVE AS
A MATTER OF MONTHS INSTEAD OF
YEARS AS YOU AS YOU NOTED
EARLIER- I CAN'T TELL YOU WITH
PRECISION WHAT WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED IF WE HAD PRECEDED THE
TRADITIONAL PATH BUT I CAN SAY
THAT WE WERE ENTITLING ANOTHER
DEVELOPMENT AROUND THE SAME
TIME. USING A TRADITIONAL PATH
SB THIRTY FIVE WASN'T AN OPTION
IN THAT CAS AND IT TOOK A YEAR
AND A HALF IT WAS MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE IT TOOK MUCH MORE TIME
AND I WOULD EXPECT THAT
SOMETHING. ALONG THOSE LINES
WOULD BE THE CASE HERE AND
PERHAPS EVEN LONGER GIVE AND YOU
KNOW THAT THE COMMUNITY THE
COMPLEXITY OF THAT DEVELOPMENT
YEAH. BASED ON WHAT I'VE HEARD
FROM. RIGHT ELDERS. YOU'RE IN A
HOUSE WOULD HAVE BEEN. I THAT'S
TERRIFIC BUT YOU WERE WHAT'S
INSIDE ALL. ACROSS OF THE YEAR
AND A HALF FROM- I THINK IT I'M
- IN SOME JUNIOR. ARE BACK CAN
HAPPEN BUT I'LL- NOT SOME. AND
WE- ARE ONE- ANOTHER PORTABLE
HOUSING- PROBABLY BUILDERS. FOR
ME THAT THEIR AVERAGE APPROVAL
TIME CONGRESS TWO THIRTY ONE SO
YEAR FOUR MONTHS. BECAUSE THERE
ARE PRICE THAT JUST.
UNBELIEVABLE ON TIME. SO SINCE
THANK YOU. IS ARE YOU GOOD WE
I'M GOOD RUNS OKAY GREAT SO NOW
WILL QUESTIONS FROM CENTER CORTE. THANK YOU MANAGE YOUR IN IN A
JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY- MS A RAP
- WAS IN- THE NEED FOR. A
PURPOSE PART OF HOUSING IN
PREVENTIVE MEASURES AS THE
PRIMARY MEANS TO- YOU KNOW
CLEARING- THIS MASSIVE HOMELESS
POPULATION THAT WE HAVE NOW-
FIRST FOUR I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY BECAUSE THEY DO A POOR
JOB OF EXPLAINING- MYSELF
SOMETIMES THAT. I AM A HUGE
SUPPORTER FROM THE SUPPORT OF
HOUSING AND I DO BELIEVE THAT IT
IS ULTIMATELY- WHERE WE NEED TO
GO. I'M A HUGE BELIEVER IN A
PREVENTATIVE- MEASURES-
ESPECIALLY WITH RENTAL HOUSING
POPULATION AND I'VE SUPPORTED
THOSE LIKE MANY PEOPLE IN THIS
ROOM- BUT WHAT NEITHER OF AND I
APPRECIATE SO MUCH OF A MISS
REPORT EMPHASIZING THAT POINT-
WHAT NONE OF THAT DOES IS TAKE
CARE OF WHAT'S OUT THERE RIGHT
NOW IN TERMS OF 70% OF THE
HOMELESS POPULATION UNSHELTERED
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WHICH IS WHAT THE NUMBER IS IN
THE DOCUMENTS THAT WE'VE BEEN
GIVEN FOR TODAY'S MEETING I'M
NOT MAKING THOSE UP THOSE ARE
TODAY'S NUMBERS IF ANYTHING I
WOULD SAY. IF I WAS GOING TO
SURMISE THAT WOULD SAY THEY'RE
PROBABLY UNDERSTATED- IN TERMS
OF OVERALL NUMBERS- SO EARLY
MICHAEL. WERE INTENDED TO SAY
BOTH AND BOTH HAND- NOT THAT I
MADE A MISTAKE BY PASSING A ONE
BILLION DOLLAR BOND IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY FOR PERMITS PART OF
HOUSING. THE MOST THAT WAS GOOD
THE MISTAKE WAS NOT TO HAVE A
GREATER OR GREATER OR EQUAL
INVESTMENT. IN SHELTER TO GET US
CAUGHT UP- THE MOST GRAPHIC
ILLUSTRATION I COULD GIVE OF
WHAT I'M SAYING THAT GOES BACK
TO THE EARLIER COMMENTS- BY THE
PRESENTER. WAS THIS- IN THE
STATEMENT I BELIEVE WAS THAT. WE
NEED THE PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING SO THAT WE CAN TAKE THE
SHELTERS AND USE THEM AS FEEDERS
INTO PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING. WE DON'T HAVE SHELTERS
OUR FEEDERS ARE NOT SHELTERS- IN
I CAN'T SPEAK FOR EVERY COUNTY
IN THE STATE- BUT I CERTAINLY
BELIEVE ARE COUNTY IS SOME TO
SOME DEGREE A MICROCOSM OF
WHAT'S OCCURRING- WE'RE TRYING
TO USE CREEKS. UNDERPASSES
SIDEWALKS AS FEEDERS INTO A
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
SYSTEM THAT TAKES YEARS AND
YEARS THE TO BUILD AND DEVELOP
IN IN IT'S NOT. IT'S NOT AN
ACCEPTABLE STRATEGY WITH THE
CONSTITUENTS THAT WE REPRESENT.
IF YOU WERE TO FLY INTO MINETA
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT SIMS
INTERNATIONAL. TO TAKE A TOUR OF
THE SHELTER PROGRAM IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY OR IN SAN JOSE YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE TO LEAVE OF THE
AREA OF THE AIRPORT YOU CAN GET
RIGHT BACK ON THE PLANE LEAVE
BECAUSE THE SHELTER PROGRAM IS
SOMETHING CALLED THE GUADALUPE
CREEK. OR RIVER WHICH RUNS RIGHT
NEXT TO THE AIRPORT. IN I WAS IN
NEW YORK- NOT SO LONG AGO WHERE
THEY DO BOTH AND THEY MAKE AN
EQUAL INVESTMENT IN SHELTER. AND
OFTENTIMES SIDE BY SIDE. SOON
SHELTER THOSE WHO WERE SHELTERED
CAN SEE WHERE THEY'RE GOING
NEXT- WHAT THE GOAL IS THE
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
STUDIO APARTMENT WITH WITH THE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES. I WAS ASKED
TO NEW YORK- BUT BY THEIR
HOUSING OFFICIALS FOR TOUR OF
OUR OF OUR COUNTY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. INTO AND I SAID THE
SAME THING TO THEM THAT I'M
SAYING TO YOU TODAY I'M
EMBARRASSED TO BRING YOU TO
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
A SHELTER FEEDER PROGRAM- THAT
FEEDS INTO PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING- WE IN CALIFORNIA THUS
FAR- HAVE. USE THE GREAT
OUTDOORS AS AS A FEEDER SYSTEM I
DON'T THINK YOU NEED TO FLY INTO
SAN JOSE INTERNATIONAL IF YOU'RE
SACRAMENTO. RESIDENT ALL YOU
HAVE TO DO IS WALK ACROSS THE
STREET FROM THE CAPITOL TO THE
STARBUCKS. IN YOU'LL SEE FROM
OUR SHELTER PROGRAM IT'S PEOPLE
IN SLEEPING BAGS RIGHT NOW TODAY
- IN BUILDING PERMITS FOR OF
HOUSING AGAIN IS A GREAT THING-
BUT IN THE FOUR TO FIVE TO SIX
YEARS OR MORE THAT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE TO GET THAT HOUSING BUILT.
THOSE FOLKS ARE GONNA SURVIVE IN
ALL I'M TRYING TO SAY IS THAT'S
UNACCEPTABLE TO THE CONSTITUENTS
I REPRESENT. OF THE SOUL. FULL
CIRCLE TO THE BUDGET I AM I'M
PLEADING FOR ADDITIONAL
CONSIDERATION- FOR. INVESTMENTS
IN SHELTER UNTIL WE GET CAUGHT
UP WHEN WE GET CAUGHT UP THEN I
THINK THIS. ALGORITHM OF MOVING
THE FOLKS FROM SHELTER INCOMES
WERE OF HOUSING WILL WORK AS AS
A NICE SMOOTH OPERATION. BUT IT
WASN'T ME IT WAS ONE OF THE
PRESENTERS WHO SAID. THE PROBLEM
IS THAT WE'RE BEING OVERWHELMED-
BY HELLO FOLKS FALLING INTO
HOMELESSNESS QUOTE ON QUOTE- AND
THAT'S WHY OUR PERMITS FOR
HOUSING INVESTMENT IS IN KEEPING
UP ON. WELL WE NEED TO SHELTER
THEM WITH THE PHONE INTO
HOMELESSNESS- WE CAN'T SAY.
DON'T WORRY- WE'RE GOING TO
PREVENT OTHERS FROM BECOMING
LIKE YOU. THEY'RE ALREADY IN
HOMELESS SISTERS IN A WAY TO.
PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING. IN
AND IT'S A HUGE NUMBER AND IT'S
BECOMING- I THINK THE BIGGEST
POLITICAL LIGHTNING ROD IN THE
STATE RIGHT NOW SO. FOR WHATEVER
THAT'S WORTH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GIVE MANAGER. SENATOR WHETHER IT
BE ABLE TO RESPOND. SURE THANK
YOU- THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR I
AGREE WITH A LOT OF WHAT YOU
SAID I DO THINK IT IS BOTH AND
WE DO NEED MORE WHAT I WOULD
CALL INTERIM OPTIONS WHICH COULD
BE A SHELTER COULD BE MOTEL STAY
OR OR OTHER OPTIONS OUT THERE-
AT THE SAME TIME I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY SOME OF MY COMMENTS I
ACTUALLY THINK YOU'RE RIGHT THAT
SOMETIMES BUILDING NEW HOUSING
TAKES A LONG TIME. AND WE NEED A
STRATEGY THAT ALSO INCLUDES
HOUSING SUBSIDIES AND WITH
HOUSING SUBSIDIES WE CAN
ACTUALLY GET PEOPLE HOUSE WITH
MUCH MORE QUICKLY I DON'T THINK
IT'S YOU KNOW ONE VERSUS THE
OTHER IT IS ALL OF THOSE IN OUR
LOCAL SYSTEMS WE NEED A BALANCED
APPROACH IF WE HAVE LOTS OF
SHELTER BEDS OR LOTS OF INTERIM
OPTIONS AND NOW HOUSING FOR
PEOPLE WHO GO TO WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO KEEP BUILDING MORE AND
MORE SHELTER BEDS AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT I WAS TRYING TO
CLARIFY- THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE AN
EXIT STRATEGY FROM THE SHELTERS
TO. THE PERMANENT HOUSING AND
WHETHER THAT'S AFFORDABLE
BECAUSE NOT I DIDN'T BELIEVE
THAT NOT EVERYBODY NEEDS SUPPORT
OF HOUSING SOME PEOPLE NEED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT THEY
DON'T NEED THE SERVICES THAT GO
ALONG WITH SUPPORTIVE HOUSING-
SO I THINK WE NEED MORE OF A
BALANCED APPROACH IN SOME
COMMUNITIES ALL WE HAVE IS
SHELTERS IN SOME COMMUNITIES WE
HAVE VERY FEW TO NO SHELTER OR
ENSURING HOUSING OPTIONS SO I
AGREE WITH YOU WE NEED A BOTH
AND STRATEGY AND GETTING PEOPLE
HOUSE QUICKLY MEANS BOTH
BUILDING TO INCREASE THE HOUSING
STOCK AS WELL AS HOUSING
SUBSIDIES TO GET PEOPLE HOUSED
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. AND THE
MORE HOUSING WE HAVE THE FEWER
SHELTER BEDS WE NEED THE PROBLEM
WITH SHELTERS AND SOMETIMES IF
YOU BUILD A LOT. OF SHELTERS AND
YOU DON'T HAVE. GOAL X. AND-
HOUSING IT MEANS PEOPLE STAYING
THE SHELTER FOR NINE TO TWELVE
MONTHS WHICH IS VERY COMMON IN
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES. AND SO
AGAIN THEN YOU HAVE TO BUILD
MORE SHELTERS IN PLACES LIKE NEW
YORK THAT HAVE A RIGHT TO
SHELTER- UNFORTUNATELY THEY FIND
THAT THEY HAVE TO SPEND MORE AND
MORE MONEY EVERY YEAR. TO KEEP
PACE WITH THAT RIGHT SHELTER
BECAUSE NONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE LIVING IN SHELTERS ARE
EXTREMELY PERMANENT HOUSING. SO
WE SEE IN THE YORK SOME PEOPLE
ARE LIVING IN THE SHELTERS FOR
UP TO THREE YEARS. SO WE YOU
KNOW I THINK WE HAVE TO. REALLY
LOOK AT ALL OF THOSE STRATEGIES
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
PROMOTING A BALANCED APPROACH
I'M IN LOS ANGELES THEY'VE-
THEY'VE IDENTIFIED THAT WE NEED
FOUR TO FIVE PERMANENT HOUSING
SLOTS. FOR EVERY SHELTER BED IN
THE BAY AREA I THINK IT'S MORE
OF LIKE- WHEN SHELTER BED. TO
PERMANENT HOUSING SITES AND OR
PREVENTION SLOTS. SO I JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY. THAT AS WELL
THANK YOU FOR. THANK YOU I DON'T
SEE ANY OTHER UP MICROPHONES UP
SO AT THIS POINT IN TIME I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE MEMBERS. OF
THE SECOND PANEL INTO THE
MEMBERS OF THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE. FOR JOINING US TODAY
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ANYONE
WANTING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT REGARDING ITEMS ON THIS
AGENDA. AS A REMINDER WE WILL
ALSO HEAR PUBLIC COMMENT ON-
SPECIFIC BUDGET ITEMS AT THE END
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER ONCE
AGAIN IS. 844-291-4185 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS NINE FOUR ONE.
SEVEN FIVE ONE. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. TODAY I'M GOING TO
ASK THAT EACH MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC PROVIDE. THEIR COMMENTS
WITH IN A ONE MINUTE TIME MARK
NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. OF MY C. NINE NOW. OKAY
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS WE WILL
BE AGAIN. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
MODERATOR THANK YOU CAN YOU
PLEASE GIVE ME THE NUMBER OF
TOTAL PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY
. I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT SEVEN
IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU MODERATOR
IF YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND
CALL THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
INDIVIDUALLY WE WILL CONTINUE.
THANK YOUR MIND TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWO FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU STATUS
STATICALLY IF YOU'RE GOING ON A
DEVICE OR A COMPUTER CAN YOU
MOVE BACK. HERE YOU'RE STATIC IN
MY FOR. NO IT'S NOT BETTER HELLO
HELLO IT'S NOT. IF YOU HAVE A
COMPUTER THAT YOU'RE LISTENING
TO OR A PHONE IF YOU COULD PUT
THAT ON MUTE THAT. ALLOW US TO
HEAR YOU BETTER. I WAS I WAS
VERY HARD TO HEAR WHAT YOU SAID
BUT I WOULD LIKE US TO GO TO THE
NEXT CALLER AND THEN ALLOW THIS
CALLER TO WORK OUT THE FEEDBACK
ISSUES SO THAT- NOW WE CAN HEAR
YOU AND MAYBE YOU HAVE TO HANG
UP AND CALL BACK IN BUT WE'RE
GOING TO NOT LET YOU GET LOST IN
THE SHUFFLE CALLER TWENTY FOUR.
THANK YOU THEY CAN DISCONNECT
AND DIALED RIGHT BACK AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DAVID MARKS I RESPECT ALL
CAN HOUSING PARTNERSHIP AND I'VE
REALLY A PLEASURE TO HEAR HOW
THE INVEST IN THE STATE IS MADE
IN THE LAST COUPLE YEARS REALLY
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNIT WE HAVE
PRODUCED. BUT I WANT TO
REITERATE THE COMMENTS OF
INSELBERGS THAT. HELLO THE
PLEDGE TO PASS WE ARE AT A FEW
THAT IS FAIRLY BLEAK THE NEW
PROP. ONE FUN BUT FUND THE MULTI
FAMILY FOR WILL BE A WAR WHAT IT
YEAR. THAT PROGRAM WILL GO IN
THE ARE MAY. FOR THE COURTS OF
HOUSING FINANCE. AT THE STATE
BUT- IT IS REAL CRITICAL THAT WE
OF. TO IN IN PROGRAM. AND AT THE
SAME ALL THE- ALL PROJECT AT A
RECEIPT. A FOR. HISTORICALLY
HAVE YOU DON'T. LOW INCOME TAX
CREDITS NOT TAX CREDITS ARE NOW
. MAX OUT YOUR THEIR CAN REALLY
DO NO MORE PROUD OF THOSE. WITH-
TAX CREDITS AND IT CRITICAL. THE
STATE. TO INVEST HOW ACCOUNT
PROGRAM THAT CREATED LAST YEAR.
AND ALLOW THOSE PROJECT THE
CANNOT GET ALONG INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDIT. FULLER SO IT'S
REALLY- THE PREVIOUS MONICA TO
THE SICK OF THE PATH INTO THE
FUTURE WE REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT
CONTINUE TO FIND AND PA CHAT.
AND THEN WITH RESPECT TO A
PATIENT YEAH I JUST TO SAY YOU
KNOW STAFF. THEIR GREATER THE
SOUTH LÀ M
AND MADELINE YOURSELF BEING IN
AFFORDABLE TO. HAVE TO TAKE
YEARS TO DEFINE FROM AWFUL FIVE
OF THE DIFFERENT PROGRAM. ALL
WHO AT WHICH CONFLICTING SO OF
POINTS IN PRIORITY. AND WHAT WE
REALLY TRYING TO ACHIEVE CAL. IS
A ONE SHOP LED BY THERE CAN VERY
OF. BUT THE STATE MAKE THOSE
RESOURCE ALL OF. THROUGH ONE
COMMON AFTER PROCESS DEVELOPED
YEAH THE READ THEY- AT ONE TIME
AND ONE PLACE IN THE STATE. NOT
ONLY THAT REDUCE COST OF
AFFORDABLE FIGURE. BUT WITH THE
SAME THE STATE A LOT OF MONEY IN
OVER. ROUTES AND BACKTRACK BUT
BASS IF YOU CAN. WE LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU GOING FORWARD
TO FUND CRITICAL PROGRAM.
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST NETWORK
INCLUDING OVER TWENTY SEVEN THE
L. P. AFFILIATES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. LAST YEAR
WE WERE LUCKY ENOUGH TO HAVE
SENATOR NANCY SKINNER AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BILL QUIRK
CHAMPION THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR FORECLOSURE
INTERVENTION HELPING
PRESERVATION PROGRAM. IT'S
PROGRAM KNOWN AS THE FIFTH OR AT
THE TEN SEVENTY NINE. PLUS
FUNDING. IS STILL IN THE PROCESS
OF GUIDELINE CREATION AT EACH
CD. BUT WE KNOW THAT ONCE THE
FUNDS ARE MADE AVAILABLE OUR
COMMUNITIES WILL BE EAGER TO
EASE THE HOUSING CRISIS BY
UTILIZING THEM AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. THE MODEL OF
ACQUISITION AND REHABILITATION
OF EXISTING HOUSING. MEANS THAT
CONSTRUCTION DELAYS DO NOT
HINDER THIS PARTICULAR HOUSING
SOLUTION. AND STOP DISPLACEMENT
OF COMMUNITY MEMBERS. KEEP
AND PRESERVES LOW INCOME
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR DECADES
TO COME. SB ACQUIRING AND IF THE
ACQUIRING ENTITY IS A CLT. THE
HOME BECOME PERMANENTLY
AFFORDABLE THROUGH OUR RENEWABLE
NINETY NINE YEAR GROUND LEASE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR.
CONSIDERATION TO THIS IMPORTANT
INVESTMENT. THANK I KNOW PLEASE
GO OUT. HELLO MY NAME IS DRAGANA
MORE WITH LEADERSHIP FOR JUSTICE
AND TO LOOK WITH MORE COME AND
OF COLOR A COUPLE AND COULD TELL
VALLEY LOWER INCOME ON IN COURT
COME TO COME IN ENGLAND CAL HAD
. BECKY NEGLECTED TO IN BASIC
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HOUSING THE
LACK OF INFRASTRUCTURE HAS A
DIRECT IMPACT ON THE DEVELOPMENT
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING POLICIES
THAT LIMIT INVESTMENT
OPPORTUNITY TO NEIGHBOR HEARD
THAT DON'T HAVE BASIC
INFRASTRUCTURE REINFORCES THE
PATH TOWARD PATH TOWARD GREATER
INEQUITY THAT MIGHT BE AN
INTENTIONAL EFFORT TO UPGRADE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN EXISTING
NEIGHBORHOODS WILL TO WANT TO
ADDRESS THE DISPARITIES IN
GEOGRAPHIC DISTRIBUTION OF THE
FUNDS THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
DISCREPANCY IN THE NUMBER OF
PROJECTS AWARDED IN TRIPPING
REGIN'S FIRST AT THE SUPPORTING
RURAL COMMUNITIES. WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE ANY ACTION
BY IN SHEREEN GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY
ACROSS FUNDING PROGRAMS TARGETED
SUPPORT FROM LOCAL PARK
COMMUNITIES AND IMPROVE CLIMATE
RESILIENCY THE PUBLISHING
COMMITTEE TRIPLED REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT ENSURE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO PARTNER HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY PORTABILITY TAPPED
INTO DISPLACEMENT WHEN ACCEPTING
PUBLIC MONEY INVESTED IN
INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES IN
EXISTING GROUP COMMUNITY TO BE
ABLE TO BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND NOTHING COULD PLACES THAT
HAVE EXPERIENCED DISINVESTMENT
AND THAT CURRENTLY LACK TRANSIT
OR OTHER RESOURCES. AND FUNDING
FOR INFECTION PREVENTION
PROGRAMS WHICH INCLUDE TARGETED
INVESTMENTS IN UNDER RESOURCE
AREA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TWENTY
PLEASE CALL. THANK YOU MORNING-
H. OF COURSE WE COULD HEARING A
CLINICAL SPEAKER MY NAME IS DR
BE JEALOUS TRACTOR APOLOGY
ACCEPTED THE CITY THAT JANE I
THINK I THE POLYTECHNIC IF I
STOP AND THEN WE'LL GET ON LAW
SCHOOL. WE ARE IN AND THEY AND
COMMITTING THINK THAT. TAKES
AFTER HUMAN TRAFFIC AND NTEREST
WAY IF I THINK FOR ME. IN OUR
HOMES THAT ARE ALL MORE GOING.
TO BE VICTIMS OF HUMAN- AND YOUR
REPORT BUT THE SENATE BASED ON
THAT AMONG COMMON USED- THAT
SURVEYED FORTY. HEADACHES A- IN
REGARD TO SEX. OUR NEIGHBOR. THE
STUDY ALL. IS AN ALLY WITH AND
EVERY PART BY W. LET YOU KNOW.
OF NEW ORLEANS THAT'S FOUND A
HOME YOU INTEND SPEND. ALL
SIXTY- SOME SORT OF A- GIVEN
TOPIC EXPIRY. IT IS THEN WE ARE
THIS BODY IS ALSO. DECLARE OF
PRADA- AS AND THAT RECOGNIZED
THE UNIQUE CHALLENGES OF THE
COALITION TO. THAT THEY- DON'T
ONLY GET ACCESS TO PROMINENT OR
- HOUSING BUT ALSO WITH A PATH
TO HEAL FROM MY- YOU. THESE
MEANS HAVE BETTER. BY THEN IF I
BECOME HUMAN. IN ANY ANY. THAT
THEY HAVE AWARE OF THE BILL
TIMES AVAILABLE AT THAT. THANK
YOU FOR TIME. MY NAME IS FRANCIS
MCILVAINE I'M WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA LAND TRUSTS WE ARE A
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST- IN
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA- AND WE ARE
PART OF CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
LAND TRUST NETWORK I'M- I'M
CALLING TO. URGE CONTINUATION IN
SUPPORT FOR THE- BECAUSE YOUR
INTERVENTION PROGRAM- I HAD THE
HONOR OF BEING THE I BELIEVE THE
FIRST PERSON TO HELP FACILITATE-
THE PURCHASE OF A HOME. IN
FORECLOSURE USING A PEN SEVEN SB
TEN SEVENTY NINE- LAW. BACK LAST
EARLIER THIS YEAR ACTION
ACTUALLY LAST YEAR- JOCELYN
FOREMAN IF THE TENANT IN THE
PROPERTY WOULD HAVE BEEN
DISPLACED IF THEY HAD BEEN.
EXCEPT FOR WE PURCHASED BY THE
WINNING BETTER AT THE
FORECLOSURE OPTION. AND THE
REASON I'M CALLING RECENTLY
PUSHED SO HARD. FOR THE FIFTH
PROGRAM IS THAT. GOING OFF THAT
PURCHASE WAS LIKE A MIRACLE IT
WOULD A UNIQUE OF A SITUATION IT
REQUIRED THE INVOLVEMENT OF OVER
A THOUSAND COMMUNITY SUPPORTERS
THAT MADE SMALL DONATIONS TO
HELP- CLOSE SOME OF THE GAPS IN
MAKING THAT THAT PROBABLY
AFFORDABLE AND WE'RE STILL
WORKING HARD TO. ASSEMBLE OTHER
SUBSIDY FUNDS TO MAKE THAT THAT
PARTICULAR HOME. EATABLE SO SB
TEN SEVENTY NINE WHILE IT'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT POLICY TO ALL
OF THE HELP TRY TO LEVEL TO
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROVIDERS AND
FOR. OUR HOME RESIDENT. BY
ITSELF IT IF YOU WAS- BECAUSE
THERE'S NOT THE MONEY THERE TO
MAKE TO PULL IT OFF AND THAT'S
WHY THE FIFTH PROGRAM WILL BE
ESSENTIAL. IF YOU REALLY WANT TO
COMMIT TO PREVENTING
FORECLOSURES IN THE MATHWAY
DISPLACEMENT THAT ARE THAT ARE
THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT IT'S
COMING THE FULL CLOSURES ARE
TAKING UP. IT HAPPENING AND SO
HAD TO KEEP THAT FUNDING IN
PLACE TO BUILD UPON IT. IT'S
GOING TO BE CRITICAL IF YOU WANT
TO TRULY ADDRESS THAT ISSUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I TWENTY NOW THREE GO
AHEAD. A LINE TWENTY NINE
READING FROM A NOVEMBER TWENTY
THIRD CALIFORNIA GLOBE ARTICLE
BY KATIE CRIMES. WHY IS
HOMELESSNESS GROWING IN
CALIFORNIA BUT DECLINING IN
EVERY OTHER STATE IN THE COUNTRY
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO MORE THAN
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND PEOPLE NOW EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ACROSS THE STATE A
31% INCREASE FROM TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN ACCORDING TO THE
INDEPENDENT INSTITUTE FOR PUBLIC
POLICY RESEARCH AND EDUCATIONAL
ORGANIZATION. THE POSTER CHILD
OF HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA IS
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA I'M
WHICH HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS WILL NOT BE RESOLVED
UNTIL POLICY MAKERS AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS STOP RELYING ON
CONVENTIONAL APPROACHES WHICH WE
DO NOT WORK THE INDEPENDENT
INSTITUTE SAYS. THE CARD FOR
THIS TRAGIC INCREASE CAN BE
ATTRIBUTED TO PRIMARILY FAILING
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
POLICIES THAT HAVE FUELED
HOMELESSNESS THE INDEPENDENT
INSTITUTE SAYS. THIS INCLUDES
DIRECTING FUNDING ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY TO HOUSING FIRST A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH TO
HOMELESSNESS. USING THIS
APPROACH TOWARDS EVERY HOMELESS
INDIVIDUAL IN CALIFORNIA WOULD
BE PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE
SEVENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
AND STUDIES SHOW HOUSING FIRST
DOES NOT REDUCE HOMELESSNESS.
MEANWHILE AN IMMENSE GOVERNMENT
REGULATORY REGIME ON HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT ON HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT DISINCENTIVES AND
OBSTRUCTS THE BUILDING OF ALL
HOUSING DRIVING THE CRISIS IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. BEYOND
HOMELESSNESS GOOD INTENTIONS BAD
OUTCOMES TRANSFORMATIVE
SOLUTIONS. EXAMINES HOUSING
POLICY AND CONCLUDES THAT
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS MUST
BE RESOLVED NOT ONLY FOR THOSE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS BUT
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. COURT ALSO
SHOWS THAT SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
CAN BE MADE TOWARD RESOLVING
HOMELESSNESS MODERATOR EVEN INTO
YOU CAN ON THE LANDING HOUSING.
AT THE DATA WE HAVE ABOUT SEVEN
MORE IN Q. OKAY ARE LINE THIRTY
THANK YOU I'M NOT GOING TO BE A
LITTLE HIGHER- FOCUSED ON MAKING
SURE FOLKS MAINTAIN THE ONE
MINUTE. I REQUEST TO SPEAK GO
HEAD MODERATOR. THANK YOU I'M
THIRTY THREE. BACKHANDED MARINA
WYATT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM I'DLIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE CHAIR THE
NUMBERS TODAY YOU'VE BEEN MONTH
THE STATE'S PRIVATE CHAMPION FOR
DROPPING CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS CHALLENGES AND
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS WE'VE
MADE HUGE PROGRESS DEFINING AND
LAND USE POLICIES AS OUTLINED
EARLIER DURING THAT HEARING AND
TODAY ONE AFTER THE COMMENT MADE
ABOUT THE NEED FOR CONSISTENT
AND ONGOING FUNDING TO INCREASE
PRODUCTION FOR DESPERATELY
NEEDED AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AS
NOTED BY IN A SILVER BURKE MHP
WILL ISSUE ITS FINAL PROP ONE
FUNDED NO FOR THIS YEAR AND
ABSENT ANY MAJOR NEW INVESTMENT
INTO THIS PROGRAM THIS VITAL
PART OF THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TYPE WHEN WILL STYLE AND
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THAT AND
THE ACCELERATOR PROGRAM AS
OUTLINED BY MR SAVERS ARE
CRITICAL COMPONENTS TO ENSURE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO MAKE GREAT
PROGRESS TOWARD ENDING OUR
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY.
CHALLENGES YEAH. THANK YOU.
OPERATOR NEXT THANK YOU I THIRTY
THANK YOU I'M THIRTY TWO PLEASE
CALL. YES MY LIMITS REPRESENT
ACCOUNT COLLEGE FOR YEARS AND
WHEN I APPRECIATE LEGISLATURE
LEADERSHIP ADDRESS MANY OF OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. I DIDN'T THINK A
COUPLE QUESTIONS- RAPING HEARING
AND TALK ABOUT I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF DIFFERENT REASONS WHY
YOUNG PEOPLE AND ENSURING THE
PATHWAY FROM THE HOME OF MATH
AND TAKEN HALL HAVE A VOICE IN
THE ACCOUNT. THREE THIRTY-
REALLY DIVED INTO YOU A LOT OF
THE DIFFERENT- BECAUSE THERE'S
BEEN AND A CURRENT BOOK FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE BELIEVE THAT
PARTICULAR AROUND THOSE
IDENTIFIABLE DEFEAT HERE TO-
OKAY MAYBE PREGNANT PARENTS HANG
WORLD. URBAN CHALLENGE THAT I AM
THAT'S WILL THAT HAPPEN AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL I REALLY AROUND
ADDRESSING VULNERABILITIES FOR
ENTRY INTO THE EARTH THAT
THROUGH THE COORDINATED ENTRY
FOR THEM AND- AT. BACK PROVIDER
PROVIDE ARE GONNA AT WORK ON IN
THE KEEP MANAGEMENT. TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR YOUNG. AND TO HELP
. HOW THAT ARE YOU KNOW AND IT.
APPROACH AND WHAT DOES NOT THAT
UP UNTIL MAYBE FIVE AGO DIDN'T
REALLY HAVE AN CAN. WE FOR THIS
FOR ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS REQUEST
OUR YOUNG TO TAKE COMMITMENT
THEN JUST UNDER G. FOR ALMOST
FOUR YEARS ME AND NOTING. WE
HAVE BEEN GROWING IN THE-
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS- POPULAR IN
A STATEMENT THAT WOULD ADMIT HE
CAN DO TO THE OUR YOUNG WE CAN
OUT OF THE LONG RUN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT CAR. THANK YOU
I'M FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
THREE SEVEN. IT'S BETTER YEAH
PLEASE LET. I HAVE BEEN BLESSED
TO HAVE. HE LIVES TO THE SPOT.
HELLO HELLO. YOU CAN. BACK TO
THE- SO THAT THE PUBLIC COMMENT
IS FOR YOU TO PROVIDE COMMENT
BUT WE DON'T REALLY RESPOND THIS
IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE OR
COMMENTS BUT JUST KNOW THAT THE
PANELISTS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
RESPOND NORMAL IRANICA MANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BUT THIS IS
CERTAINLY YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO
PUT YOUR QUESTIONS ON THE RECORD
. OKAY AND NOW THAT THEY'VE THE
STATE'S CORPORATION FOR. HELLO
ANGELES AND I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
SAY I WELL QUOTABLE BE DOING ON
CONTINUED UP. THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK CALLER. THANK YOU LINE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BURY
FORMER FOSTER IN AB. WHO WAS
ONCE HOMELESS AND AS AN
ADOLESCENT MY EXPERIENCE LIKE
MANY OTHERS WAS OF COURSE
TRAUMATIZING AND AT TIMES IT
FELT VERY HOPELESS. FOCUSED
EFFORTS TO SUPPORT HOMELESS
YOUTH IS WHAT BRIDGES THE GAP TO
HELP I AM N SUPPORT OF THE
STATE'S CURRENT APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING YOUTH HOMELESSNESS BY
ESTABLISHING SATISFIED IN
MAINSTREAM HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS
OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS
INCLUDING KEEP UP IN HOME HERE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PREVIOUS
EFFORTS AND I URGE THE MOMENTUM
TO CONTINUE SUPPORT FOR AN
ONGOING INVESTMENT AND HAPPY
WITH HOW THE TEMPLATE THAT YOU
SET ASIDE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU I'M
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS DONNA KANE AND I'M
CALLING FROM THE LOS ANGELES
HOMELESS SERVICES AUTHORITY ALSO
KNOWN AS LHASA WE ARE THE LEAD
ENTITY FOR THE LOS ANGELES
CONTINUOUS CARE THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR AND FOR THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR MAKING THE SPACES
HOMELESSNESS TODAY. WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT ON GOING FUNDING FOR
HOMELESS SERVICES IN ORDER TO
ADEQUATELY SCALE OF THE CAPACITY
OF ALMOST EVERYTHING FROM WE
CANNOTKEEP LOOKING AT ONE TIME
FUNDING RESOURCES. ONE HAVE
FUNDING SOURCES THAT CHANGED THE
ELIGIBILITY FUNDING AND I'LL
COME EVERY YEAR WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE AT THE COMMITTEE
CONSIDERS INVESTMENTS IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET THE NEED FOR A
LARGE INFUSION OF RENTAL
ASSISTANCE FUNDING. WE CAN MOVE
PEOPLE INTO HOUSING TODAY WITH
RENTAL ASSISTANCE FUNDING
ADDITIONALLY THERE IS A NEED FOR
HOUSING NAVIGATION AND UNIT
ACQUISITION FUNDING TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO ACCESS
AVAILABLE RENTAL UNITS. FINALLY
WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO LOOK AT FUNDING TO
SUPPORT THE WORKFORCE OF THE
HOMELESS SERVICES SYSTEM OUR
ABILITY TO END HOMELESSNESS IS
ONLY AS STRONG AS A SERVICE
PROVIDERS WE HAVE ON THE GROUND
AND THEY NEED RESOURCES TO
ATTRACT AND RETAIN GOOD STAFF
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MODERATOR
HOW MANY COLORS. ARE LEFT IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU I HAVE LIVE.
OKAY THANK YOU. BY FORTY ONE GO
OUT. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARES
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES MY
NAME IS ANDY LAMELLAE AND I WORK
FOR JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR
YOUTH WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
STATE'S CURRENT APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING YOUTH HOMELESSNESS BY
ESTABLISHING SATISFIED IN
MAINSTREAM HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS. OVER THE LAST FOUR
YEARS INCLUDING HE HAPPENED HOME
KEEP JB HAS DEVELOPED THREE
REPORT ANALYZING THE IMPACT OF
YOU SATISFIED IN KEEPING HAPPEN
THESE REPORTS ABOUT THE
CERTIFIED APPROACH HAS EEN
EFFECTIVE FOR SEVERAL REASONS
ONE IT INCREASED INVESTMENT IN
YOUTH ALMOST. TO GET INTEGRATED
YOU INTO LOCAL ALMOST WAS
SPONSORED NETWORK THREE IT
INCREASED LOCAL UNDERSTANDING
AND AWARENESS OF YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS FOR IT EXPANDED THE
CONTINUUM OF HOUSING OPTIONS FOR
YOU AND FIVE LOCAL COMMUNITY
SUPPORT YOU SATISFIED. THANK YOU
FOR THE TREMENDOUS INVESTMENT TO
DATE AND FOR BEING A CHAMPION
FOR CALIFORNIA'S YOUTH AND YOUNG
ADULTS WE ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO BUILD THIS
MOMENTUM I CONSIDER HOW WE CAN
CONTINUE TO IMPORT INVESTMENTS
MOVING FORWARD POTENTIALLY.
MAKING THEM ONGOING INVESTMENT.
THANK YOU MODERATOR NEXT CALLER
. THANK YOU I'M FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION AND IT'S HEALTHY
HOUSING FOUNDATION WHICH IS
CREATED ABOUT THIRTEEN POUNDS
THIRTEEN HUNDRED UNITS OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS FOR.
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE EXTREMELY
AND VERY LOW INCOME WE
APPRECIATE THE EFFORT OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR TO
DIRECT FUNDS TO ADDRESS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS I'M WE PARTICULARLY
KNOWLEDGE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THIS YEAR TO PUT A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OVER TWO
YEARS INTO ADAPTIVE REUSE OF
EXISTING PROPERTIES SUCH CREATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. OVER THE
PAST THREE YEARS H. F. AS IN
CALLING ATTENTION TO THE NEED TO
EMPHASIZE ADAPTIVE REUSE OTHER
PROMINENT AND PERMANENT
MECHANISM FOR PROVIDING HOUSING
TO CALIFORNIA'S INCOME IS LESS
THAN 50% OF THE AREA MEDIAN
INCOME. BUT MILLION UNITS NEEDED
FOR VERY LOW INCOME PEOPLE IN
OUR STATE AND WITH THE COST-
EXCEEDING FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER UNIT WE CANNOT
CONSTRUCT OURSELVES OUT OF THIS
CRISIS WE NEED MORE QUESTIONS
AND WELL FUNDED. EFFORTS TO
EXPAND ADAPTIVE REUSE AND OTHER
DEVELOPMENT OPTIONS LIKE MODULAR
HOUSING THAT CAN COST AS LITTLE
AS A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER UNIT AGE OF URGES THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO TWO THINGS
INCREASE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR IT AFTER USE ABOUT THE
CURRENT ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL OVER TWO YEARS.
AND NUMBER TO DIRECT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO GIVE
GREATER ATTENTION TO ADAPTIVE
REUSE PROJECTS WHEN GRANTING
STATE FUNDS IN THE LAST CYCLE
ONLY THREE ADAPTIVE REUSE
PROJECTS WERE APPROVED OUT OF
NINETY TWO PROJECT OVERALL. WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MATTER
AS THOSE ALL THE CALLER. I DO
HAVE ONE MORE THAT CAME IN HERE
BY FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES HELLO THANK YOU FOR TAKING
MY CALL FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO
MENTION THAT THESE CALLS THAT WE
CALLED INTO. ARE NOT THE DRESS
WAS BY CITIZENS BY PRESSING ONE
ZERO POUND I'M TELLING PEOPLE
WHEN THEY CALL LAND CA PRESS ONE
ZERO POUND BECAUSE- THE PHONE IS
NOT ADDRESSING THAT TO PEOPLE
THAT CLEAR SO WE'RE NOT GETTING
OUR VOICES HEARD. THE PHONE
SYSTEM IS NOT WORKING FIRST OF
ALL SECOND OF ALL ABOUT THE
HOMELESS SITUATION I'VE BEEN A
BUSINESS OWNER HERE IN DOWNTOWN
FACT TWENTY YEARS I'VE SEEN. A
LOT OF THE BUSINESSES. BEING
AFFECTED BY THE HOMELESSNESS I
AM VERY EMPATHETIC TO HOMELESS
PEOPLE I CAN ADDRESS THREE
DIFFERENT THINGS FIRST OF ALL
THE HOME THE HOUSING IS NOT. THE
ANSWER. THERE ARE THREE THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO CONSIDER. THE
MENTALLY ILL. DEPRESSION AND
THEY HAVE NO WORK. I WE COP. HOW
OTHER PEOPLE DO THE THINGS WITH
THE HOMELESS. GOOD THINGS. ONE
NINETEEN COPY IT LEARN FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES WHEN THEY SEE
OTHER HOMELESS PEOPLE ON THE
STREET WHETHER THEY DO. OFFER TO
HELP THEM FIND A JOB. OKAY WE
NEED TO OFFER PEOPLE TO HELP
THEM FIND JOBS MA'AM YOU'RE A
NUMBER OF MONEY THEY LIKE TO
WRAP UP YOUR COMMENTS. WELL THE
HOUSING THE WEEK THE MONEY
BASICALLY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY OTHER
CALLERS IN THE QUEUE. I DO HAVE
ONE MORE IN Q. LINE FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU THANK
YOU CAN HAVE MY YOUR BILL AND A
CITY COUCIL MEMBER I WANT TO
THANK THE PREVIOUS CALLER FOR
TELLING ME HOW TO USE MY PHONE.
IMPLIED THE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER- PUTTING MORE FUNDING
TOWARD TRANSITIONAL HOUSING-
THERE WAS A HARVARD STUDY THAT
WAS DONE SEVERAL YEARS AGO
SHOWING BAD HE DOESN'T
INVESTMENT IN HOUSING- FOR A
JACKET FOR PROSECCO AGAIN. CAN
REACH YOU BUT- HOMELESS
POPULATION APPROXIMATELY A THIRD
OF THE STUDENTS OF THE PROJECT.
AND EXITING THE HOME- FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM WILL BECOME HOME ONE
IN CALIFORNIA THAT WOULD
TRANSLATE TO ABOUT TWELVE
THOUSAND CAN'T AUTOMATICALLY
BECOMING HOMELESS. IF WE WANT TO
STOP HOMELESSNESS LEGALLY ONE TO
REALLY TAKE CARE OF OUR KIDS WE
NEED TO M. VAST AMOUNTS AND
INVEST IN THEM TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING STARTING AT THE AGE OF
TWELVE. TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
TRANSITIONAL POSSIBLY GIVE
PROGRAM REALLY COMING FALL
AMOUNT THAT IT TAKES SO THAT WE
CAN STOCK ON THE MAP- AT LEAST A
PORTION OF THAT POPULATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
MODERATOR THERE ANYMORE FOLKS IN
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FOR COMMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH SO SENATOR WIENER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO ANYTHING WE ARE AS A
HERE. THANK YOU A MANAGER- NO I
JUST WANT TO THANK EVERYONE IT
JUST CREATED TODAY- WE'RE GOING
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK ON OUR
STATE IN TERMS OF FINDING.
STREAMLINING WRITTEN SERVICE
PROJECTS TO MOVE FORWARD MAKING
SURE. THAT WE ARE SUPPORTING OUR
AT RISK YOUTH- ARE UNNATURAL.
THIS YEAR IN TERMS OF. FUNDING
BECAUSE MOST CHINESE DON'T HAVE
YOUR SPECIFIC HOMELESS PROGRAMS
AND SO THE STATE NEEDS TO STEP
IN AND DO MORE. FOR OUR USE BOB
IT'S BEEN REALLY HELPFUL HEARING
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO THE WORK.
HAD THIS YEAR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE AYE AND THIS IS BEEN MOST
IN FORM AND IT AS MANY OF US
HAVE- EXPRESSED AND HEARD FROM
PANELISTS IT'S NOT SO MUCH ABOUT
THE MONEY IT'S ABOUT THE POLICY
pMAKING SURE THAT WE ARE A STATE
THAT BRIDGES THE GAP AND GETS
OUT OF THE WAY SO THAT OUR
LOCALS- CAN DO THE WORK THAT
THEY ARE SEEING IS NEEDED TO BE
DONE- THROUGHOUT A DISTRICTS AND
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE.
OBVIOUSLY WITH STREAMLINED
ACCOUNTABILITY SO THAT EVERY
PENNY THAT WE HAVE IS BEING USED
MOST EFFECTIVELY TO GET FOLKS
OFF THE STREETS. WITH THAT WE
WILL NOW ADJOURN AS A JOINT
HEARING WE WILL TAKE A BRIEF
FIVE MINUTE RECESS AND THEN
RECONVENE AS A BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE.